I'M GONNA GOING ON. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WELCOME TO THIS
MORNING'S ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING WE
HAVE NINETEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
HEARING AGENDA INCLUDING THE
FOLLOWING FIVE BILLS ON CONSENT
THE B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE
RUBIO AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THE
LACKEY THE TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
FOUR POWER QUE HAN AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT COOLEY AND AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SIX BY WHICH
THE COMMITTEE BILL AND THE
COMMITTEE IS ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. FOR EACH
BILL HER TODAY WILL BE ALLOWING
PRIMARY WITNESSES TO SPEAK FOR
UP TO TWO MINUTES EACH WITH UP
TO TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES PER
SIDE FOR THOSE WISHING TO
PROVIDE FURTHER COMMENTS WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE IN ADDITION TO HEARING
FROM THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM
TODAY WILL BE USING AND
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALLING
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE
ZERO ZERO AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE
ZERO ZERO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON TV. IF YOU
WERE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION OUT WITH
THAT SAID IT WILL BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING MY STAFF IS KILEY LEFT
ME A NOTE SUGGESTING I'M NOT
COSTS DURING TODAY'S HEARING- SO
WE- DON'T HAVE ANY AUTHORS HERE
IN THE ROOM SO I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD OF ITS ARE WITH THE VICE
CHAIR. IN PRESENT HE- SINCE THE
- MOST READ ANOTHER COMING IN.
OKAY ALL RIGHT MISTER GIBSON
PERFECT TIMING AS ALWAYS. YOUR
UP SIR AGENDA ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO.
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WE ARE
OPERATING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO
WE SHALL NOT BE TAKING VOTES.
YET. YES SIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT A SIX- A BILL
SIXTEENTH TWO WITH SIX TO
PROVIDE AN EARLY. ON IN.
CRIMINAL RECORD WILL DISQUALIFY
THEM FROM OBTAINING AN OP AND AN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE B. FOUR
UNDERSCORE BEFORE THEY INVEST IN
EXPENSIVE TRAINING AND EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS. BEFORE I BEGIN I
WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
CONSULTANTS WORKING WITH- MY
TEAM OR TO MAKE THIS BILL
BETTER- HAVING A CRIMINAL RECORD
CAN. MAKE IT DIFFICULT OR EVEN
IMPOSSIBLE FOR INDIVIDUAL TO
ENTER TO THE WORK FORCE
EXPRESSLY. IN A FIELD THAT
REQUIRES AN OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE
WHEN EXAMINING- OTHER STATES
THAT REQUIRE THE MOST OCCUPY
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING
CALIFORNIA RANKS AMONG THE
HIGHEST IN THE COUNTRY WITH VERY
STRANGE IT ARBAB REQUIREMENTS
HOWEVER. OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PROVISIONS OF THE STATE LAW
LIMITS ACCESS TO LICENSE FOR
PEOPLE WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS
ACCORDING TO A REPORT PUBLISHED
BY THE INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE
REQUIREMENTS TO OBTAIN LICENSE
ARE AMONG THE MOST RIGOROUS
BASED ON HIGH COST AND LENGTHY
EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS OFTEN FACE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS THAT
DISCOURAGE AND EXCLUDE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO PAY UP FOR IT
LICENSE LOOKING AND SEEKING FOR
JOBS PEOPLE THAT ARE REJECTED
FROM EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO FALL INTO THE
CYCLE OF CRIME MEMBERS IRATE I
REPRESENTS A COMMUNITY ONE OF
THE POOREST- DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF
THE MAIN BARRIERS THAT PEOPLE.
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS TO FACE
WHEN TRYING TO APPLY FOR A
LICENSE PROFESSIONAL IS
EXPENSIVE TUITION THAT COMES
WITH EXPENSIVE TRAINING COURSES
THIS MEANS TIME AND MONEY. WITH. WITH THE MOST CARE. IN GET
DISCOURAGE AND FEEL HELPLESS AS
A RESULT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS ON PROGRAMS THAT COULD
TAKE MONTHS AND SOMETIMES YEARS
IN ORDER TO COMPLETE JUST TO
FIND OUT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DENIED DUE TO THEIR CRIMINAL
RECORD. THIS BECAUSE THOSE. ARE
NOT TO BE REHABILITATED- IT ALSO
SEEMS LIKE FUTURE IS ADDED IN.
LET BE CLEAR. THIS IS AN AUNT
POOL OF JOBS TALENT INDIVIDUALS
HAVE TO CAN. IN A VERY POSITIVE
WAY IN OUR SOCIETY BY HAVING HIS
. OF WITH VERY. AT A VERY BASIC
TIME THE LIVES THIS IS ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES AND HOPE LET ME
UNDERSCORE IT'S ABOUT
OPPORTUNITY AND HOPE FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AND PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY
DESERVE A SECOND CHANCE A
CRIMINAL RECORD SHOULD NOT BE A
LIFE SENTENCE. FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
AND POVERTY LICENSE JOB FOR
INSTANCE COSMETOLOGY- BARBERING-
A- OF FEEL- JUST TO NAME A FEW
OF INDIVIDUALS OR INDIVIDUALS
TRIED TO SEEK AN OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE- AFTER THEY'VE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED AND PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY ARE HELD
BACK. FROM THESE OPPORTUNITIES
AND FROM HOPE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
TWO IS FOCUSED ON GETTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK IMPROVING ACCESS TO
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS AND
ELIMINATING BARRIERS THAT KEEP
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE GOING
THROUGH THE RE ENTRY PROCESS
FROM OBTAINING AN OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE JOINING ME. IN SUPPORT
OF SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO IS A
REPRESENTATIVE BY NAME OF COREY
JOHNSON FROM THE COUNCIL OF
STATE GOVERNMENT WHO WOULD
TESTIFY ALONG WITH. MARGO WHAT'S
FORMALLY- INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO INDIVIDUAL WHO
OVER MANY OBSTACLES BEFORE BIG
BEFORE OBTAINING A REAL ESTATE
LICENSE AS AN AGENT WHO WILL
SHARE HIS STORY. THE FIRST ONE
UP AS MR JOHNSON. GREAT OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY I BELIEVE
YOU SAID MISTER JOHNSON'S
TESTIFYING BEFORE JOHNSON YES-
SO- I'VE GIVE CANARY IF CORY
JOHNSON'S AVAILABLE THE GREAT.
SHE'S AT THIS TIME THANK
GOODNESS BECAUSE A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY. NO YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY FINE GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GETS
SENT AND YOUR STAFF TO INCLUDE
BRENDA CONTRARIS FOR THE TIMELY
AND NECESSARY LEGISLATION MY
NAME IS CORY JOHNSON AND I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST AND
ATTORNEY AT THE COUNCIL OF STATE
GOVERNMENTS THAT THE CENTER I
WHICH IS THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ARM OF THE COUNCIL STATE
GOVERNMENT ALSO KNOWN AS THE
EXTREME. FIFTY S. T. JUSTICE
CENTER FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE NATIONAL NONPROFIT ON
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION THAT
COMBINES THE POWER OF THE
MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING STATE OFFICIALS ON
ALL THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT- WHAT POLICY AND
RESEARCH EXPERTISE TO DEVELOP
STRATEGIES THAT INCREASE PUBLIC
SAFETY IN STRENGTHENING
COMMUNITIES I THURMOND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY TEAM AND OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
BOTH HAVE ACCESS TO MEANINGFUL
ON JOB OPPORTUNITIES WHO
CONVICTION- INPUT INCARCERATE.
IN THE STATE OF UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES AT THE JUSTICE CENTER
IT'S MORE FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING
FACING ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND JOB
CREATION OF PROJECT IMPACT IT
INDIVIDUALS ABSENT FROM ON GIVE
THANKS MEANT COMMITTEE. BASED
OCCUPATION LIKE ARE CALM ACROSS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THEY CAN
PRODUCE VERY HARMFUL OUTCOMES AT
BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL
BY CONTRIBUTING TO RECIDIVISM I
THINK ALIVE IN COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES AND DEPRESSING ECONOMIC
GROWTH- THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
LAUNCHED OUR NATIONAL INITIATIVE
TO SUPPORT STATE. AND ADOPTING
BEST PRACTICES TO REDUCE THE
OCCUPATIONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING FOR PEOPLE WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS- OCCUPATIONAL
AND PROFESSIONAL LICENSING CAN
BE A PATHWAY AT THE CAREERS THAT
THE PORT FAMILIES AND TRY
ECONOMIC WORLD- IN RECENT YEARS
THE MAJORITY OF US STATES HAVE
ENACTED AN EXPANDED ROBUST
OCCUPATIONAL. LICENSING POLICIES. DESIGN HELLO BARRIERS TO WORK
FOR PEOPLE WITH CRIMINAL RECORD
WALKING. TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY THESE POWER ARE BASED ON
THREE PRINCIPLES OF. ONE THAT
LIKE BY SHOULD NOT SHOULD NOT
HAVE USED TO DO APPLICANTS WERE
PASSED IN BIG FAN DIRECTLY
RELATED THE TAX IN BEAUTY OF THE
LIKENESS ACTIVITY. TO THAT
WORKERS NOT BE FROM ON. LICENSE
ONLY THE BASIS OF THE PACT AND
DICTION AND THREE. BOX IMPACT
AND TO. ABOUT CRIMINAL. OF
APPLICANTS SHOULD BE TRANSPARENT
AND CONSISTENTLY APPLIED ON
ATHLETES ACROSS THE NATION FOCUS
ON ECONOMIC RECOVERY- I WOULD
LIKE TO COMMEND CALIFORNIA. FOR
NEEDING AND PAVING THE WAY I
THINK THE TYPICALLY WITH THE
PACKING OF YOU ALL LEGISLATION
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY
REQUIRES INDIVIDUALIZED
CONSIDERATION OF APPLE CAN'T
CRIMINAL HISTORY WHILE ALSO
ALLOWING- WE WAIT FOR INTO. FEW
ARE APPEAL CERTAINTY IN THE
PROCESS AB THINK THINK TWO BILL
UPON EXISTING LAW- WE ALREADY IN
SOME THE FUNDING TO PRINT THANK.
A PRE. PROCESS AND NOT
AUTHORIZING A PRE APPLICATION
ELIGIBILITY. FOR PERSPECTIVE
APPLICANTS I DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER
THEIR RECORD IS DISQUALIFYING
BEFORE INVESTING HI AND THE-
INTO TRAIN AND EDUCATION OTHER.
IS INACTIVE- PUMP IN THE PULL
MANNER ONE. RADICAL ON AND THAT
WOULD. ABSOLUTE CAN'T ALMOST I
THINK SOME- BECOME WHO CALLED ME
A ONE ACT WILL NOT AND- SELF
DEFENSE. INTO APPLE WILL NOT WE
TIME AND RESOURCES FOR LICENSE
THAT THEY MAY NOT QUALIFY FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES I WE HAVE A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT RESOURCES IF
ANYONE HAS ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THE OCCUPATIONAL LICENSURE
PROJECT. ON AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR QUESTION THANKS THANKS
SO. MUCH MISS JOHNSON MISTER
WHAT'S- GOOD MORNING. I REMEMBER
THAT IS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MAN
I'M ALIVE BAR LICENSE ESTATE A
AND OWNER OF A CORPORATION AND
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT I WAS
CONVICTED OF A CRIME I HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH
AND SENTENCED TO FIFTEEN YEARS
OF WHICH I SERVED. THIRTEEN
YEARS. THIS RELEASE FROM
INCARCERATION IN FEBRUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. OUR SECURITY
MAINTAIN TWO JOBS. COMPLETED
THREE YEARS OF HIGH RES PAROLE
WITHOUT ANY IN KIND OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PAY TAXES PAID OFF
CHILD SUPPORT IT ACCUMULATED
WHILE I WAS INCARCERATED. IN
ACTIVELY INVOLVED WITH MY FAMILY
AND OVERALL BEEN A PRODUCTIVE
MEMBER OF SOCIETY. UNFORTUNATELY
IN CALIFORNIA THE ONLY THING
THAT SEEMS TO MATTER IS A
CONVICTION IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND
ITS TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWO.
WHEN SUBMIT AN APPLICATION FOR
MY BAR EXAM I WAS REQUIRED TO
WRITE A DISCLOSURE STATEMENT.
GIVEN A DETAILED ACCOUNT OF A
CRIME THAT I SAID I HAD
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH. I
WAS INSTRUCTED TO LIST THE WHO
WHERE WHY HOW X. CETERA OF
SOMETHING THAT THE CURATORS IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. I WAS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE PROOF OF
REHABILITATION. I WAS REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE THE ABOVE LISTED
INFORMATION AGAIN. WITH MY STAB
LISTENING LICENSE PROCESS I WAS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE TO BOTH
LISTED INFORMATION AGAIN WHEN I
SUBMITTED A CHANGE OF ADDRESS
FOR MY STATUS IN THE LICENSE
WHICH WASN'T EVEN EXPIRED YET.
IT DOESN'T EXPIRE NEXT YEAR BY
THE WAY- AFTER I PASSED THE REAL
ESTATE SALESPERSON EXAM I
SUBMITTED MY APPLICATION AND I
WAS ESSENTIALLY PUT ON FILE. MY
APPLICATION WAS WALKED ALL THE
WAY TO THE COMMISSIONER. AND THE
NIGHT FOR UNRESTRICTED LICENSE.
I WAS GIVE THE LEGAL DOT CALL
THE STATE BILL IN WAIVER. THAT
STATED THAT I WOULD ACCEPT A
RESTRICTED LICENSE. AND IT WOULD
BE CONSIDERED QUOTE DISCIPLINE.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE. I PASSED A REAL ESTATE EXAM
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND I
RECEIVED MY RESTRICTED LICENSE
IN JANUARY THIRTEENTH OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. THERE HAS
TO BE A BETTER APPROACH TO
HELPING HUMAN BEINGS REENTER
SOCIETY AND BECOME LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS. HOW CAN A PERSON
TRULY MOVE FORWARD WHEN THE
LICENSING DIVISION OF EVERY
DEPARTMENT IMPERIAL CAN'T SEE
BEYOND THE PAST. THIS BILL AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO IS THE BETTER
APPROACH TO HELPING HUMAN BEINGS
WITH PAST CONVICTIONS BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF BECOMING A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL. BUT DOES HAVING
LIMITED RESOURCES IN BEING IN A
VERY TIME SENSITIVE SITUATION
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU WILL HELP
REDUCE THE MISALLOCATION OF TIME
AND RESOURCES. HOW MANY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ARE STILL
PEOPLE AND MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE THEIR
PROFESSIONAL GOALS. ARE YOUR A
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
MISTER WANTS PROCEDURE TESTIMONY
I WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO ANY
PRIMER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
DON'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SO LET'S OPEN IT
UP TO ANY- IF FOLKS WANT TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AGAIN THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOUR
NAME. AND ORGANIZATION YOU'RE
WITH IF ANY IN YOUR POSITION
SUPPORT FOR OPPOSED TO THE BILL
LET'S START WITH FOLKS HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM DOES ANYBODY
WANT TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. I WANT
TO DIE TO THE MIKE RIGHT APPEAR. THIS FOR A BI SIXTEEN SIXTY
TWO. MY NAME IS RACHEL GATES-
ORANGE COUNTY I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AS
FUNDING AS WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WANT TO ADD
ON- A SINGLE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT'S OPEN THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR CAN YOU IDENTIFY
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO. HEY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR- AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO. AND ONE
MOMENT. WE DO HAVE ONE FOR
ANYBODY ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO.
THIS PATIENTS ARE ARE MISTER
CHAIR THAT UP ONE SHOULD BE WITH
THE IN THE SECOND THAT'S GREAT
THANKS SO MUCH. AND WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR MORE THAN ANYONE
. THERE GO GO. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BROWN A MEDICAL
OF WE HAVE A SUPPORT IS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL TO ENSURE
THE PORTS COSTS ARE COVERED BY
SUFFICIENCY IN THE CLEAR THESE
DETERMINATIONS ARE NOT BINDING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
FOUR DID YOU NOT YET THAT. HI
THIS IS VIRGIL GRANT FROM UP
CALIFORNIA MINORITY ALLIANCE I'M
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. I LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC WHILE I
MAYES OF MULTI SPOT OWNER HERE
IN ORANGE COUNTY- COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE OWNER
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY SCHOOL OF
MASSAGE AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. A LINE.
I'M NOT A BIG DIFFERENCE OUTSIDE
ANYBODY ELSE IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FILE BIGGER AGAIN WE'RE ON A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO. AND WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER ONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR.
ANYBODY THERE. YES THEY ARE
STILL WITH THE OPERATOR OKAY
GOTCHA THANKS. OKAY THEY SHOULD
BE WITH US IN THE SECOND IMAGE
HAD A QUESTION I APOLOGIZE NO
PROBLEM WITH THIS MOMENT.
ANYBODY ELSE UP PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
FOR A BI SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO OF
THE FINAL REMINDER AND NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR OPEN THANK YOU.
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ALBERT GIORDANO FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SB SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SUPPORT ALL OR
OPPOSITION ALL AT ONCE LASKO.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR ABC
I SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AND- WE DO OUR TO
QUEUING UP AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE. FIFTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
SORRY MY APOLOGIES I JUMPED ON
OF THAT MAY I AND I HAVE- NOT
NOT OF LEICESTERSHIRE THIS IS
ERIC LAW WITH ORANGE COUNTY
THANK YOU THAT'S A DIFFERENT
BILL YOU DIFFERENT BILL THAT'S A
DIFFERENT BILL WILL BE HEARING A
LITTLE LATER ANY ACTING THANKS
SO MUCH STAY TUNED I APOLOGIZE
NO PROBLEM AT ALL. THANKS LINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BRENT MY NAME
IS JESSICA DETERMINE AND THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD THE
BOARD UNDERSTANDS AND
APPRECIATES THE INTENT OF A
DIFFICULT THING TO YOU BUT YOU
TO BE UNAVAILABLE WILL.
ASSOCIATED COSTS TO PUT NATURE
OF INVESTOR AND POTENTIAL FOR
DEBRIS DETERMINATION ONCE THE
APPLICANT APPLY FOR LIFE AND SO
YOU'RE POSTED NOW OKAY THANKS
REMEMBER- JUST NAME ORGANIZATION. AND SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
ANYONE ELSE IN. WE DO HAVE ONE-
ONE FIFTY SEX OR FIFTY SIX
PLEASED AHEAD THANK YOU. HELLO
THIS IS THE STORY IS THIS TO
BILL FOR CANNABIS NO THAT'S NOT
THIS ON THE CANNABIS BILL. NOPE
THAT'LL BE LATER WE'RE GONNA
CALTRAIN IS REMOVING THANK YOU
FOR SIGNING SO MUCH TO. WE HAVE
ADJUSTED THE KEY ART RIGHT BRING
ABOUT THE CALL QUESTION COMMENTS
WE DON'T OF A QUORUM YET WE WILL
BE TAKING A VOTE WE DO. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
FINE MISTER GIBSON ON THE BILL.
SEEING NONE MICHIGAN'S WE LIKE
TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK- MISTER WATTS WHO I
SHOULD TO USE YOU THIS MORNING.
I'M AT THE BAR BECAUSE ACT NICK
MY HIT UP HERE AT THE TOP. NOT
WHICH SHOWS YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
DOING- BUT NOT ALL I'M SERIOUS
ONE THINK MISS TO WATCH FOR WHEN
HIS TESTIMONY ALSO MISS JOHNSON
FROM C. AS G. THIS. IS ABOUT
GIVING PEOPLE A SECOND CHANCE
THIS IS ABOUT ONE- I'LL BE
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION TO TRY
TO REMOVE IT OPPOSITION THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD. BUT ALSO
THIS IS ABOUT INDIVIDUALS WHO
PAY THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY GIVE
THEM OPPORTUNITY RIDE A NEW.
NARRATIVE FOR THE LIVES MOVING
FORWARD THIS IS NOT THE END OF
THEIR STORY. AND I THINK TODAY
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR STORY DOES NOT
END BY CONTINUE. TO ADD TO- THE
VERY FABRIC OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY GIVING THEM
OPPORTUNITY TO USE A SCHOOL. USE
THIS THE SKILL SET- WHICH
THEY'VE LEARNED TO TRY TO BETTER
THEMSELVES AND ALSO. TO CITIZENS
I'M WHO ARE SOCIETY THIS BILL IS
A COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT
WOULD PUT CALIFORNIA AT THE
FOREFRONT. AND IN LINE WITH
TWENTY OTHER STATES. THAT HAVE
ALREADY ADVANCED SIMILAR
POLICIES AND I. AND I WANT TO
LIKE. TO THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
ABOUT GIVING INDIVIDUALS SECOND
CHANCE ONCE AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK BUT I VOTE. ON IT ASSEMBLY
BILL SICK. SIXTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER GIBSON AND THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS TO
EXPAND ON THE LANGUAGE TO ME THE
BILL'S INTENT. I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- AS
AMENDED ONE OF AYE
RECOMMENDATION ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THE TAKE A VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY MOVING ON I DON'T. IF.
AUTHOR IN THE ROOM TO HAVE ANY
OTHERS IN THE ROOM. IT'S ON THE
RUN THROUGH THE CENTER BILLS
OKAY. GET ANY AUTHORS.
MISTER CHAIR WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO
WHEN WE START WITH A FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
BOARD SUNSET. A HERE CHEERING
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
PRESENT- PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY ONE OF RELATING TO THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ONE OF THE FIVE CENTS A
BILLS BEING PER TODAY. THE
SUNSET BILLS WILL CARRY. THE
SENSIBLE CARE RECOMMENDATIONS
DEVELOPED THROUGH OUR ONGOING
SINCE THE REVIEW PROCESS AS WELL
AS EXTEND THE BOARDS. THAT ARE
SET TO WRITTEN THAT ARE SET TO
REPEAL. THIS BILL CURRENTLY ONLY
MAKES ONE TECHNICAL CHANGE BUT
THE RECOMMENDED SUNSET
AMENDMENTS ALSO ALLOW
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST TO FORM
THEIR OWN PROFESSIONAL
CORPORATIONS CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER SIMILARLY SITUATED
PROFESSIONS. ALLOW OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST A SERVICE SHAREHOLDERS
IN MEDICAL CORPORATIONS. EXTEND
THE BOARD BY FOUR YEARS AND MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES ON THE
PHONE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS
HEATHER MARTIN EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE BOARD- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ONCE WE HAVE
A QUORUM TO TAKE VOTES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF. THE MARTIN DO
I HAVE ANYTHING TO SAY WE JUST
WANNA BE ON THE PHONE FOR
TECHNICAL. QUESTIONS. WE'LL TAKE
THAT AS OF TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT WORKS THE OTHER SUPPORT AND
AGAIN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. C.
NINE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. C. NINE MISTER
MODERATE DO WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT
AND OR OPPOSITION TO THE SUNSET
BILL AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU ARE
AND NOT SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
RIGHT TO TWENTY SIX OR TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND HIT.
STAR FOLLOWED BY ONE AT THIS
TIME. DID YOU WANT BOTH MISTER
CHAIR YES SIR. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE WANTED TO DEBT IS TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY ARMY YEAH. TWENTY
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND- WE DO WELL WE'RE
LIKE SEVENTY YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS JENNIFER SNYDER
REPRESENTING OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND A
FINAL REMINDER TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
MR CHAU NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
XENON MISTER CHURCH ARTICLES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I GO TO THE
RIGHT TIME FOR DATA THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO FILE A NUMBER
FOURTEEN RIGHT I RESPECTFULLY
PRESENTED THE NEXT SUNSET BILL
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR
RELATING TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. THIS BILL
CURRENTLY ONLY MAKES ONE
TECHNICAL CHANGE BUT THE
RECOMMENDED SUNSET AND IT'S ALSO
ESTABLISH AS A STARTING POINT A
NEW EDUCATION COMMITTEE WITHIN
THE BOARD. REQUIRE THE BOARD'S
NURSING EDUCATION CONSULTANTS TO
APPROVE REQUESTS IN A CONSISTENT
AND TRANSPARENT MANNER. PROHIBIT
PAYMENTS FOR CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
AND EXTEND THE CODE NINETEEN
FLEXIBILITIES BY ONE YEAR. I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT OUR
REVIEW IS ONGOING AND THESE
AMENDMENTS ONLY MARKED THE START
OF A LONGER CONVERSATION BETWEEN
THIS COMMITTEE THE SENATE BMP
COMMITTEE THE BOARD AND
STAKEHOLDERS. ON THE PHONE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS- IS LORETTA
MELBY EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
BOARD AND I WILL RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THE RIGHT
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHAT
WOULD YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON A
ON THE PHONE AT THIS TIME. RIGHT
ANY COMMENTS- SUPPORT FROM THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. CNN ANY
OPPOSITION TO COMMITTEE ROOM. IT
ALSO- INTO THE SPORT PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JUDY
CORELESS ARE PROBABLY SERVED AS
A MEMBER OF THE BE OUR OWN UNDER
OUR SCHWARZENEGGER AND BROWN
ADMINISTRATIONS I'M HERE TODAY
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND
SHARE WITH YOU THE PROFOUND NEED
TO INCLUDE FUTURE AMENDMENTS.
THAT WOULD HAVE THE B. R. AND
REMOVE THE BEARINGS ABILITY TO
CONTROL ENROLLMENTS AND THE
STATE'S NURSING SUPPLY
HISTORICALLY THE B. R. AND I HAS
NOT ACTED AS A CREDITOR AS AN
ACCREDITOR AND THIS IS A RECENT
DEVELOPMENT IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS SO WE ASK THAT- MAY NOT
ACT AS A CREDITOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HEARING ME. THE YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS THIS. GERMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DEBBIE SIR AND I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND A STUDENT
AT WEST COAST UNIVERSITY LOS
ANGELES I'M HERE TO TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND URGE
FUTURE AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW. HIGH
PERFORMING SCHOOLS TO MEET
STUDENT DEMAND ACCESS INCREASED
ENROLLMENTS AS APPROVED BY THE
CREDITOR THE B. R. AND SHOULD
NOT BE CHOOSING WHO IS ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF COMMITTEE ROOM. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS AND STALLS AND I'M
REPRESENTING THAT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES OF
NURSING AND WE SUPPORT-
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS IN REGARD
TO THE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS-
APPROVAL CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
FACULTY AND THE B. R. AN
APPROVAL PROCESS ACCORDING TO
THE COMMUNICATIONSTHAT WE
PRESENTED IN THE PAST THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT TO AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR. CENA MOVED OPPOSITION ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
. THE AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR
. SEEING NONE MISTER MODERATOR
WILL GO TO SUPPORT AND OR
OPPOSITION THE PHONE LINES
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF
YOU'RE IN A SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. BUT YOURSELF Q. AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THIS IS LORETTA MOBILE THAT
OFFICER FOR THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING I WASN'T
ABLE TO GET ON THEM THAT THE
LINE OR ON MUTE WHEN YOU CALLED
SO I WAS ABLE TO. GO ON WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF THAT SHE SAID THAT
NUMBER- I'M HERE FOR TECHNICAL
SUPPORT OF COURSE WE SUPPORT OUR
SUNSET AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH AGAINST SHE AND OTHER
STAFF. AS THE BILL CONTINUES TO
EXPAND AND GROW THROUGH THE
PROCESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THEM. ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS ON PERSUADING THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION-
CNA DOESN'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR BUT SUPPORT THE FULL
EXTENSION OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING SUPPORTS
VARYING CLINICAL EDUCATION
DELIVER CONCURRENTLY BUT OPPOSES
THE SUBSTITUTION OF CLINICAL
LEARNING WITH ACTUAL PATIENT OR
LEARNING IN A HIGH FIDELITY
SIMULATION LAB. BEYOND 25%
OPPOSE THIS WEEDING OUT A PUBLIC
NURSING PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL
SPOTS TO THE RAPID AND
UNREGULATED EXPANSION OF PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT PROGRAMS IN OPPOSES
CALIFORNIA JOINED THE NURSING
LICENSE OR COMPACT WHICH WOULD
UNDERMINE PUBLIC PROTECTION BY
INHIBITING CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY
TO SET STANDARDS THAT APPLY TO
ALL NURSING. NURSES PRACTICING
HERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY ONE EUROPE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY EIGHTY ONE AT YOUR OWN
BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MORE
SHOT EIGHTY ONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND IT THEY'RE NOT
RESPONDING SO ANYBODY ELSE GOING
YET ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. TO A AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FOUR. AND MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. S.
R. ONE. AS A THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE A AND TIME YOU'VE SPENT SO
FAR ESPECIALLY- WITH ALL THE
SUNSET HEARINGS THAT WE HAD OF.
I THINK THAT WE DO NEED TO FOCUS
ON INCREASING THE PIPELINE OF A
GOOD NURSES. AND I HOPE YOU
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE- EXPANDING
CLINICAL SIMULATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
MISSOURI AS NUMBER ONE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION IN
THE SENSE THAT HEARINGS AS WELL.
SHOULD ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. CNN RESEARCH
PROJECT CLOSE AYE WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU SO MUCH. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM. C. AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE. A RIDE. LET'S
DO IT. AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
IS A SUNSET BILL FOR THE NATURAL
PATHAK MEDICINE COMMITTEE.
CURRENTLY THE BILL ONLY MAKES
ONE MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGE IN
THE NATURAL PATHAK DOCTORS ACT
AS WE CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND ANY FURTHER CHANGES WITH
THE SENATE. REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE OF THE COMMITTEE ARE WITH ME
BY PHONE TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT FOLKS
MAY HAVE. AND- RESPECT S. RIVAL
. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE IN
SUPPORT. THE MODERATOR ANY
WITNESSES ON THE ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE PRIMARY
WITNESSES THANK YOU I WE CAN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME OR TO SUPPORT JUST PRIMARY
WITNESSES. OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD
ANY WITNESSES YOUR LINES ARE
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN YOU. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE BACKING MITCHELL
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER WITH THE
NATURE CATHOLIC MEDICINE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO BE
HERE WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AS NEEDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I SEE THAT
ON OUR AGENDA WE DO A ONE OTHER.
WITNESS DAR THOMPSON. HELLO
THANK YOU THIS IS DOCTOR TARA
THOMPSON I'M THE CHAIR OF ANY
DRAMATIC MEDICAL COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND I
SUPPORT HURDLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY OTHER WITH US ON THE
PHONE LINES IT IN SUPPORT. I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM TO
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE. CNN
WE GOT OPPOSITION ANY OPPOSITION
IN A COMMITTEE ROOM TO AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU LAYS
WILL JUST HAVE DOT TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS JILLIAN MILLER. I
AM A LICENSED REGISTERED NURSE
FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
PRACTICING IN ALLOPATHIC
MEDICINE AND ACUTE CARE AND
CURRENTLY IN THE LAST NINETEEN
YEARS AS A TRADITIONAL MATCH
PATH. I COME BEFORE YOU TODAY
BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DEALINGS OF NATURAL MEDICINE
COMMITTEE. IN REGARDS TO THE
PRACTICE NATURAL. AS THIS YEAR
LETTER REVIEW MADE. THE NATURAL
CATHOLIC DOCTORS ACT IS A TWO
BILL ALLOWING FOR BOTH THE
PRACTICE OF NATURAL UP AT THE
END NATURAL PATHAK MEDICINE AS
DISTINCT HEALTH SCIENCES WITH
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS AND
DIFFERENT TITLES GIVEN TO THEIR
PRACTITIONERS. THOUGH NATURAL
PASS TRADITIONAL NOT FILES AND
MATCH PUBLIC PRACTITIONERS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE EDUCATED AND
TRAINED TO PRACTICE MATCH RAFI.
AND ABIDE BY THE PROVISIONS IN
SECTION TWO OH FIVE THREE POINT
SIX OF THE COMPLEMENTARY AND
ALTERNATIVE HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS ACT WE HAVE FOR
ALMOST TWO DECADES DECADES NOT
BEEN LICENSED OR REGISTERED WITH
ANY BOARD OR COMMITTEE IN THE
STATE. WE HAVE HOWEVER AS THE
CLAY OF STANDARDS BEFORE. AND
SELF REGULATION SINCE HEALTH
CARE AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND AS IT WOULD SEEM
START STATED IN THEIR REVIEW
THAT NATURAL PATHAK MEDICINE
COMMITTEE HAS TAKEN IT UPON
THEMSELVES AT TIMES TO TAKE
COMPLAINTS. ON BEHALF OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AGAINST SOME
PRACTITIONERS OF NATURAL WITH
THE WITHOUT APPARENT LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO DO SO WE WOULD MOST
RESPECTFULLY ASK THIS COMMITTEE
TO AMEND KIRKPATRICK CURRENT.
NATURAL HEALTH DOCTORS ACT TO
CREATE A REGISTRY FOR
PRACTITIONERS OF NATURAL UP WITH
THE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND. HERE SUPPORTING NOW
TROPIC THE AS TRADITIONAL
METROPASS AND WE WISH TO
CONTINUE THE CARE UNDER
REGISTRATION. TO THE PUBLIC THAT
IS SEEKING ALTERNATIVE CARE FOR
THEIR HEALTH THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EXPECTS WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME IS LUCY HICKS
AND I'VE BEEN A CLIENT OF A
NATURAL PATH THE- PRACTITIONER
FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS NOW AND
IT'S BEEN A VERY SUCCESSFUL
EXPERIENCE FOR ME. MY MEDICAL
DOCTORS AND OSTEOPATHIC AND HE'S
VERY RESPECTFUL OF THE CARE I
RECEIVED FROM MY NATURAL PATHAK
PRACTITIONER. RECENTLY IN A
DISCUSSION REGARDING A HEALTH
ISSUE HE FELT THAT MY NATURAL
PATHAK PRACTITIONER MIGHT
ADDRESS THIS BY. ISSUE MORE
SUCCESSFUL. WE HAVE A PARA HAD
NATCHER PASS LICENSE- REGISTERED
IN THE COUNTRY FOR NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED YEARS. THESE TRADITIONAL
NATURAL PASS FUNCTION VERY
DIFFERENTLY THE MEDICAL NATURAL
PASS AND IN ADDITION THE
APPOINTMENT COST. IS SIGNIFICANT
. I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
THIS BILL BE AMENDED SO THAT
THESE- CLASSIC NATCHER PASS MAY
ONCE AGAIN BE RECOGNIZED AND
WRETCHED REGISTERED SEPARATELY.
APPROPRIATELY UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CLIENTS
SUCH AS MYSELF RELY ON THIS
PROFESSION THANK YOU SO MUCH
LUCIA HICKS A CLIENT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
. I WANT TO PLEASE JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. OPPOSITION
TO AB. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE.
MICHAEL SALAS OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. ADDING ALL
AND LENTIL I OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. KELLY MCGEE I OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. BRENDA GENERALI
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. LESLIE
SCANNER OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THE G. BURNED OUT FOR DINNER
COMMANDER. DANNY HOW ARE YOU
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. SAMANTHA
JOHNSON OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
EDWARD MATTESON OPPOSED WAS
RECORD THAT LASTED LESS ADMIN
HIS. RACHEL GATE SUPPOSEDLY
AMENDED THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. SEEING NONE SEMATARY WILL
GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES ONE
LAST TIME FOR SUPPORT AND OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOUR SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY.
ZERO MR SURE- WHAT JUST WHEN I
SAID THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE- EIGHTY ONE YOUR OPEN
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
I'M I'M OPPOSED. COMPLETELY
AGAINST EVERYTHING THE STATE
DOES. THANK YOU DURING THE LAST
THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD DAY. HOW
TO GIVE A FINAL REMINDER
THROUGHOUT SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND ONE
IS QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ONE
MOMENT. WITH AN OPERATOR SHOULD
BE WITH US MOMENTARILY THANKS
AGAIN FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE GIVEN
THE LINE NUMBER. AND WE WILL GO
TO OUR LINE EIGHT NINE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD NINETY FOUR
. HI MY NAME IS DAVID PIKE WE
RUN HIM ASIDE HERE SAN FRANCISCO
BODY PONY IS. THANK NAME AN
ORGANIZATION.WRONG BILL DAVID
THANK BODY I THINK IT'S THE
WRONG BILL MY FOR. ALL RIGHT
RESERVED. BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I WE'RE GONNA
ESTABLISH A CORE REAL QUICK SO
WE GET THAT TAKEN CARE OF FOR
CIRCULAR PLEASE CALL. BERMAN
HERE. FOR THEIR- LIMB. BONTA
CHEN. CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG
GIPSON GRAYSON IRWIN WE MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN SALAS THANK WEBER. THEY WERE STILL GOT A QUORUM I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ADMINISTRATION
THE COMMENTS FROM FOLKS AND WILL
KEEP WILL KEEP THEIR WORK ON
THIS THANK YOU SO MUCH. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE MOTIONS DO PASS
BERMAN HI BERMAN I FLOOR. FLOOR
I BLOOM BONTA. CHAN CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM DALY. FONG FONG I
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE IRWIN- WHEN I LEAN.
A. I. MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN. SALAS THING WEBER ALL
RIGHT. THE BILL'S OUT LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER LIKE YOUR LAST ONE
HAVE A GREAT. WE MOVED ON THE
NEXT BILL THANK YOU LADIES. THE
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN THE LAST SUNSET
BILL AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
IS A SENSIBLE FOR MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL. WELL WE HAVE
DISCUSSED A NUMBER OF ISSUES FOR
THIS COMMITTEE DURING SUNSET
REVIEW THIS BILL IS CURRENTLY
STILL LARGELY A PLACEHOLDER
VEHICLE WHILE DISCUSSIONS AROUND
THE ADDITION OF POTENTIAL
REFORMS CONTINUE IN THE SENATE
WE ANTICIPATE HAVING ANOTHER
HEARING ON THIS BILL WHEN IT
RETURNS TO US WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS LATER THIS YEAR. IN
THE MEANTIME THE BILL SIMPLY
CONTAINS A STANDARD FOUR YEAR
EXTENSION FOR THE COUNCIL I
THINK THIS MIGHT HAVE BEEN WHAT
THE PRIOR CALL I WAS CALLING IN
FOR. RESPECT AFTER. THANK YOU IT
WAS A GOOD COUPLE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY
MCHALE REPRESENTING C. M. T. C.
FIRST OF ALL I DO WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF. WITH A
FOUR YEAR EXTENSION. THE FOUR
YEARS IS NOT ARBITRARY THEFOUR
YEARS WILL ALLOW THE
CERTIFICATION FOR SCHOOLS WHICH
ARE FOR YEARS TO CONTINUE.
BEFORE YOUR CERTIFICATION ALLOW
THERAPISTS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
VALIDLY. WITH LOCALENTITIES. TO
PROVIDE THE ABILITY TO ENFORCE.
AND MOST OF ALL THE FOUR YEARS
WILL ALLOW THE IMHO USE HAVE
BEEN ENTERED INTO. WITH DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND WITH ANTI
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATIONS TO
CONTINUE. THE FOR YEARS
ABSOLUTELY DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE
WILL NOT CONTINUE TO WORK. WITH
THE STAFF AND WITH THE CHAIR AND
WITH MEMBERS OF THE SENATE. WE
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE CA NTC. AND
TO WORK WITH THOSE. WHO HAVE
IDEAS TO- TO PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ASTRONOVA
INC U. S. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY CONCERN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE THERAPY
COALITION- WE ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE FOR YOUR SUNSET EXTENSION.
LITTLE BIT OF A JOURNEY TO GET
HERE BUT THIS IS THE RIGHT
RESULT IN OUR OPINION- IT IS
SMALL BUSINESS FRIENDLY- IT IS
THERAPIST FRIENDLY IT ALSO WILL
PROVIDE- THE KIND OF THE
CERTAINTY THAT THIS INDUSTRY
NEEDS- GOING FORWARD. UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S OTHER CONVERSATIONS
AND WORK AND WE HOPE TO BE A BIG
PART OF THAT- BUT A GREAT FARMS. SUPPORT OF THE BILL HERE.
THANK YOU A ONE. OF AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN COME ON. IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. C. NINE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. SENA OPPOSITION MISTER
MODERATOR LIKE TO GO TO THE
PHONE RIGHT PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN. WE GOT
ONE HERE THE COMMITTEE ROOM YES
MA'AM. SKEWS ME I THOUGHT
SOMEONE MORE FORMAL WAS GONNA
COME UP MY NAME IS LAUREN
MCLAUGHLIN. I AM A CERTIFIED
MASSAGE THERAPIST I AM A SOLE
PROPRIETOR. IN ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA. I AM OPPOSED UNLESS
THIS IS AMENDED I AM IN FAVOR OF
ONLY A ONE YEAR EXTENSION AND I
AM IN FAVOR OF LICENSURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. CENOVUS
MODERATELY OF THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AB.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF YOUR SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZEROS ON OPERATOR CAN GIVE
YOU THEIR LINE NUMBER. YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WE WILL START WITH
LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. AND CHAIR. BUT. ONE MOMENT.
RIGHT AT FORTY WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT. MAYBE THEY'RE
NOT ACCURATE GO AHEAD AND
ACTUALLY HELLO MEMBERS THIS IS
ALICIA PRIEGO- AND THAT LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION ON THE
BILL AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN.
GO AHEAD GET TWO MINUTES. THANK
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT AT YOUR
MEMBERS ONLY SHOULD CREATE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
BODYWORK AND MASSAGE
PROFESSIONALS AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN. AB AND T. IN THE MCCARTY
MANY CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD
INTRODUCING A BILL FOR STATEWIDE
LIKE NATURE IN THE COMING YEAR.
AS A RESULT WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE EXPANSION OF THE EMPTY
INCOME JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN AND ASKED THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDER AMENDING THE
BILL TO REVISE THE SCENT THAT
DATE TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY. FOUR AND THREE INSERT
THAT CAN AT FORTY SIX TWENTY ONE
FEET REGARDING SUBSEQUENT
CONSIDERATION OF LEGISLATION TO
CREATE A NEW STATE BOARD AND A
NEW CATEGORY OF LATENT
PROFESSIONAL. IN SEPARATE NEED
REASONS WHERE PART OF THEM AT
THE MANDATE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE CARE AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
AS WELL ON THAT ISSUE AND IN
HERE FOR ANY. TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER MODERATOR IN THE SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. OKAY WE'LL GO
BACK TO LINE EIGHTY FOUR SHE WAS
A ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
TESTIFIED AND ONLINE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS TONY PSYCHOSIS- I
AM A MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
MASSAGE THERAPY ASSOCIATION AND
FORMER GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
CHAIR FOR THAT ORGANIZATION- AND
I AM SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO EXPRESS- SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN WE HAVE A NUMBER OF THE
STRIP CARE WHAT IT LINE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINES OPEN PLEASE ON YOU.
EIGHTY ONE ONE MORE SHOT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO AYE TESTIFIED TODAY
. I WILL MOVE ALONG AND WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SARAH EVER I'LL RODRIGUEZ NUMBER
. BURKE WILL AND MORE AND%
SUPPORT- EIGHT TWENTY ACRES. MY
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DR STEP YOU'D
CALL THE NATIONAL PLAN ON AT.
AND WE ARE. IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU TWO YOUR OPEN. THIRTY TWO
PLEASE ON YOUR PHONE. HELLO MY
NAME IS KATRINA DORY AND I'M A-
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPIST I'M
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN UNLESS COMMENDED I'M IN
FAVOR OF A ONE YEAR EXTENSION OF
THE C. ANTI SEE AN INVASION OR
FAVOR OF LICENSURE THANK YOU. I
NINETEEN YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S CHRIS CAME
I'M REPRESENTING PROCLAIMS I'M
IN FAVOR. I AM THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
I'M PHILIP MANAGER IN MY HAIR
I'M A MEMBER OF A AND G. A. N. I
AM OPPOSED TO A. B. TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN UNLESS AMENDED-
ALLOWING FOREIGN I WOULD PREFER
ONE YEAR EXTENSION OF C. A. M.
P. C. AND IN FAVOR OF STATE
NELSON JR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
JUST LIKE TO REMIND THE COLORS
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE. A
CHRISTIAN- AND WE'LL GO LINE
FIFTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY
NAME'S JENNIFER MUCH HIGHER NAME
WITH BURKE WILLIAMS AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. ONE FIFTY SEVEN
EUROPE. FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MORE SHOT FIFTY SEVEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ON MUTE AND
TESTIFY. I WILL MOVE ALONG THE
LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO THIS IS PAMELA ESTES
WITH THE CEMETERY COUNTY HUMAN
TRAFFICKINGPROGRAM AND WE
SUPPORT THE AB. TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN. FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIFTY SEVEN ONE MORE
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO TESTIFY. THE
MOBILE ONLINE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ASHLEY HERNANDEZ LEFT FEDERATION
LAST THURSDAY MORNING SUPPORT.
I'M AT EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL RIGHT SIR- NATIONALISTIC
INSTITUTE THE LARGEST- AND- YOU
KNOW CREDITED MASSAGE THERAPY
SCHOOL CALIFORNIA TEN LOCATIONS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. KIRSTEN
PRESIDENT OF MISOGYNY FRANCHISE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED INDEPENDENTLY OWNED AND
OPERATED MASSAGEIN THE CLINICS
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL
. I NINETY FOUR EUROPE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINETY FOUR YOU MUTED.
ONE MORE SHOT NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I WILL MOVE ALONG THE
LINE ONE OH ONE FOR ANYBODY ELSE
I PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO OUR AB. TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN NINE ONE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS TERRY HARMON I AM A
PROSECUTOR IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
I OVERSEE OUR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
UNIT. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN WHO IS
JOINING. CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX EIGHT.
SEVEN THIS IS OUR C. A. M. P. HE
HAS BEEN FANTASTIC YOU SO MUCH
ONE- AND WE THAT THE EXTENT TO
IS GRAN THANK YOU Q. ONE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK YOU ARE
THREE RETIRED JACKSON CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
EXTENDING THE TIMES THAT TO
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
I AND ONE OH FIVE EUROPE. THE
MORNING MY NAME'S MONICA WILSON
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF
ANTIOCH IN THE AND DEVELOP THAT
RELATIONSHIP MANAGER FOR LOVE
NEVER FAILS AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. FINE ONE AWAIT
YOU YOU ARE OPEN. WHEN ONE AWAIT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME CHESTER JOHN
pSO MUCH OF THE BOARD AND I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY A. B. SEVEN I
WILL YES. THANK ONE ONE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BRANDY THE PRESTIGE BMTC
NUMBER SIX FOUR FIVE FOUR AM
TEAM MEMBER I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE STYLE THANK YOU. I'M MISTER
SHORTLY EXHAUSTED THE Q. AS
OUTSTANDING. BRING ABOUT TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES DR WEBER. GOOD MORNING CHAIR GOOD
MORNING DODD WEBER SO- THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL AND LIKE MANY OF OUR
OTHER BOARDS- IT IS A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT NONPROFIT PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATION AND IN OUR
ANALYSIS- A TALK ABOUT THAT
THEIR ADVANTAGES THAT COME WITH
CONSTRUCTING IT AS A NONPROFIT
CORPORATION WHAT ARE THOSE
ADVANTAGES I WILL DEFER TO MY
TECHNICAL EXPERT THAT I ASSUME I
HAVE ON THE LINE TO DISCUSS THE
BOARD STRUCTURE- AND THE PROS
AND CONS. OF SUCH A STRUCTURE-
POSSIBLY ONE OF MY- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WERE HERE EARLIER. MR
CLINTON. A QUICK ANSWER BRIGITTE. I THINK M. JUST A COUPLE
REASONS AND HAPPY TO DO THIS IS
KIND OF A SIDE BAR AND I DON'T
REPRESENT THE MTC BUT IT'S VERY
EFFICIENT IT'S ABLE TO FOCUS ON
TRAFFIC IT'S DONE SOME AMAZING
THINGS IN STOPPING TRAFFIC IN
THE MIGHT BE DIFFICULT FOR I'M
AT A LICENSING AGENCY TO DO. ITS
PROVIDED A VERY KIND OF NICE
BENEFITS AND AN IDEA TO THIS WHY
YOU HAVE WE'VE DONE A COUPLE
HEARINGS ON THIS IS WHETHER SUCH
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT FOR SEEING TO
SEE IT IT'S A VERY GOOD AT WHAT
IT DOES IT'S AS YOU HEARD HIM
TESTIFY THEY'RE OPEN EVEN SOME
ADDITIONAL IMPROVEMENT WE THINK
IT'S OF A NICE MODEL FOR HOW
THINGS CAN BE DONE ONE OF THE
THANK YOU REGION THEN ONE OF
THAT ONE OF THE BIGGER THINGS
THAT I'VE HEARD FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT- IN IN MY DISTRICT
IS JUST THEIR ABILITY TO ACT
VERY QUICKLY- WHEN. THEY THEY
LEARNED THAT THERE'S
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR AND
POSSIBLY EVEN WORSE YEAH FINAL
ACTIVITY IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HAPPENING AT AN ESTABLISHMENT
HERE SAYING THAT IF IT WERE
ACTUALIZADAS WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO ACT QUICKLY THEIR CONCERNS
THAT THAT HAS BEEN THE CASE IN
THE PAST AND THAT YES THAT WOULD
BE THE CASE. SO I'M SINCE. IT'S
NOT A REQUIREMENT TO ACTUALLY BE
A LICENSED THERAPIST IT'S A
VOLUNTARY- CERTIFICATE. AND
THERE IS NO DEFINED SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR MASSAGE THERAPY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND SINCE
NOT EVERYONE HAS THIS LICENSE OR
CERTIFICATE THERE IS REALLY NO
DISCIPLINARY AUTHORITY OVER ALL
OF OUR MASSAGE THERAPIST. I'M
JUST WONDERING WHY WE HAVE
CHOSEN TO REPEAL THE LANGUAGE
TO. CONSIDER CREATING A LICENSE
OR BOARD. SURE I THINK DURING
THE DISCUSSIONS HAS BEEN
DETERMINED THE END AND DURING
DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IT'S BEEN DETERMINEDTHAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS A DRESSING THE
NEEDS- OF. AT LEAST A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY AS YOU
KNOW- IS THAT YOU NEVER GONNA
GET A HUNDRED PERCENT- HAPPINESS
WITH ANY. KIND OF SOLUTION- BUT
THERE A LOT OF FOLKS ARE HAPPY
WITH THE CURRENT SITUATION AND-
A LOT OF FOLKS WHO FEEL LIKE THE
CURRENT SITUATION- IS BOTH
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF. HER
MASSAGE THERAPIST AND ALSO OF
LIKE I MENTIONED EARLIER KIND OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER
ENTITIES THAT- YOU. SPEND A LOT
OF TIME IN THE SPACE AND HAVE
CONCERNS AROUND- SOME
INAPPROPRIATE AND ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE GOING ON. AS
THIS- BILL CONTINUES TO MOVE FOR
IT I HOPE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS- I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A DESIRE
WITHIN. A MASSAGE THERAPIST
ACTUALLY HAVE- THEIR PROFESSION
AS A LICENSED PROFESSION AS-
MANY OF OUR- YOU KNOW OUR
POSITION IS ACTUALLY A LICENSE
BOARD. I'M AND ALSO YOU KNOW THE
PURPOSE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
NOT ONLY ARE YOU DEALING WITH
SEX TRAFFICKING BUT YOU KNOW THE
CONSUMERS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO GET THEIR MASSAGES.
THERE THAT THERE SOME
STANDARDIZED. LEVEL OF CARE AND
THERE'S ACTUALLY A BOARD. WITH
AUTHORITY OVER ALL OF THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE DOING IT SO- I
JUST ASK THAT WE CONTINUE THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND REALLY
RECONSIDER SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THE OPPOSITION HAS SAID
ABOUT THE TIME THAT WE'RE-
GIVING THIS EXTENSION AND ALSO
THE FACT THAT. WE ARE CURRENTLY
REPEALING. THE TAKING OFF THE
TABLE THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
CREATING AN ACTUAL BORN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR APPRECIATE
THAT. ELECT WEBER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS PLEASE
. CENA MISTER REJECT WEST AFTER
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SURGERY.
CALL AB TWENTY SIX ABC EMOTIONS
DO PASS BERMAN HI BERMAN I FLOOR
BY FLOOR AYE BLOOM BONTA. CHAN
CHAN I CUNNINGHAM DALY. FONG
FONG I GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON IRELAND- IRWIN KILEY MAY
I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN SALAS TANG. WEBER MEMBERS. THE BUILDINGS WERE MORE
VOCALLY WITH ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT ON. THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR AND I BELIEVE- SOME
NUMBER LEE HAS A COUPLE OF BILLS
. THE PRESENT- EXCUSE ME DIDN'T
SEE OTHER OVER THE DOCTOR WOULD-
DOCTOR WOULD DRIVE MY SHEET
THAT'S GOT THE. FILE I'M NINE.
OKAY SO YOU'VE GOT NINE AND
YOU'VE GOT EIGHTEEN IT WHATEVER
PICK YOUR POISON DOCTOR WHAT. NO
PRESSURE WE HIT THE HIT THE
BUTTON ON YOUR LEFT ON THE
TABLE- IT YEP PERFECT. YES THANK
YOU I WAS WEARING MY
INVISIBILITY CLOAK OVER THERE SO
I'M CRESCENTA WE SHOULD THAT WE
FOUND ME. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- IS MY PLEASURE
PERCENT AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWO. OF FIRE RESISTANCE BUILDING
STANDARDS- BILL- WOULD LIKE TO
START BY TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL VERY HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL SO IT'S MUCH
APPRECIATED- THE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THAT THE STATE FARM
FIRE MARSHAL IS THE CORRECT
ENTITY TO DEVELOP AND PROPOSE.
APPROPRIATE LIFE AND FIRE AND
LIFE SAFETY STANDARDS TO BE
CONSIDERED BY THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION AS WELL AS
MODIFY THE CODE SECTION IMPACTED
BY THE BILL. SAYS THE PROPOSED
UNDERSUPPLY ONLY TO NON
RESIDENTIAL STRUCTURES MEMBERS
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
DESTROYED APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
THOUSAND HOMES AS WELL AS
COUNTLESS OTHER STRUCTURES
INCLUDING GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS
AND SCHOOLS THAT EXISTS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITY. VERY DIFFICULT TO
REBUILD DEVASTATED COMMUNITIES
WHEN KEY SERVICES ARE ALSO
DISPLACED IN A COMMUNITY. AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY FOCUSING
ON STANDARDS THAT INCREASE THE
FIRE SAFETY FOR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDINGS IN HIGH
RISK FIRE ZONES BY SHARING THESE
BUILDINGS HAVE A BETTER CHANCE
REMAINING IN PLACE. AFTER A
CATASTROPHIC FIRE. WE MINIMIZE
ONE OF THE HURDLES ENCOUNTERED
WHEN COMMUNITIES ARE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW AND WHERE TO
REBUILD- TO. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL ARE GARY I FOR WITH
THE BRICKLAYERS AND ALLIED CRAFT
WORKERS AND SO NEW- MATTHEW WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL MASONRY
INSTITUTE. GREAT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. JUST YOUR PERFECT EXCUSE
ME BERMAN BERMAN STEAM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING I STAND
BEFORE YOU WERE SET BEFORE YOU
TODAY AS A SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
BRICKLAYERS AND ALLIED CRAFT
WORKERS LOCAL THREE CALIFORNIA
AN AFFILIATE OF THE OLDEST
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
CRAFT. IN NORTH AMERICA. AACS
LONG BEEN COMMITTED ALONG WITH
ITS SISTER LOCAL B. A. C. FOR IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. TO BUILDING
. RESILIENT COMMUNITIES AND
STRENGTHENING THOSE COMMUNITIES
THROUGH BUILDING RESILIENT
CONSTRUCTION- STRUCTURES AT LAST
THE TEST OF TIME. UNTIL NOW VERY
LITTLE HAS BEEN DONE TO ENSURE
THAT BUILDING MATERIALS UTILIZED
TO CONSTRUCT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN AREAS OF THE
STATE THAT ARE MOST SUSCEPTIBLE
TO WILDFIRE MEET STANDARDS
NECESSARY TO WITHSTAND PROLONGED
EXPOSURE TO FIRE. ABC TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWO PROPOSES A
SOLUTION TO THAT PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING. THE BUILDING
STANDARDS TO IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE STATE FARM ARE STUDENTS. THE
UP TO BUILDING STANDARDS ON FIRE
RESISTANT THAT WOULD APPLY TO
NON RESIDENTIAL CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN VERY HI HIGH.
AND MODERATE FIRE SEVERITY ZONES
. WE THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR- SUPPORT ON THIS
COMMONSENSE BILL TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD FOR THE BENEFIT OF
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BURKE. RESPECTED
CHAIRMAN AND THAT DECISION
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS SENSITIVE
MATTHEW ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL MASONRY INSTITUTE
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO I'M A
LICENSED STRUCTURAL ENGINEER AND
THE LEAD TO CREATE A
PROFESSIONAL AND I HAVE A TWENTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE. AND- DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION. I CAN TELL YOU
. FOR SAID INFORMATION THAT
STATES BUILDING STANDARDS HAVE
NOT KEPT UP WITH OUR CHANGING
CLIMATE AND THE THREAT IT POSES
TO OUR COMMUNITIES. IT IS TIME
WE DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT. I
ASK YOU ALL- A CONSIDERATE FORTY
IN FAVOR OF THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOT A MOTION
. GOT A SECOND. ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ON MY SHEET- SWIMMING THERE NO
PRIMER WITNESSES- LET'S OPEN IT
UP TO ANYBODY TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AGAIN A REMINDER THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOUR
NAME. ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH
IF ANY AND YOUR POSITION JUST
SOME OR AFP- TO THE BILL ANY
WANTS ADD ON IN SUPPORT OR ON IN
THE HEARING ROOM. TODAY SEEING
NONE LET'S MOVE TO THE OPERATOR
OPERATOR- ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES WANTS TO ADD ON. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO BY
DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWO. MR CHAIR NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING BACK COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR DOCTOR WOULD. ON
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO KERN I'M
ALRIGHT. DONNA IS GRAYSON THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANNA
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR. ACTUALLY
COMING FROM AN AREA THAT HAS
BEEN PROFOUNDLY IMPACTED BY
WILDFIRES AND ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT- YOU WORK THROUGH THE BILL
TO NOT IMPACT TO THE COST OF
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING BUT REALLY
FOCUS ON THE LARGER STRUCTURES
THAT HAVE A MUCH. MORE THE HAS
MUCH MORE POTENTIAL OF ENHANCING
A WILDFIRE SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE SEEING NINE.
ARE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
MY FAVORITE CLOTHES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD IT IS
CERTAINLY IMPORTANT TO DO ALL.
THAT WE CAN TO PROTECT THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM WHAT HAVE
BECOME ALL TOO FREQUENT
WILDFIRES. I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY WITH THE AGREED
UPON AMENDMENTS AND ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONINUE WITH THE STATE
ENTITIES. RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD- WITH THAT MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE. THE
MOTION TO PASS AS A MAN TO.
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE FIRM HI
BERMAN I FLOOR. FLOOR I BLEW.
BUT WHEN I BONTA TEN CAN I
CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG. ON AYE
GIPSON GRAYSON. GRAYSON I. IRWIN
EILEEN. MAY I MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MEDINA THE AYE MULLIN. SALAS
THING WEBER I THINK BILL IS OUT.
OKAY THE ROLE OF MEMBERS THE YOU
THINK IT OUGHT TO THANK YOU. AND
I SEE SANTIAGO STEINORTH ELEMENT
OPEN JUST KIDDING YOU'VE GOT ONE
MORE BILL I SHOULD KNOW THAT.
GEN I NUMBER EIGHTEEN A BEACH
SIX NINETY ONE BUT DOCTOR WOULD
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
CHAIRMAN. REPRESENT LIKE TO
START BY TECH ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THANKING STAFF ONCE AGAIN FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. MEMBERS
IT'S NO SECRET THAT SMALL
CANNABIS BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE STRUGGLING.
THERE'S NO SHORTAGE OF
CHALLENGES FACING THE INDUSTRY
TODAY TAXES COMPLIANCE COSTS
UNEVEN IMPLEMENTATION ILLICIT
MARKET THE LIST GOES ON. ALL
THESE ARE MULTI. AND COMPLICATED
THIS BILL HOWEVER IS ATTEMPTING
TO SOLVE A MUCH SIMPLER PROBLEM
AS A STATE WE HAVE A RICH
HISTORY OF PROMOTING AND
SUPPORTING CRAFT BEER. ARTISANAL
WINE AND FAMILY FARM AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTS OF ALL KINDS.
UNFORTUNATE FOR SMALL CANNABIS
FARMERS UNLESS THE FARMERS HAS
THE RESOURCES YOU VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED THEY ARE PROHIBITED
FROM SELLING ANY AMOUNT OF THEIR
CANNABIS CONSUMERS AND MUST RELY
ON DISTRIBUTORS TO SECURE SHELF
SPACE ESTABLISH RELATIONSHIPS
WITH CUSTOMERS ON THEIR BEHALF.
THIS LACK OF ACCESS TO CONSUMERS
HAS MADE IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE SMALLEST CANOPY GROWTH
RAFT OUT OF ITS FARMERS TO
DEVELOP CUSTOMER RELATIONSHIPS
AND DRIVE DEMAND. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE SIMPLY ALLOWS CRAFT
CANNABIS FARMERS THAT IS FARMERS
WHO GROW LESS THAN ONE ACRE. ONE
ACRE OF CANNABIS TO SELL THEIR
PRODUCT AT LIMITED NUMBER OF
LICENSED CANNABIS EVENTS.
EMPHASIZE LICENSED CANNABIS
EVENTS. I WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS
IS NOT ALLOWING FARMERS TO THROW
UP A FARM STAND ON THE SIDE OF
THE ROAD OR OPEN UP A SHOP. THIS
IS ONLY FOR LICENSED AND LOCALLY
APPROVED SPECIAL EVENTS. SUCH AS
THE EMERALD COP IN THE CITY OF
WHERE I LIVE IN SANTA ROSA. IT'S
NOT ABOUT CIRCUMVENTING
RETAILERS ARE PITTING ONE SIDE
OF THE INDUSTRY AGAINST THE
OTHER. THIS IS ABOUT GROWING THE
INDUSTRY OVERALL. WE DON'T NEED
TO LOOK ANY FURTHER THAN THE
CRAFT BEER INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE WHAT
ACCESS TO UNIQUE AND HIGH
QUALITY PRODUCTS CAN DO FOR THE
GROWTH OF AN INDUSTRY. MEMBERS
YOU LISTED CANNABIS SENT MARKET
IS WELL ESTABLISHED AS
UNDERCUTTING OUR BEST EFFORTS TO
STAND UP A REGULATED CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. I FEAR THAT WITHOUT
VIABLE PATHWAYS TO COMPLIANCE
AND HEALTHY CONSUMER MARKETS WE
WILL LOSE THESE FARMERS WHO HAVE
CHOSEN TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
YOUR TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT ARE-
CARLA ABA LOW WITH THE TRINITY
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL LANDS. AND
ROSS GORDON WITH THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE THANK
YOU DOCTOR WOULD AND WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM THE VICE CHAIR.
ANYBODY WANTS A SECOND IT. GOT A
SECOND. BIPARTISAN MOTION SECOND
YES PLEASE WHEN YOU'RE READY.
JUST HIT THE LITTLE BUTTON THE
LAW MIGHT BUTTON. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CARLA VILLA
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE TRINITY COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
SCIENCE. I AM AN INDEPENDENT
FAMILY FARMER AND HOMESTEADER
MUCH LIKE THOUSANDS OF OTHER
LEGACY CANNABIS PRODUCING
FARMERS THROUGHOUT MY REGION. I
HOLD A SINGLE TYPE ONE FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT SPECIALTY
OUTDOOR COTTAGE WE'RE SORRY
OUTDOOR SPECIALTY CULTIVATION
LICENSE AND CULTIVATE CANNABIS
ALONGSIDE DOZENS OF OTHER
DIVERSIFIED CROPS. FOR SALE AT
OUR LOCAL FARMERS MARKET. THIS
DIRECT TO CONSUMER CONNECTION IS
A AN ESSENTIAL PIECE OF HOW A
SMALL FARM BUSINESS WORKS. OUR
PRODUCE FARM WOULD NOT SURVIVE
WITHOUT DIRECT RETAIL MARKETS.
AND SMALL SCALE PRODUCERS LACK
THE ABILITY TO MARKET DIRECTLY
TO CONSUMERS WE LOSE THE
ARTISANAL VALUE OF OUR PRODUCT
AND OUR SCALE WE CANNOT AFFORD
TO DO SO. FROM WINE TO
VEGETABLES TO CRAFT CANNABIS
THIS MECHANISM IS HOW CRAFT
SCALE AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS AND
RENOWNED GROWING REGIONS AROUND
THE WORLD ARE RECOGNIZED AS
UNIQUE AND DISTINCT AND MADE
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE. OUR STATES
GLOBAL REPUTATION AS ONE OF THE
WORLD'S MOST SIGNIFICANT
CANNABIS PRODUCING REGIONS WAS
BUILT ON THE BACKS OF THOUSANDS
OF SMALL FAMILY FARMS WHO ARE
FACING AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS
TODAY. WHAT WE STAND TO LOSE IN
THIS MOMENT IS AN ENTIRE
CULTURAL HERITAGEBUILT OVER
MULTIPLE GENERATIONS THE GENETIC
BIO DIVERT DIVERSITY OF OUR SEED
VARIETALS AVAILABLE ONLY ON OUR
FARMS. A REGIONAL ECONOMY THAT
SPANS THE ENTIRE NORTH STATE AND
FROM THE LEGAL SHELVES IS ABOUT
TO DISAPPEAR THE CRAFT ARTISANAL
HIGH QUALITY CANNABIS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S GLOBAL REPUTATION
WAS BUILT UPON. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE WOULD BRING SMALL
FARMERS AN ESSENTIAL TOOL TO
SURVIVE AT OUR SCALE AT THIS
MOST CRITICAL TIME AND AN
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE PATHWAY FOR
BRINGING UNIQUE SMALL SCALE
BATCHES INTO THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
BOLSTERING RETAIL ACCESS TO
CONSUMERS WHEN IT IS MOST
IMPERATIVE WE SUPPORT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RURAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CANNABIS TOURISM
EXPANSION OF THE LEGAL MARKET
FOR CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
OUR GLOBAL REPUTATION FOR CRAFT
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR GORDON.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ROSS CORDON I SERVICE
POLICY CHAIR WITH ORIGINS
COUNSEL AND POLICY CHAIR WITH
THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS
ALLIANCE. ORIGINS COUNCILS A
STATEWIDE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING NEARLY NINE HUNDRED
MEMBERS ACROSS THE FULL CHEMICAL
SUPPLY CHAIN BOTH OF THEM ARE
SMALL AND INDEPENDENT LEGACY
LICENSE CANNABIS FARMERS.
REGULATED CANNABIS MARKET FACES
MANY CHALLENGES IN THE CONTINUES
TO BE A ROBUST ILLICIT MARKET
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE NOT MADE THE
TRANSITION INTO THE LEGAL AND
LICENSED MARKET. A SMALL
PRODUCER SPECIFICALLY WE FACE
UNIQUE CHALLENGE OF MARKET
ACCESS YOU DO A LACK OF TOOLS
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE IF ARE
SMALL PRODUCERS OF ANY OTHER
CRAFT AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT. IN
OTHER SECTORS INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA'S WORLD RENOWNED
CRAFT WINE INDUSTRY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIRECT TO
CONSUMER MARKETING SUCH AS
FARMERS MARKET SALES. ARE THE
MECHANISM BY WHICH SMALL
PRODUCERS APRIL TO COMPETE ON A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WITH LARGER
COMPETITORS. THESE OPPORTUNITIES
DO NOT REPLACE TRADITIONAL
RETAIL SALES RATHER AUGMENT
THEM. BY PROVIDING APPROPRIATE
MARKET ACCESS OPPORTUNITIES TO
PRODUCERS WERE OPERATING ON A
SMALL SCALE. IT'S INDEPENDENT
PRODUCERS WE LIKE ACCESS TO
MARKETING RESOURCES SUCH AS
SALES TEAMS IN ADVERTISING
BUDGETS THAT ARE OFTEN TAKEN FOR
GRANTED BY LARGER BUSINESSES.
VERTICAL INTEGRATION IS
FINANCIALLY OUT OF REACH FOR
NEARLY ALL SMALL PRODUCERS AND
LOCAL LAND USEREGULATION
CONSTRAINTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PURSUE SALES DIRECTLY FROM THE
FARM. WHAT AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
ONE WOULD MOST DIRECTLY IMPACT
SMALL CANNABIS PRODUCERS IT'S
POTS OF AFFECTED EXPENSE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET AS A WHOLE.
FILLS MY CRAP PRODUCES A CAMPUS
EVENTS WILL DRIVE ADDITIONAL
SALES THROUGH LICENSED
DISTRIBUTION AND RETAIL. IN
CRAFT PRODUCERS TO SELL CANNABIS
EVENTS OR THE STRONG INCENTIVE
TO DIRECT THE CUSTOMERS TO LEGAL
RETAILERS OR MORE OF THEIR
PRODUCT CAN BE PURCHASED. WE ARE
PROUD OF THE BROAD COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WHICH
INCLUDES MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE
DIVERSE ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING SMALL PRODUCERS.
EQUITY BUSINESSES PATIENT
ADVOCATES AND VETERANS GROUPS
AND WE ASK SUPPORT TODAY TO
PROVIDE EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA'S WORLD RENOWNED
CRAFT CANNABIS PRODUCERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
BELIEVE WE ARE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- MISTER.
MEHTA AND MR RIVERA WERE IN THE
ROOM TODAY. OR NOT. MAYBE WORD
EVER LAST MINUTE AUDIBLE. I
DON'T. BUT WILL HAPPEN WHAT'S
THAT THE HEART OF I AS WELL
ABOUT MARVIN AND I GOT A- LOUISE
RIVERA. BUT WE ALWAYS HAVE A
CONSIDER. GO AHEAD. IN TWO
MINUTES EACH. HELLO GOOD MORNING
- MISTER CHAIR
REGULATIONS AND OF MANY AS
STRINGENT AND PROTOCOLS TO
FOLLOW IN ORDER FOR US TO GET TO
THIS POINT- WE OPPOSE AB- TWO
SIX NINE ONE OF BECAUSE IT
UNDERMINES THE RETAILERS- I
THINK THE INTENT MAY BE WELL.
BUT ULTIMATELY OF THE RETAILERS
ARE ONES THAT SHOULD RETAIL OF
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS PROCESS
OF WE'VE MET. OF THE
REQUIREMENTS. AND FOR SOMEONE
ELSE TO BE ABLE TO COME IN-
CIRCUMVENT KIND OF THE TAXES ON
THE PROCESS I SHOULD SAY AND-
THAT WE'VE HAD TO GO THROUGH. OF
DOESN'T REALLY SPEAK TO I THINK
THE ISSUES THAT ARE WE'RE
DEALING WITH AND SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS- IN ADDITION WE HAVE TO
COMPETE WITH ILLEGAL OPERATORS.
WITH THE HIGHER HIGHER YOU KNOW
THAT THEY'RE NOT PAYING ANY
TAXES- ANNA SAYS RETAILERS
POLICY PAYMENT- THE PRODUCTS.
SELLING ABOUT DOUBLE WHAT
SOMEONE CAN BUY A ILLEGALLY-
WELL SIR COMPETING WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COMPANIES CMING AND
DELIVERY COMPANIES AND OTHER
THAT ARE ABLE TO SELL IN OUR
JURISDICTION SO AN ALTERNATELY
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
FAMILIES THE CULTIVATORS AND THE
RETAILERS ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS- IN
REGARDS TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
HOW HOW IT WORKS AS WELL OF
CULTIVATORS NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
NECESSARY SAL WE STILL GOING TO
HAVE TO GET IT THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF DISTRIBUTION TESTING.
ETCETERA SO THEY'RE STILL GONNA
BE A NEED FOR THAT PROCESS TO BE
FOLLOWED- BUT THINK THOSE
RETAILERS AN EVENT LICENSE
HOLDERS OF FOLLOW THAT PROCESS
AND DONE THAT SO REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ARE DOING THAT MOVING
FORWARD RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GO AHEAD- MANAGER ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED CAN WITH
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION- WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY SIX NINETY
ONE- THIS IS A FOUR YEAR REUNION
OF THIS BILL- AND SOME OF THE
THINGS ISSUES WE HAVE IF WE LOOK
AT TWELVE AND FOR I THINK IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN DOWN TO EIGHT.
THE NUMBERS ARE TWELVE AND SET
FOR DAYS AT FORTY EIGHT DAYS PER
LICENSEE- AT FORTY TWO HUNDRED
LIFE AND FEES THAT PRETTY MUCH
WILL OPERATE UNDERNEATH THE
SMALL LICENSE- THAT BRINGS
ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO NEW RETAILERS INTO THE
MARKET ASCENTIAL EVERYDAY- I
REALIZE THAT WE NEED MORE
RETAIL- BUT THIS WAS NOT A
DILUTION OF EXISTING MARKETS
WHICH ALREADY HAVE RETAIL ACCESS
AND THEM IN THIS TO BE A GREAT
BILL IS A GREAT EXPANSION OF
RETAIL THIS GIVES EVERYONE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MARKET THEIR
PRODUCTS WHICH I THINK IS VERY
NECESSARY. BUT THIS CURRENT
DILUTION OF AN EXISTING MARKET
PUTS SOCIAL EQUITY GROUPS THAT
AT AND HARM'S WAY- AND ALSO PUTS
A BIG BURDEN ON THE STATE THE
DCC THE DCC TO- PROCESS OVER
FOUR THOUSAND APPLICATIONS AND
THAT FOUR THOUSAND APPLICATIONS
EVERY TWELVE EVENTS WHAT IS THE
COST OF DEATH LAST TIME IN
APPROPRIATIONS WE GOT TO SOME
POINT WHERE THIS COST WAS GOING
TO BE ALMOST IN SOME PAUL. AND
THE AMOUNT OF LICENSES WE NEED
TO BRING ON TO ONLINE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS ALMOST A
DISTRACTION I REALIZE THIS IS
NECESSARY I'VE BEEN IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GROWER FROM EIGHTEEN
YEARS THIS IS NOT SOMETHING I'M
DISTANT FROM. BUT AS A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RETAILER I SEE THIS
IS A DILUTION OF AN EXISTING
MARKET WHERE WE HAVE ALMOST.
SEVEN HUNDRED RETAILERS IN THAT
MARKET AND WE DON'T NEED SEVEN
HUNDRED MORE TO ENTER THAT
MARKET ON ANY ONE DAY. SO THIS
IS THE POSITION WE HAVE ALSO
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS YOU'RE
CREATING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
CREATE BANDS. AND WE SEEN THIS
ALREADY IN LONG BEACH WHERE 75%
OF ALL RETAILERS THAT COME INTO
SPECIAL EVENTS. HAVE TO BE LOCAL
FROM LONG BEACH MULTIPLE CITIES
ARE TALKING ABOUT BANNING
OUTSIDE RETAILERS FROM COMING IN
TO SPECIAL EVENTS SO ALL WE'RE
CREATING A BIGGER DIVISION.
AMONGST THE SUPPLY CHAIN I DON'T
KNOW WHY WE'RE DOING THIS I DO
HEAR THE NEED I BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS A NEED THERE. BUT WE
NEED TO EXPAND INTO NON EXISTING
MARKETS NOW THAT IS WHERE IT'S
GOING TO HELP REVENUE. THANK YOU
MISTER GALLO THANK YOU WHAT YOU
DID WAY BETTER THAN MR PANETTA
EVER KIND OF- AND NOW OPENING IT
UP TO- ANY ADDITIONAL ADD ON'S
ANYBODY WANTS THAT ON IN THE
HEARING ROOM SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION A REMINDER THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOUR
NAME. THE ORGANIZATION OU'RE
WITH IF ANY. AND YOUR POSITION
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANKS SO MUCH. MISTER
MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE PARENT COMPANY BETTER KNOWN
AROUND THE CAPITOL IS KHALIFA.
WHEN THE LARGEST VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CANNABIS BUSINESSES
IN SUPPORT OF OUR SMALL GROWERS.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THIS
MORNING THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
CAN WORK WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE MORNING
TYLER MITCHELL- IF I MAY I DROVE
ALL THE WAY FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO
CAN I TAKE A FIFTEEN SECOND
UNDER WILL DO FIFTEEN SECONDS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FIFTEEN
SECONDS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE US FARMERS ARE
THE FOUNDATION OF OUR WORLD.
OPPOSITION SIXTY FOUR CREATED
INEQUITIES IN THE DISTRIBUTION
MODEL CANVAS FARMERS DESERVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING THE
FARM TO THE CONSUMER AND SIMILAR
PLATFORMS AS CRAFT BEER AND
WINERIES A DIRECT MARKETING
MODEL REDUCES THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT FOR THE CANNABIS
CULTIVATOR. ONE SOLUTION
CANNABIS CULTIVATORS DESERVE THE
RIGHT. OF EQUITABLE FORMAT FOR
PROCESSING PACKAGING AND HOLDING
A PRODUCT FOR DIRECT MARKETING
IS C. AS A PILOT PROGRAM
CONSISTING OF. BUT NOT LIMITED
TO A COOP ASSOCIATION
DISTRIBUTION. LIKE A BY RIGHT
OKAY AND THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- KEVIN BUSH SHAMA SOCIAL
EQUITY CULTIVATOR THE BILL AND
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS KRISTIN CALLAHAN I'M A
CULTIVATOR AND LAKE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA- I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND I HAVE SUBMITTED A
DOCUMENT AND THAT WILL
REFERENCE. ALL OF THE
DIFFICULTIES THAT THE FARMING
COMMUNITY IS FACING IN
CALIFORNIA AND I ENCOURAGE HAVE
POURED PLEASE REVIEW THE
DOCUMENT THANK- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE IT THAT'S THE
STRUGGLE BACK ON OF THE NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION THANKS- MY NAME IS
DANIEL FOUGHT NO I'M WITH
EMERALD MOUNTAIN FARMS- SMALL
CULTIVATION COMPANY- AND I AM IN
SUPPORT- AND I ALSO ENCOURAGE
YOU GUYS TO READ KRISTIN'S.
THANK YOU DOCUMENTS APPRECIATED
THANKS SO MUCH. NORMAN GRAHAM
EMERALD MOUNTAIN FARMS IN LAKE
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. DIANNE AGAIN SIGN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE NEVADA
COUNTY CANNABIS AND AN ALLIANCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GAIL
GEHRINGER WITH CALIFORNIA NORMAL
IN SUPPORT OF THE SMALL FARMERS
AND SMALL RETAILERS THANK YOU.
JUDE CHILDREN PRESIDENT OF
MENDOCINO CANNABIS ALLIANCE IN
ORDER OF A RETAIL OF FACILITY IN
MENDOCINO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. A SHOW
COMMISSION CAR- OWNER OF TWO
SMALL CULTIVATIONS IN HUMBLE IN
NEVADA COUNTY I ALSO OWN A
LICENSED RETAIL DELIVERY IN
OAKLAND AND I AM STILL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KEEP A SMALL
FARMERS GOING THANK YOU THOUSAND
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATED THANKS IS WHAT I
GET FOR LET IT SLIP IN. MONEY
MEN COUNTY AND THE FOUNDER OF
THE KALO CANNABIS ADVOCACY GROUP
ANNOUNCES THAT ON THE POLICY
COMMITTEE OF THE MENDOCINO
CANNABIS ALLIANCE AND I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS GINA RODRIGUEZ I AM A
FARMER MENDOCINO COUNTY AND A
MEMBER OF THE MENDOCINO CANNABIS
ALLIANCE AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOANNA CEDAR POLICY CHAIR CINEMA
COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WHAT DID YOU BRING
EVERY CONSTITUENT YOU HAVE HERE
NOW WE'VE GOT THOUSANDS WE
OPERATE. JUSTIN MY NAME IS SAM
DELA PAZ I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF HASSLE FARMERS GRANGE AND I.
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO SPEAK
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE GRANGE AS WELL
COLLECTIVELY. REPRESENTING FIVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LASKAR RUTHERFORD WE
CULTIVATE NEVADA COUNTY
DISTRIBUTE MANUFACTURE OUT OF
MONTEREY- DEAD STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS DAN TURBIE FEEL PROUD
MEMBER OF MENDOCINO CANNABIS
ALLIANCE AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
AM RAINY THIS IS A JACK CAL MAKE
AND- FAMA IN MENDOCINO COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. SURVEYED AS A JACK
FROM MENDOCINO- COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT IS B. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS DANIEL MONTERO I
SERVICE CHAIR FOR THE SANITY
CANNABIS EQUITY WORKING GROUP
AND I'M CO FOUNDER THE BEAR THAT
YOU KNOW CANNABIS ALLIANCE AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS
I ON A GRIGORY FROM HUMBLE
SYNCHRONICITY IS FARMING PART OF
H. CGA. AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ADRIAN KEYS ON THE PRESIDENT OF
THE BOARD OF THE TRINITY COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN A LICENSED
CULTIVATOR AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU TO
THAT THANK YOU. MY NAME'S
MADISON SHOCKLEY ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CANNABIS EQUITY
POLICY COUNCIL. WE REPRESENTS
SOCIAL EQUITY RETAILERS ACROSS
THE STATE. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M TIM CLARK LEGACY
CULTIVATOR AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NAME S PATRICIA ALIVE I AM A
CALIFORNIA BOARD CERTIFIED
ENGINEER IN TRAINING I'M A
MEMBER OF THE MEDICINE NO
HUMBOLDT AND TRINITY I CANNABIS
ALLIANCES I REPRESENT THIRTY
LEGACY FARMERS AND WE ALL
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO MICHAEL
KATZ EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
MENDOCINO CANNABIS ALLIANCE AND
REGIONAL CHAIR OF ORIGINS
COUNCIL FOR MENDOCINO COUNTY AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS. HI
MY NAME'S PHIL CREWS I'M A
LEGACY FARMER FROM MENDOCINO
COUNTY. THE OWNER OF MENDOCINO
FAMILY FARMS AND WE REALLY TRULY
NEED THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS MARTY
KLEIN. I'M A CRAFT CANNABIS
FARMER MENACE IN ACCOUNTING I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU. I'M
KAREN HESSLER WITH AMARANTH
FORMS THIS IS MY HUSBAND TOM AND
MY DAUGHTER YVONNE WHERE
HERITAGE FARM WITH THREE
GENERATIONS OF A FARM AND WE
CAME HERE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANKS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THEN ON ALL SORTS OF
TROUBLE UP FEEL FREE- MARC
SCHAFFER I WAS A FARMER UNTIL MY
FARMS NOW BEING CLOSED- FOUNDING
BOARD MEMBER OF MCA. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS ALL OF RUSSELL
PARENT PARENT FAMILY FARM I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
RICHARD. MY NAME IS STILL IN MY
TOLL ON OUR UP AND OPERATOR OF
MOTTOLA VALLEY SUN GROWN BOARD
MEMBER OF H. C. G. A. AND
PRESIDENT OF THE LOST COAST
FARMERS GUILD I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD DAY MADELINE TO LAPID'S
ACTIVE DIRECTOR FOR HUMBOLDT
COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE REGIONAL
CHAIR OF ORIGINS COUNCIL AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GINNING COLEMAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ORIGINS
COUNCIL STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. I'M JOSH FREE-
GROWER HUMBLE COUNTY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OR IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO-
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. NOT SEEING
ANYBODY- SO LET'S GO TO PHONE
LINES ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION THE PHONE LINES
REMINDER THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH IF ANY
YOUR POSITION IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OPERATOR
LET'S OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR.-AB TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE. THANK
YOU AYE MR IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO- AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WILL BEGIN
APPLYING TWENTY FOUR ZERO BUT.
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES I'M I AM MY
NAME IS VIRGIL GRANT FROM
CALIFORNIA MINORITY ALLIANCE-
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
RETAILER AND ALSO CULTIVATOR IN
SOUTHERN HUMBOLDT COME IN
STRONGLY- HELPFUL OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. ONE FORTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS OMAR
FIGUEROA AND I AM A CANNABIS
LAWYER IN CINEMA COUNTY I AM
HONORED TO JOIN ALL OF US WHO
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LIFELINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE GOT A LOT
OF FOLKS ON THE LINE LET'S JUST
KEEP IT TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND JUST
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THAT BE
GREAT THANKS FOLKS. THANK YOU
ASSURE GO ONLINE THIRTY
FOUR YEAR OLD BUT. HI MY NAME IS
MITCHELL COLE BEAR AND I
STRONGLY I'M A CAN OF A SINGLE
PAYER ADVOCATE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT CULTIVATORS BEING ABLE
TO REDUCE THEIR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND PACKAGING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I WAS FOLKS LET'S
NOT USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SLIDE IN SOME POLICY POSITIONS
WE KNOW THE BILL AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE THE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR TWENTY SIX NINETY
ONE THANKS AGAIN. I ONE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD MS AND.
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
THIS IS JONATHAN BUSCO
REPRESENTING THE COACHELLA
VALLEY CANNABIS ALLIANCE NETWORK
AND WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
. FIFTY FIVE YEAR OPEN. THAT
COULD LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
RUNNING THAT OUT BETWEEN GONNA
DISPOSE I COULD OWNERS IN
WORKERS ASSOCIATE ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD TODAY I
STAND WITH THE SMALL FARMER
HOWEVER IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE
THANK THANK YOU THANKS. ONE ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS THROUGHOUT THE MOST
BECAUSE THE PRODUCT ON THE
LEGACY FORMER FOR MENDOCINO
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ONE ONE THREE YOUR
OPEN. AT ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS MICHAEL LONG.
AND WHAT'S EMERALDS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WHY ONE
THIRTY SIX YOU ARE. HELLO MY
NAME IS KAREN BYERS I'M WITH
MENDOCINO CANNABIS RESOURCE
ADVANCE I HOLD THE CDL LICENSE-
CANNABIS EVENT ORGANIZED
RECYCLING AND I AM STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SIX NINE ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY ROLLINS
OWNER OF LUMINESCENT FARMS AND
ABOUT A COUNTY CAMPUS ONLY
NUMBER NINE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SIX NINE ONE. THANK YOU.
I WANT FOR THANK YOU SIR MR ONE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JOHN.
CALIFORNIANS I'M PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO CANNABIS
RETAILERS ALLIANCE. AND WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY FOR EUROPE
. HELLO HI MY NAME IS PATTY
LINEAR I AM THE OWNER AND
OPERATOR OF THE BALL FARM IN
LAKE COUNTY NOBLE GARDENS AND I
AM EMPHATICALLY SUPPORTING THE
BILL. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEAN KELLY
RIGHT PRESIDENT FOUNDER OF
SILICON VALLEY CANNABIS ALLIANCE
REPRESENTING HEALERS IN SANTA
CLARA AND SAN MATEO COUNTY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DANIEL
THINK COTTAGE CULTIVATOR NEVADA
COUNTY AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANKS ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS EMILY PORTER
I AM IN ABOUT A COUNTY CANNABIS
ALLIANCE MEMBER AND A COMPLIANCE
CONSULTANT IN ABOUT A COUNTY AND
I AM IN TRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICH MILLER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR AMERICAN
ALLIANCE FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS
STRONG SUPPORT THE TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES RUN ADWORDS I SAID ON
THE POLICY CHAIR OF MCA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE. THANK
YOU. ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR UP. HI
SEAN O'CONNOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF AXIS OF LOVE- LEGACY PATIENT
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FERRO
DONALD LEGACY FORMER MENDOCINO
COUNTY BOARD MEMBER ORIGINS
COUNCIL BOARD MEMBER MENDOCINO
CANNABIS ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR OPEN. MY
NAME'S KEEP A KEEP THEM UNDER
CARRILLO IRAQ'S THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN UNSUCCESSFULLY WE'VE GOT
SANTANA ANGELES AND PRESIDENT OF
THE BUS EQUITY- OWNERS FROM
WORKING WITH. ALTHOUGH I
FANTASIZE WITH MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS BOB FARMERS IN A FELT
THE IMPACT OF THE WAR ON DRUGS
I'M NOT SUPPOSE THAT THE
RETAILER AB. TWENTY SIX NINETY
ONE THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MARIA BY THE OWNER OF GOLD COAST
BOTANICAL FARM LABOR AND MEMBER
OF NEVADA COUNTY CAMPUS CLIENT
FROM THE PORT ITSELF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR OPEN. RAMOS CHUCK FERGUSON
. AND I'M ON SMALL CRAFT
CANNABIS FARMER AND A MEMBER OF
MCA IN MENDOCINO COUNTY AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE
GOVERNOR SKEWS ME ONE MOMENT.
WINDS ARE NOW WILL GO TO ONE OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS LOUIS HARRIS I'M OF
SOCIAL EQUITY INVESTOR AND-
RETAIL IN LOS ANGELES. IN
SUPPORT OF THE LEGACY FARMERS
BUT OPPOSING A. B. TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
TAMARA KEPT BACK ON OPERATOR OF
AN EQUITY LIKE WHAT STATE FARM
THAT GOOD GOOD FARM IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY CALLING SUPPORT OF TWO
SIX NINE ONE. THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTY TO YOUR OUT. I'M KAREN
HAGEN OWNER OF GREEK HELD THE
HEALING TREE LAKE ELSINORE
CALIFORNIA AND CULTIVATION I AND
I AM IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO SIX
NINE ONE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR OP ED. WELL I
THINK THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT
OUT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY. HI MY NAME'S DANIEL
COOPER WHAT HILL CRAFT FARMS
NEVADA COUNTY I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE.
NO ONE THIRTY FIVE ONE MORE SHOT
. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIA'S
WITH MARGARET VISORS REPORTING
OUR HUNDRED LEGACY FARMERS CRAFT
CANNABIS FARMERS- ON IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN.
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I TRY ONE FIFTY FIVE
AGAIN PLEASE CALL AT. ONE FIFTY
FIVE. ALL RIGHT ONE ONE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS MAGGIE PHILLIPS FOUR NINE THE
DIRECTOR OF MEMBERSHIP AND
EDUCATION AT THE NEVADA COUNTY
CANNABIS ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
FOUR YOU ARE ALREADY. HOW MANY
HAVE YOU MONTANA OWNER OPERATOR
OF DR NINETY OUR RETAIL
CULTIVATION IN THE CITY LIGHTS-
LOS ANGELES AND VICE CHAIR OF
THE USED TO BE A I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REPORT I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE SOCIAL EQUITY OWNERS MARKET
EXPECTATION AS WELL AS THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF OUR ACT AND I
OPPOSE AB TWO SIX NINE ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
FERRIS MALAM OWNER NETWORKING AT
DELL PC IN NEVADA COUNTY CALLING
STRONG SUPPORT AT AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M WHAT OKAY EXCUSE ME-
OUTLINED ONE NINE- ONE NINETY
TWO YOU'RE OPEN. ONE NINETY TWO.
WELL HELLO HELLO YES HI MY
NAME'S DENISEDORING AND IF YOU
CAN HEAR ME I'M PRETTY SURE LIVE
ABOUT SHALL I IN SAN FRANCISCO-
AND THEN BACK IN OF LAVA PATIENT
. AT THE CAN AND- PROVIDING TO
PASS TO- FOLKS YOU CAN'T FOR.
AND I SUPPORT- NUMBER OF BILLS
TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE THANK YOU
MUCH. THANKS ONE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND IT'S NOT BE
A BROWNING I'M WITH HIGHER OR
DEPORTING OVER A HUNDRED PLUS
LEGACY CULTIVATORS AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY FOUR
EXCUSE ME ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ALLISON
VIGIL FROM KOREA LARA WANNA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE SOCIAL
EQUITY HONORED THE WORK OF THE
VOCATION REPRESENTING EQUITY
RETALIATES AND WE OPPOSE AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
. WHAT A WHITE ONE NINETY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. GRADING GRADING MY
NAME IS NICK KNIGHT DANIEL A
MEMBER OF THE SOCIAL EQUITY
HONOR TO WORKERS ASSOCIATION I
AM OFF OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD
LIAISON FOR AROUND IRAQ
ATTENTION EQUITY RESELLER IN THE
INNER CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE ARE
ONE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
GOING OUT TO BE IN THIS INDUSTRY
APART MINORITIES BE IN TE
INDUSTRY AND IT. HAPPENS THIS IS
GOING TO UNDERMINE EVERYTHING
ABOUT THE SOCIAL EQUITY THANK
YOU EVERYTHING THAT COULD
POSSIBLY REQUESTED WE ARE TO
EIGHTY. NINE ALL RIGHT THANKS
MUCH. ONCE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I AM SENDING. THAT ARE MISSING
ARE AND I GUESS HE CALLED AND I
STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHT TWO SIX
ONE THANK YOU. YOUR TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO NAME IS JENNIFER
I'M AT FOR. AND MEMBER MOBILE
COUNTY A LOT WAS IN JEOPARDY
LOSING OUR FARM IT'S THE OF
RETAIL. OF COMMERCE AND I AM
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI FOUR
NINETY COOLEY UP THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YEAH TO TEN PLEASE
AHEAD. RIGHT IS SHARON ON OF THE
SHIP SO IT COULD OWNERS AND
WORKERS BUDGET REFERENCE A COULD
B. SEVEN AND WE ARE A JUST
NINETY. THANK YOU. AB ONE TWO
EIGHTEEN YEAR. HELLO MY- HELLO
MY NAME IS ADAM J. I'M ON THE
DIRECT OF A LONG BEACH BLACK
RESOURCES AMONG FARMER AND
LEGACY RETAIL OPERATOR AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE- THIS BILL WE
NEED MORE RETAIL- ACT THAT'S
NOT- WHERE ROUTE RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LET'S GET ONE
LAST QUICK FINAL REMINDER ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO- SB. TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE TO NINETEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. I NAME IS BOB UP FOR I AM
OUT OF THE FOR OF THE- O. C. A.
WE STRONGLY OF. EIGHT TWO SIX
NINE ONE THANK THANK YOU THANK
YOU. TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO TWENTY SEVEN. ONE
MORE SHOT TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
ON YOU. THERE ARE MY NAME IS THE
BEST GLOBE I'M A PROUD MEMBER OF
THE NEVADA COUNTY CANNABIS
ALLIANCE AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB TO SEARCH NINE ONE. THANK YOU
THANKS. TWO THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE
YOU LOSER AND I'M A MEMBER OF C.
C. A. G. AND MCA AND I'M CALLING
BECAUSE REPORT. TO SIX NINE ONE
THANK. YOU THANKS SO MUCH. TWO
THIRTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS CHRISTIAN NEED TO AND IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. A SIMILAR TERMINAL. RUSSIA
THANKS LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD FIFTY ONE. JOINT OR- FIFTY
ONE- PATHMARK BY THE BALLOT BOX. FIFTY ONE YEAR OPEN MORE HELLO
MY INNER JUKEBOX I'M HERE WITH
MY HUSBAND MICHAEL BURNETT WE
HAVE- BUT THING ON THE PATIENTS
ARE QUALITY OF ORGANIC SMALL
FARM PLANTS. YOU KNOW THE ONLY
THE HEMP FARMERS AND WE NEED TO
THAT BILL WITH ALL THE FAR
NATIONAL RIDE THANKS SO MUCH
THANK. AND ADDRESS CHAIR WE HAVE
ONE FINAL AND QUEUING UP WITH AN
OPERATOR AND THEN WILL CONCLUDE.
RIGHT THANKS. THANK YOU. TWO
THIRTY EIGHT- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH REMEMBER THE MENDOCINO
CANNABIS ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH GET
ONE MARK HERS QUEUING UP I
GUESS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
THAT. TWO TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO TWENTY TWO. NO TWO
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE SOME ARGUING UP SORRY ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME BERKELEY LEFT YET I'M A
RETAIL OPERATOR IN ALONG THE
SHALL APPOINT A MY- ALMOST ON
THE BORDER DIRECT FOR. LONG
BEACH CA WAS SUPPOSED AND NIGHTS
THE UP THIS BILL THANK YOU. WHAT
ARE. PLEASE GIVE ME TO TWENTY
TWO YEAR OPEN. MY NAME IS MEGAN
AND I'M A LEGACY FARMER LOCATED
IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY I'M IN DANGER
OF LOSING MY FARM DUE TO LACK OF
RETAIL ACCESS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN
. I BELIEVE HE WORKS BETTER IN
NEVADA COUNTY AND MEMBER OF THE
NEVADA COUNTY CAMPUS ALLIANCE IN
STRONG STRONG SUPPORTERS STILL
DON'T SEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I MISTER CHAIR WE GET
EXHAUSTED Q. GRAHAM BRING ABOUT
A COLLEGE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS START WHEN MR CHEN-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK COUPLE QUESTIONS I WANT TO
THANK GD WOULD FOR BRING THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO HAVE. MORE ACCESS FOR OUR
CONSUMERS ARE CALIFORNIANS WHEN
IT COMES TO CANNABIS- THERE'S NO
DENYING THE MEDICAL. POWERS OF
CANNABIS AS WELL AS- WE HAVE
MORE FOLKS THAT ARE HAVING
ACCESS IT WAS LIKE THEY WERE
GOING TO HAVE A INDIVIDUAL BLACK
MARKET OPERATORS YEAH. HOWEVER I
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS IN THE
AREA. SATURATION SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE ALLOWING FIVE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED OUTDOOR
CULTIVATORS FOUR. EIGHT
TEMPORARY CULTIVATOR RETAIL
LICENSES. AND THAT EQUATES TO MY
UNDERSTANDING FORTY TWO.
THOUSAND- LICENSES. SO IF THIS
WAS TO CONTINUE WANT TO BELIEVE
IN AREAS SUCH AS YOURS I
REPRESENTS ORANGE COUNTY THE
DEBATE OVER SATURATION- OF THESE
RETAILERS- IN MY COMMUNITIES. I
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAN FOR THE QUESTION I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT EVERY LICENSE EVERY EVERY
LICENSED. SMALL CANDLES OPERATOR
WILL DO THIS- BUT THERE ARE SOME
THAT WILL WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS- I THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR. SMALL MEAN.
MAYBE HUNDREDS OF DAVID'S
VERSUS. A FEW GOLIATHS UP THERE-
TAKE TO ACTUALLY GET THEIR
PRODUCT IN FRONT OF PEOPLE.
EXAMPLE THE EMERALD COP WHICH IS
ONE OF THE PREMIER CANNABIS
EVENTS IN IN CALIFORNIA. A SMALL
GROWERS. CAN'T JUST SELL THEIR
PRODUCT THEY CAN BRING IT AND
HAVE IT HAVE IT JUDGE BUT THEY
CAN'T SELL THEIR PRODUCT WITHOUT
GOING TO A DISTRIBUTOR. NOW THAT
IS THE WAY IT USED TO BE- WHEN
THIS HAPPENED BUT BACK IN THE
PROP TWO FIFTEEN DAYS OR EVEN
EARLY ON IN THE PROCESS. IT'S
JUST ABOUT GETTING MORE VARIETY
GIVING THE SMALL GUYS A CHANCE
AND- THAT I DON'T BELIEVE ITALY
TOOK OVER SATURATION TIME BY
EIGHT EVENTS WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT. EVERYBODY SETTING UP A
SEPARATE LICENSE IT'S NOT. FOR
ON A DAILY BASIS IS REALLY
PRETTY LIMITED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ANSWER- I. HAVE BEEN A
BIG PROPONENT OF EXPANDING
CANNABIS- AT THIS CURRENT STAGE
I'M HAVE TO LAY OFF. I DO
RESERVE THE RIGHT AT THIS BILL
MOVE FOR SOMEONE TO. LOOK AT
WITH KEEN INTEREST ON TO TRY TO.
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME TO
SUPPORT THE BILL LATER DOWN THE
LINE. BUT I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
DR WOULD- FOR BRING THIS BILL IT
TO OUR ATTENTION. THANK YOU SOME
NUMBER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. DR WEBER. GOING
BACK TO WHAT I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING HERE THE ENTIRE TIME
RUNNING IN BETWEEN COMMITTEES
BUT- I'M- THERE SEEMS TO BE VIA
PHONE AND ALSO WITH REGISTERED
OPPOSITION- I'M ISSUE WITH
SOCIAL EQUITY AND THE MINORITY
COMMUNITY BEING OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. CAN YOU PLEASE ELABORATE
ON. WHETHER OR NOT THEIR
CONCERNS ARE VALID OR NOT. WELL
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE HAD OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WHO WERE
SOCIAL EQUITY LICENSE HOLDERS
RETAILERS IN THIS IN THIS ROOM
HERE SO I WOULDN'T SAY THAT IS
UNIVERSAL- IN THAT RESPECT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE SUPPORT FROM EVERY
ASPECT OF THE INDUSTRY- IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SO. SO
WHETHER MAYBE SOME CONCERN BY
SOME SOCIAL EQUITY- LICENSEES-
COMMON DENOMINATOR HERE IS ALL
THE ALL THE OPPOSITION COME FROM
LARGE URBAN AREAS AND THIS IS
JUST A MICROCOSM WHAT I FIGHT
EVERY DAY TO GET RESOURCES FOR
MIGHT RURAL COUNTIES. UP AND THE
WIND IT WASN'T JUST MY RURAL
COUNTIES THAT REPRESENT HERE
ACCOUNTS FROM ALL OVER THE STATE
SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THIS IS NOT MEANT IN ANY WAY TO
UNDERWRITE SOCIAL EQUITY IF THAT
WERE THE CASE WE WOULDN'T HAVE
SOCIAL EQUITY LICENSE HOLDERS
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF THAT.
YOU MAY HAVE MISSED THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE OUT OF THE ROOM BUT-
THANK YOU THEY DID. THANK YOU
MISTER IBSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I WAS OUT OF THE ROOM
BUT I WAS TRYING TO WATCH IT ON
TV AND HEARD THE TESTIMONIES AND
I LIKE- DOCTOR WEBER- REPRESENTS
LOS ANGELES IN A LOT OF SOCIAL
EQUITY- INDIVIDUALS AND GROUPS
HAVE REACHED OUT TO ME- WITH
RESPECT TO THEIR BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S WOULD DISENFRANCHISE
THOSE SOCIAL EQUITY GROUPS AND I
REALIZED I DID HEAR. SOME OF THE
AYE VOTES- FOR ORGANIZATIONS
THAT REPRESENT SOME SOCIAL
EQUITY HOWEVER- THIS IS- THE
CONCERNS- DO YOU BUT AS IS BILL
MOVE FORWARD- I JUST NEED YOUR
INSURANCE THAT YOU'LL CERTAINLY
BE WORKING WITH OPPOSITION TO
TRY TO I'M STRENGTHENED TRY TO
FIND A MIDDLE GROUND THAT PEOPLE
CAN WHO ARE REGISTERED
OPPOSITION YOU CAN'T PLEASE
EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WE WORKED SO
HARD IN LOS ANGELES TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S SOCIAL EQUITY ESPECIALLY
AMONG THOSE IN THE CANDICE BASS
ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN- WHO ARE
EXISTING THE LOS ANGELES AREA TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD- AND THEY'RE
FILLING THAT THIS IN FACT THIS
BILL WOULD. DISENFRANCHISE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND SO I NEED NEED
TO MAKE SURE- THAT THAT
CONSTITUENCIES VOICES HEARD IN
THIS SPACE BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT THEIR VOICES ARE TAKEN IN
CONSIDERATION MOVING FORWARD
WHAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONCERN AND MY DOOR IS ALWAYS
OPEN ALWAYS HAPPY TO WORK WITH-
WITH BOTH SIDES ON AN ISSUE- YOU
KNOW. I JUST THINK OF THE
THOUSANDS OF LEGACY FARMERS
MULTI GENERATION FARMERS THAT
ARE ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO
IS IT OKAY TO TELL THEM THAT
THEY CAN. PROSPER THEY CAN'T BE
SUCCESSFUL. IS THAT IS THAT OKAY
- IS IT OKAY TO TAKE THEIR
LIVELIHOODS AWAY THIS DOESN'T I
BELIEVE IN ANYWAY TAKE AWAY
LIVELIHOODS MATTER FACT I
BELIEVE BY BRINGING MORE
PRODUCTS OUT THERE AND MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO SEE
A WHAT THE QUALITY OF ARTISANAL
GROWERS CAN BE IT'S A PLUS FOR
THE INDUSTRY. I CAN'T HELP RIGHT
NOW THE LACK OF RETAIL OUT THERE
THAT'S THE SPACE OUT THERE THAT
WAS PUT IN THE PROPOSITION. DO
AND THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF LOCAL CONTROL IF THERE WAS A
WAY TO CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC WE'D
BE ALL OVER THAT. BUT RIGHT NOW
IT DOES APPEAR TO BE A SO THIS
NOT ANYTHING ATTEMPT UNDERMINE
ANY EQUITY. BUT I WOULD JUST ASK
FOR CONSIDERATION FOR SOME OF
THE LEGACY FARMERS. WHO WILL
LOSE THEIR FARMS WHO LOSE
EVERYTHING. AND- I JUST I WAS
AFTER SCHOOL. AND SURGEON MISTER
MAY I. AND CERTAINLY IS NOT OUR
INTENT OR MY ARTICULATION THAT
WE WANT TO HURT ANYONE
ESPECIALLY THOSE THOSE FARMERS-
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES
SPECIFICALLY IS DEALING WITH AN
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY BLACK MARKET
WHO ARE YOU KNOW WHO WE NEED TO
DEAL WITH THAT I'M NOT SURE
THAT. WE REALLY SERIOUS IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO PUT THAT BUSINESS
OUT OF BUSINESS I'M MOVING
FORWARD SO THAT THE LEGAL-
GROWERS AND CULTIVATORS CAN
CONTINUE TO YOU KNOW DO THAT AND
NOT BE BEAR WITH THE AMOUNT OF
TAXES ALSO DEALING WITH- THE
ILLEGAL ILLICIT BLACK MARKET
UNDERMINING- THIS LEGAL
PROFESSION THAT CALIFORNIA
VOTERS HAVE VOTED INTO LAW- SO
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THAT. AS
WELL SO IT WAS A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I SUPPORT THAT AS WELL-
WE ABSOLUTELY NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ALLOW
LEGAL- LICENSED OPERATORS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE BLACK MARKET
TO NOT. NAME IS GIVEN ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES THE NON DOCTOR
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE- I JUST JUST
A THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THESE WERE NOT ALL MY
CONSTITUENTS I JUST WANT TO
STRESS ONCE AGAIN THAT WOULD
HAVE BROUGHT WE HAVE SUPPORT
FROM EVERY ASPECT OF THE
INDUSTRY HERE- AND THIS IS NOT A
MEANT MEANT TO UNDERMINE
ANYTHING. THIS IS A CLASSIC
STRUGGLE OF SMALL RURAL AREAS
TRYING TO COMPETE WITH LARGER
BEEN AREAS I DIDN'T HEAR ANYBODY
FROM A LOT FROM A SMALL RURAL
AREA. IN OPPOSITION THIS BILL
BUT I EVERYTHING I DID HERE WAS
ALL ABOUT LARGE URBAN AREAS AND
- WE NEED TO FIND A DIFFERENT
BATTLE THAT'S TO GET EXPAND
RETAIL ACCESS HERE. THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THAT IS ABOUT GETTING
PRODUCTS TO MARKET GIVING THESE
FARMERS A CHANCE TO SURVIVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY AND THAT BUT BUT
DEFINITELY ENCOURAGE YOU YOU
KNOW WE HEARD A LOT OF
COMMENTARY- THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A
REMARKABLY COMPLICATED SPACE
WITH A LOT OF MOVING PIECES NOT
ALL OF WHICH ARE WRAPPED UP IN
YOUR BILL- THAT BY. YOU KNOW ONE
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION-
WITH THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE- TO ENSURE THAT THE BILL
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
UPLIFTING SMALL CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS- WITHOUT UNDULY
DISADVANTAGING. LICENSED
CANNABIS RETAILERS AND WITH
THAT- I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. THANKS MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I FOR. FLOOR AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOUGHT. CAN NOT FUNDING
CUNNINGHAM DALY. FONG GIPSON.
GRAYSON GRAYSON I FOR ONE. WE
MAY I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA I
SAW MULLIN SALAS THING WEBER.
THAT IS SIX VOTES WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS A
GRIMACE PROJECT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY ALL ONE REMINDER THAT
I SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED AT THE
TOP OF THE HEARING IS THAT- FOR
ME TO TESTIMONY FOR AT ON
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE HAVE A FORTY FIVE
MINUTE TO CAP PER BILL- THAT
WILL MOVE WE BARELY FIT UNDER ON
THAT ONE- AND WILL CONTINUE. TO
IMPLEMENT ON FUTURE BILLS I SEE
MR SANTIAGO SITTING IN THE
AUDIENCE- WITH ITEM NUMBER THREE
ON THE AGENDA AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
ONE PHONE NUMBER SANTIAGO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
HEY MISTER CHAIRPERSON LIKE TO
TAKE THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL. AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE WOULD CREATE
EDUCATIONAL NOTICING
REQUIREMENT. AS A POTENTIAL
ADOPTERS OF DOGS AND CATS WOULD
KNOW HOW TO TREAT THEIR PETS-
NEARLY ONE IN FIVE HOUSEHOLDS
ADOPTED PETS DURING A PANDEMIC.
HOWEVER NONE OF THE SHELTERS OR
AGENCIES WERE REQUIRED TO HAND
OUT ANY SORT OF. A STANDARD FOR
CARE OF THESE. OF THESE-
ANIMALS. BEING PETS AND DOGS.
AND CATS. NOW THAT THE STATE
WILL BE HARDER FOR OWNERS TO
PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL CARE THAT
THE WAR- WHILE THEY WERE STAYING
AT HOME. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE
REQUIRE SHELTERS AND ADOPTION
AGENCIES TO POST THE WELL FOR
DOGS AND CATS NOTICED EDUCATE
POTENTIAL. ADOPTERS HEALTHCARE-
DOGS AND CATS SHOULD BE TREATED
PART ADOPTION SO THAT THE
ANIMALS RECEIVED- A LIFE OF
PROPER CARE AND ATTENTION. WE
HAVE TO WITNESSES MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE SIZE AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR- WORKING WITH US- AND
WE'LL BEGIN WITH A NECKLACE AS A
CAT AND THEN- JUDY- MANGUSTA
WHO'D BE ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BRING PROCEED YEAH
THANKS VERY MUCH. HELLO CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SACKETT DIRECTOR OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION PROUD
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. ACCORDING
TO THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO A. P. P. A. NATIONAL
PET OWNERS SURVEY 70% OF U. S.
HOUSEHOLDS ON A PET. WHICH
EQUATES TO NINETY EIGHT POINT
FIVE MILLION HOMES ANIMAL
COMPANIONSHIP BECAME ESPECIALLY
APPEALING DURING THE ISOLATION
OF THE PANDEMIC. WE CELEBRATE
AMERICANS OPENING THEIR HOMES TO
DOGS AND CATS WHO NEED A LOVING
FAMILY. BUT WITH THE STATE RE
OPENING SADLY SOME ADOPTERS
ENCOUNTER CHALLENGES IN CARING
FOR THEM AND HAVE OPTED TO
RELINQUISH THEM TO SHELTERS OR
RESCUE GROUPS. CURRENTLY PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE ANIMAL SHELTERS AND
RESCUE GROUPS MAY BUT ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO INFORM POTENTIAL
ADOPTERS OF THE STANDARDS OF
CARE DOGS AND CATS DESERVE. TO
ENSURE THESE ANIMALS ARE TREATED
APPROPRIATELY AND HAVE GREATER
ODDS OF STAYING IN THAT HOME.
POTENTIAL ADOPTERS MUST FULLY
UNDERSTAND THAT DOGS AND CATS
REQUIRE A CERTAIN LEVEL OF CARE
THAT IT TENDS TO ALL OF THEIR
NEEDS. THIS CONVERSATION SHOULD
OCCUR PRIOR TO MAKING WHAT
SHOULD BE A LIFELONG COMMITMENT
TO THAT ANIMAL. DOGS AND CATS
HAVE NEEDS BEYOND FOOD WATER AND
SHELTER WHICH IS WHAT CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES. DOGS AND CATS
SHOULD BE RESPECTED AS LIVING
BEINGS THAT HAVE PHYSICAL MENTAL
AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH NEEDS. IN
FACT STUDIES CITED IN THE
JOURNAL OF MEDICAL ETHICS HAVE
SHOWN THAT DOGS CAN EXPERIENCE
POSITIVE EMOTIONS. AS WELL AS
OTHER SIMILAR. EMPATHIC
RESPONSES THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF FELINE
PRACTITIONERS HAS ALSO STATED
THAT CATS EXPERIENCE THEIR OWN
EMOTIONAL A MOTIONS THAT NEED TO
BE SUPPORTED. THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS TO EDUCATE POTENTIAL
ADOPTERS OF THESE IMPORTANT
NEEDS. TO HELP MINIMIZE FUTURE
BURNING QUESTIONS NOT ONLY ARE
WE RELINQUISHMENT TRAGIC FOR
BOTH THE ANIMAL AND THE FAMILY.
BUT THEY ALSO COST TAXPAYERS
MONEY TO RE HOME OR EUTHANIZE
THE ANIMAL. TO BE CLEAR THIS LAW
PUT INTO PLACE EDUCATIONAL
DISCLOSURES. TO AN ADOPTER THE
BILL DOES NOT PENALIZE AN
ADOPTER IN ANY WAY. THE ONLY
MINOR PENALTY WOULD BE TO A
SHELTER OR OTHER LISTED ENTITY
WHICH REFUSES TO POST THE NOTICE
AFTER A SIXTY DAY WARNING PERIOD
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SACKETT- AND NEXAVAR BELIEVE WE
HAVE MS MAKE- SO ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY HIS
MAKERS AS LANDO. LETTER
TESTIFIED. PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU VERY HI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS IS JUDY MAN INCLUSO
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION ABOUT
WHAT MY GROUP HAS BEEN WORKING
ON- BILLS TO MINIMIZE THE
SUFFERING OF DOGS AND CATS IN
SHELTERS FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS AND
WE'VE MADE GREAT PROGRESS BUT
THERE IS STILL ROOM TO DO MORE
AND WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO OR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. IT IS AN
EDUCATIONAL BILL ALL AND DURING
THE PANDEMIC THE SHELTERS WERE
CLOSED SO YOU MAY HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION BAD THEY'RE NOT
TAKING IN AS MANY ANIMALS BUT
THAT'S BECAUSE THE DAUGHTERS
WERE SHOT AND THE MANY RESCUES
HAD TO PICK UP THE SLACK AND-
ARE INUNDATED WITH ANIMALS THAT
ARE BEING RELINQUISHED SO- I'M
HERE TO SPEAK- AS NEEDED- AND
THEY'RE STILL ANIMALS BEING
EUTHANIZED WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH THANK THANK YOU MS
MECHANISM APPRECIATE THAT AND I
HAVE TO WITNESSES. I BELIEVE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
I HAVE JOEL TUCKER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION VIA PHONE AND GEORGE
MILLER FROM THE MEME FROM THE
AMERICAN KENNEL CLUB IN PERSON I
THINK- WHILE WE START WITH THE
MISS TUCKER- VIA PHONE OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY. HER LINE.
BECAUSE IT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
NAME IS PARKER THE STATE OF THE
COW ANIMAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF
NONPROFIT AND MUNICIPAL ANIMAL
SHELTER I WANT TO START BY
SAYING THAT WE AGREE THAT
DOCTRINE CAPTIVES ARE GREAT CARE
AND LOVING HOME THIS IS THE WORK
WE SUPPORT EACH AND EVERY DAY
HOWEVER OPPOSITION EXTEND FROM
THE FACT THAT THIS BILL IS
SPECIFIC TARGETING SHELTERS AND
THE PEOPLE WHO ADOPTING THEM.
THERE IS REALLY NO JUSTIFICATION
IN DOING SO WHY DON'T YOU
DISTRIBUTION REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS BILL ONLY TARGETING SHELTER
WHY NOT VETERINARY OFFICE DOORS
AND OTHER PLACES TO REACH PEOPLE
THAT ARE HIRING PAT AND. FINE
OUR HARD WORK UNDER THE FLOOR
SHOW AND ALSO PUT TO FLY
THEMSELVES FOR THE POSTER. THE
BILL MISPLACED. PEOPLE CHOOSE TO
ACQUIRE UNDER FROM SHELTER ARE
DOING VERY YOU MAY TO. A JOB.
SHELTERS NOT JUST IN THE ANIMAL
WE FOR BUT IN WE- THE COUNCIL.
AND PROVIDE OPTION OR- WE WANT
PEOPLE TO COME OUT IN DROVES TO
ADOPT CHILDREN AT TAKEN CHAMPION
THAT DOG CARE ACT UNIQUE. AND
ALLOW SUPPORT BECAUSE THEY THE
ANIMAL BOND FORWARD. BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT SHE DO WHEN AND ARE
. TO IF YOU EITHER. THE
PATTERSON WRONG MAN. OR THE
PERSON HAS UPON. HARDSHIP. WE
WANT TO SHAME PEOPLE FACING
EITHER THE AREA. IF THIS BILL
AND TO DISSUADE PEOPLE ACROSS.
HEALTH ANIMAL SHOW ARE FEWER
ENTERING OUR SINCE THE PANDEMIC
THERE OKAY I'M WELL THE CLIENT
IS A RATE. WHICH SHELTERS ARE
WITH RIGHT NOW OUR SCHOOL GOT.
THIS IS NOT LIKELY DERIVED OFF
AND AT AND- THIS BILL IS NOT A
FEEL GOOD BILL IT IS THE WORK
ABOUT HOW. AND THEIR IN A PAT WE
SHOULD HAVE FAITH IN OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS YOU KERN
TRANSIT A CHANCE ON SO HAD AND
ALLOW TO SUPPORT THE SHOULD LIVE
TAKEN ON. TURN IN THE FUTURE WE
ARE TO VOTE NOW ON. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
MISS TUCKER AND- I DO BELIEVE
MISTER WILL BE. AS A- OPPOSITE
WITNESS TO. SO LET'S HOPE IT UP
TO AN- I WANT TO ADD A IT'S A-
OR- OR NEUTRALITY- IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RE
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN KENNEL CLUB. THANK YOU
TO YOUR OFFICE THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS ON THE AMENDMENTS
AND WE ARE NOT IN A NEUTRAL
POSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
REJECT THANKS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CRISTINA TO
CARL REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO PLEASE TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION AND MOVED TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR MISTER SUMNER
OF YOUR STAFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS SO MUCH. MY NAME'S
JIM GENTS FALLS I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF. DEMOCRATS FOR THE
PROTECTION OF ANIMALS ITS STATE
CHARTER CLUB WITHIN THE LA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. AND WE SUPPORT
A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO
MY NAME IS MANUEL SANTOS-
HOMELESS CAT COLONY CARE GIVER
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY SINGH NINE
LET'S OPEN THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD IDENTIFY
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE. JUST
ADD ON AGAIN- JUST IT JUST TO
ADD YOUR NAME. AND ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH IF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- TO AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO. FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL BEGIN DAY WITHOUT
LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
TWENTY FOUR ONE MORE SHOT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. HELLO CAN ANYONE
HEAR WE CAN'T. HI MY NAME IS
ROCKY I SHALL AND I AM A
RESIDENT OF RICHMOND CALIFORNIA
I AM AN ANIMAL ADVOCATE AND I
ALSO FOUGHT- DOG THE CAT AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE. MY ONE
THIRTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS JULIE WALTERS I LIVE IN
WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA I HAVE
BEEN A DOG FOSTER MOM IN A
LIFELONG ANIMAL THIRTY IS- EVAN
WITH COMPASSIONATE DATE TONIGHT
IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS ANKIT DOLLARS DOLLARS AND I
LIVE IN FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA I
MEAN AND LONG GUARDIAN AND I
SUPPORT THAT SO. ONE THIRTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NOT
A LAW FIRM- I LIVE IN VISTA
CALIFORNIA I PROCESO WORKER AND
A THIRTY TWO ANIMALS AND I.
DON'T ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS IN TURN
YOUR MORE ANY MINUTE I LIVE IN
SAN MATEO CALIFORNIA I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY ONE I WAS- I AM A
REGISTERED VETERINARY TECHNICIAN
AND I WORKED AT A SHELTER FOR
MANY YEARS AND I THOUGHT THESE
ANIMALS FIRST MENU SIMILAR AND
EVEN. DEPUTATION THANK YOU. WHAT
ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
ON MUTE. ONE MORE SHOT ONE FIFTY
. OVER ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S RAE KOTECHA
HASHI FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I NEED SUPPORT AT ONE
EIGHT EIGHT ONE. ONE SIXTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
MICHAEL FOR YOUR MORNING I LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES R. I. AND MAY I
AM A GUARDIAN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I WE CAN HEAR YOU
. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING TO
APPRECIATE IT I'M GOOD VETS
HARMONY MY NAME IS AN ANAGRAM
I'M FROM THE TENDER OF
CALIFORNIA I URGENTLY PLEAD WITH
YOU TO PASS THIS BILL I'M
TOTALLY WHAT. ONE EIGHT EIGHT
THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KELLY
VETO I'M AN ANIMAL GUARDIAN AND
NUMBER OF T. I SEE A FIVE OH ONE
SEE THREE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. TWO
THIRTY FOR YOUR UP. HI MY NAME
IS ALLISON BERNARD AND I LIVE IN
BURLINGAME CALIFORNIA I'M A
MEMBER OF COMPASSION AND BAY AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
TWO FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FORTY TWO AND YOU PLEASE. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
. YEAH MY NAME IS JORGE MARIO I
NEED INCOME PROCEEDS GO ON A
BALANCE HERE WITH A LOT OF LOCAL
SHELTERS AB I SUPPORT THIS BILL
IF INTERNAL BRAINER. THANK TWO
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON EMILY PAPPAS WITH ME
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE THIRTIETH ON
AUTHOR INC AND CHAIRMAN FOR THE
AT MENTION WE ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AND GOING TO NEUTRAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TWO FIFTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. CAPEN
LAWCENTER LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I'M A BOARD MEMBER-
FOR ON ONLY SUNSHINE SANCTUARY
IN A VOLUNTEER CAPTAINS THE
HUMANELY AND IMPROPER MULTIPLE
DOGS AND CATS AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. WE WILL MOVE TO LINE TO SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS THE
CLIP SIMON I LIVE IN MILPITAS
CALIFORNIA I'M AN EDUCATOR AND
I'M RIGHT AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. TWO SIXTY TWO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DR
KENTUCKY I AM HEARING FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND THE
FOUNDER OF THE NONPROFIT HONOR
AND VETERINARY PRACTICE THAT
HARMONY I SUPPORT THAT WAL THANK
YOU. TWO SIXTY FOR YOUR OPEN. HI
THIS IS JULIE BURNETT FROM
SACRAMENTO WITH A GROUP CALLED
FIX FRONT STREET THIS IS A VITAL
EDUCATIONAL TOOL THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
TWO SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTY BEAVER AND
I AM FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT AND
BUILT IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE I
AM HAVE BEEN A LIFELONG ANIMAL
GUARDIAN AND THE ANIMAL RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS AND SUPPORT THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH. THE
EACH ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN. HI THIS IS JULIANA TAIWO
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
FOR SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
YOUR OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JULIA GOODWIN AND FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF WATER THREE LOS
ANGELES I'M A FIERCE ANIMAL
ADVOCATE I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH.
MY FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME ONLY RIGHT I WITH IMPACT
MENTAL AND I HAVE- KNOWN MANY
HAPPENED ON IN MY LIFE AND I
SUPPORT. EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU ONE EIGHTY THREE YOU
ARE A- BY THE FOODS AND MAKE A
CLIMATE ACTIVITY BENNETT AND
MEMEBER I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
RICHARD THANK YOU. I'LL GIVE ONE
QUICK FINAL REMINDER. TO ONE
ZERO EIGHTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CURTIS PALMER
I'M PRESIDENT OF THE ANIMAL
RIGHTS CITIZENS LOBBY GROUP
COMPASSION DAY AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS. WHY
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DIANE AND AVON I'M
COME BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANKS. TWO SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY I'M DOCTOR SIR
STAN ROSENBERG AND I RUN HAPPY
HEN ANIMAL SANCTUARY- AND I'M
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
THANKS SO MUCH SO IS THE ROOSTER
THANK YEAH. YES I THINK OKAY.
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY TWO. HELLO HI NINE AIR
HURT THEN I AM I AM A
VETERINARIAN- WORKING IN
FORENSICS AND THEY WORK WITH THE
SACRAMENTO ANIMAL CRUELTY TASK
FORCE AND I AM IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. TWO SEVENTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. EIGHT TWO SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE ON MUTE. TWO SEVENTY
NINE HELLO HI I DON'T KNOW HER
NAME WE GET AREA HI- HI MY NAME
IS LESLIE MASON- I'M I LIVE IN
INGLEWOOD AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MMHM BOB MISTER CHAIR WE DID IT
THAT'S FOR EVERYBODY THANKS SO
MUCH AND THEN GIVE A BIG SHOUT
OUT TO THE OPERATOR FOR DOING IT
STELLAR JOB TODAY- SO LET'S
BRING BACK THE CALL FOR
QUESTIONS. OR COMMENTS- I THINK
WE'RE STARTING WITH SOME NUMBER
LEAD OVER IN THE CORNER. SO I
THINK THE OFFERING IS STILL I
THINK IT'S AN EXCELLENT BILL TO
MAKE SURE AS AN EDUCATIONAL TOOL
FOR PROSPECTIVE PET OWNERS AS WE
NOW. AND I WILL BEGIN OFFICE
MYSELF WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE GETTING ANIMALS IN THE
GREAT HOMES SO AND MAKE SURE
THEY KEPT THEIR- YOU KNOW TOO
OFTEN WE EVEN SEE THIS A
DIFFERENT HOLIDAYS WERE PEOPLE.
IMPOSED BY DIFFERENT TYPES
ANIMALS AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW
ANIMALS ARE STILL LIVING BEINGS
ARE NOT TOYS THEY'RE NOT FLUFFY.
TEDDY BEARS OF LIKE THAT TO THE
POINT TO REMIND THEM OF THEIR
NEEDS LIKE THAT. SO I'M VERY
MUCH HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER YES
MR GRAYSON. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- WHEN READING THIS
BILL THE ANALYSIS AT LEAST TO ME
IT BECAME A STATEMENT OF THE
OBVIOUS THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
STATING THE OBVIOUS IS BOTH
APPROPRIATE NEEDFUL THIS WOULD
BE ONE OF THOSE TIMES JUST TO
CLARIFY BASED ON WHAT WE HEAR
FROM OPPOSITION SOMEONE COULD
TRULY JUST GO ONLINE AND LOOK UP
THE BILL COPY AND PASTE THE BILL
OF RIGHTS. PRINTED ON AN EIGHT
BY TEN PIECE OR A NAP BY ELEVEN
PIECE OF PAPER AND TAPE IT TO
THE FRONT DOOR THEIR BUSINESS OR
OF THE SHELTER AND WITH THAT
FULFILL THE REQUIREMENT THIS
BILL WELL I'M NOT A WRITTEN
NOTICE OF THIS INTENT TOWARD
FULL PHILIP THAT'S- CORRECT. AND
THEN IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE IT DONE
AND SOMEONE COMES AND BRINGS IT
TO THEIR ATTENTION OF AUTHORITY
THEY HAVE ACTUALLY SIXTY DAYS TO
DO THAT ONE MINUTE ACT THEY HAVE
SIXTY DAYS TO CORRECT THAT THANK
YOU. I'LL SUPPORT HIM AS A
GRAYSON ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. I NEED A MOTION AND
SECOND. GOT GOT MOST GOT A
SECOND MRS SANTIAGO DEAL TO
CLOSE YEAH I THINK ESPECIALLY
AYE FOR NOVEL BUT WOULD LIKE TO
CORRECT THREE THINGS FROM THE
OPPOSITION NUMBER ONE IS NOT
GOING TO SHAME SOMEBODY WITH A
TO TELL THEM THAT A DOG OR A CAT
OR A CAT TO. LIVE FREE FROM
EXPLOITATION THAT THEY SHOULD
RECEIVE NUTRITIOUS FOOD
APPROPRIATE VETERINARIAN KERR-
OR IDENTIFIED THROUGH A TAG OR
MICROCHIP THESE ARE ALL THESE
THINGS AND I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION FROM MY COLLEAGUE
THAT'S A GREAT SHAME SOMEBODY IF
YOU HAVE THERE IF IT'S NOT THE
RIGHT FIT IT'S NOT THE RIGHT
FIT- SECOND- IT. IT DOESN'T JUST
ATTACK ONE. GROUP OF PEOPLE LIKE
THEY SAID IT WOULD ACT. IT ALSO
DOES RESCUE GROUPS FOR EXAMPLE-
A AND- I MEAN I JUST WANTED TO
CLEAR THOSE UP REALLY QUICKLY
THAT IF. IT IS THE OBVIOUS IBAT
WE WANT TO STATE. THAT THIS IS
THE CARE- THAT A DOG OR A CAT
SHOULD HAPPEN. SO I DON'T FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE AND IN OUR INTENT
AND WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF. TO
ENSURE THAT THAT THIS LAND IN
THE RIGHT SPOT TO IN THAT THE
INTENT IS MADE OUT THAT THAT A
CAT OR A DOG. SHOULD HAVE. THIS
SET OF CARE- I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AND WE DEMONSTRATE
THAT WE WANT TO WORK BUT- IT IS
UNREASONABLE SAY WE'RE GOING TO
SHAME THAT. SOMEBODY FROM
GETTING A DOG IT'S GOING TO
PREVENT SOMEBODY FROM- RESCUING
A DOG THIS IS NOT THE CASE-
IMPACTED HOPE TO EDUCATE. ON
WHAT CARE IT REQUIRES- SO THAT
IT MAY BE YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T DO
THAT SORT OF CARE. MAYBE IT'S
NOT THE RIGHT PET POINT. YOU GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE FOR DIFFERENT
SORT OF PAT. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR PUTTING A LOT OF A TIME
INTO THIS. WE THINK OF LANDIS-
IN THE DIRECTION WE NEED TO GO
AND THANK MR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUMMER SANTIAGO- THE ONLY
QUESTION THAT I HAD WHEN I WAS
INITIALLY REVIEWING IT IS. YEAH
MY BROTHER HAS A DOG- I HAVE A
DOG. HIS DOG REALLY ENJOYS A
LIFE OF COMFORT FREE OF FEAR AND
ANXIETY. BUT MY DOG HER MENTAL
STIMULATION IS. TORTURING HIS
DOG YET SO WHO. WHO GETS TO DO
WHAT THEY WANT WAS WHERE I
STRUGGLED BUT I THINK MY DOG'S
GONNA WIN OUT- SHE OFTEN DOES.
MATHIS HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM I
HAVE A FOUR POUND YORKIE THAT
JUST CARE RIGHT MY HUNDRED POUND
EXACTLY A GERMAN SHEPHERD. YEAH
IT'S EXACTLY RIGHT AS OUR
SITUATION TO YOU. THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- CERTAINLY
WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT ALL ANIMALS HAVE A
SAFE CARING HOME WHEN THEY'RE
ADOPTED. THE AMENDMENTS- WILL
FURTHER THIS INTENT WHILE MAKING
IT CLEAR TO CONSUMERS AND THE
PUBLIC. THESE ARE IDEALS AND
ASPIRATIONS NOT ENFORCEABLE
RIGHTS- WITH THAT MOMENTUM
HAVING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABOUT. MOTIONS TO PASS AS A- TO
THE- ON A PER. BERMAN BERMAN I
FLOOR. ON A VOTING BLUE. WHEN I
BONTA. GEN CHENNAI CUNNINGHAM
DALY FONG IPSEN IPSEN I GRAYSON
REASON IRELAND IRWIN KILEY MAY I
MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
MULLIN AYE SALAS THING WEBER.
THAT HAS- NINE VOTES WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- SOME RELIEF YOU'D
LIKE TO PRESENT YOU'RE ADDING TO
BILLS IS THAT RIGHT. THAT WOULD
BE FANTASTIC. BOTH ON BEHALF OF
DID DIDNOBODY DID I DID NOT YOU
I SHOULD SAY TO REMEMBER THANK
YOU SIR. I'M GOING TO START WITH
AB NINETEEN S. R. EIGHTEEN
NINETY FOUR THAT SOUNDS GREAT
THANKS THE GENERAL NUMBER FOR.
GOT A MOTION AND A BIPARTISAN
SECOND GRADES GOOD START. RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO RESENT AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR THE
CANNABIS VAPE LABELING FOR
PROPER DISPOSAL ACT BY
pSAID THIS PROHIBITS LEAVING I
CANNABIS VAPING DEVICES THAT
INDICATES THEIR DISPOSAL OR
IMPLY THEY MAY BE THROWN IN THE
TRASH OR RECYCLING THIS THING
THIS BILL REQUIRED CANNABIS
VAPING DEVICES BE PROPERLY
LABELED AND ADVERTISED AS
HAZARDOUS WASTE. AB IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THE CULMINATION OF
WORK BETWEEN OUR SPONSOR HOLLERS
AND CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE
CLEAR LABELING AND STOP THE
MARKETING OF THESE PRODUCTS AND
ANYWAY IT IMPLIES WE CAN DISPOSE
OF IN IT. IN TRASH OR RECYCLING
SYSTEMS THAT ARE CLEARLY LABELED
SURE THE CONSUMERS WHERE THEY
MUST BE DISPOSED OF AS A
HAZARDOUS WASTE- ACCORDING TO
FDA VAPES CAN CATCH FIRE EVEN
EXPLODE AND SERIOUSLY HURT
PEOPLE. TODAY I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES JOINING ME TODAY I
HAVE JORDAN WELLS WITH THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL AND AMY JENKINS ARE
PRESENTED CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. AND RIGHT-
TO START WITH WITH MS JENKINS IN
THE IN THE ROOM AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO JORDAN WELLS- OR MAYBE
SOMEONE ELSE. JORDAN IS ON THE
PHONE UNTIL PERFECT. PLEASE
THANK YOU AND OF YOUR WILL GO
AHEAD NOT OF WHATEVER YOU WANT.
BUT YEAH NUMBERS JACKSON DRAGON
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THINKING THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL FOR PRO ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH C. C. I. A. AND THE BROADER
INDUSTRY THIS REALLY IS A
CONSENSUS BILL THAT CONTINUES TO
PERMIT. THE MANUFACTURE AND USE
OF NON RECHARGEABLE VAPING
PRODUCTS WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
ADVANCING SENSIBLE PROVISIONS
AIMED AT PROMOTING ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY OF THESE PRODUCTS
CCA HAS A VERY PROUD TRACK
RECORD OF SUPPORTING POLICIES
THAT ENCOURAGE THE USE OF
RECYCLABLE AND ARE BIODEGRADABLE
MATERIALS I'M REDUCING LANDFILL
WASTE IN PROMOTING RESPONSIBLE
USE- WHILE MOST NON RETRACTABLE
CANVAS VAPES ARE MADE WITH
RECYCLED MATERIALS. THEY ALSO
CONCLUDE INCLUDE LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES AND HEATING ELEMENTS
WHICH SHOULD BE DISPOSED OF AS
HAZARDOUS WASTE I WOULD NOTE
THAT NON RECHARGEABLE PRODUCTS
ARE PREDOMINANTLY USED BY
PATIENTS FOR THEIR EASE O USE-
AND SO AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THIS BILL STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN ENSURING THAT
THE PUBLIC IS AWARE THAT THESE
NEED TO BE PROPERLY DISPOSED-
WELL ALLOWING PATIENTS TO
CONTINUE TO ACCESS THESE
PRODUCTS SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL INNER
DRIVE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE GOT
WE'RE VOTING NOW WE SKIP THINGS
AND WE ARE OFF TO VOTING- DO WE
HAVE JORDAN WELLS VIA PHONE.
YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME I CAN'T
THANKS. OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU
MEMBER LEAD CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AM JORDAN WELLS WITH THE
NATIONAL STORAGE OF ACTION
COUNCIL A NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR CIRCULAR AN
EQUITABLE ECONOMY AND A
SPONSORED AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
FOUR. AB EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR
FROM REQUIRE AN INTEGRATED
CANNABIS VAPORIZER OR BETTER
KNOWN AS A CANNABIS VAPING
DEVICE OR DATE TO PROMINENTLY
DISPLAY THAT IT MUST BE DISPOSED
OF AS HAZARDOUS WASTE AND WILL
PROHIBIT ANY MESSAGING THAT
EIGHT THAT IS DISPOSABLE OR
IMPLIED THAT IT MAY BE THROWN IN
THE TRASH OR RECYCLING.
ACCORDING TO THE STATE WIDE
RECYCLING COMMISSION THERE'S A
SERIOUS TRUTH IN LABELING
PROBLEM FOR WHAT PRODUCERS ARE
CLEANING ON THEIR PRODUCT LABELS
REGARDING RECYCLABILITY AND
PROPER DISPOSAL WHICH LEADS TO
CONFUSION AND IMPROPER DISPOSAL
OF MANY PRODUCTS. THE THING ONE
OF THEM. ONLINE WE HAVE FOUND
MANY PRODUCTS ARE LABELED
DISPOSABLE AND SOME EVEN STATE
OUTRIGHT THAT THEY CAN BE THROWN
IN THE TRASH OR IMPLIED THEY CAN
BE DISPOSED OF IN THE TRASH. OR
DO NOT INCLUDE ANY INFORMATION
ABOUT PROPUBLICA'S. TO GAS.
CONFUSE CONSUMERS ARE DISCARDING
BATES AND THEIR HOUSEHOLD TRASH
OR RECYCLING BINS WHERE THEY CAN
AND DO. CAUSE EXPLOSIONS AND
FIRES THAT CAN RESULT IN COSTLY
DAMAGE TO PROPERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT WITH THE POTENTIAL
TO HURT PEOPLE WORKING IN THE
WEEKS INDUSTRY. AND THE THING IS
ON THE RISE. IN THE MARKET FOR
SINGLE USE BATES IS INCREASING
YET THERE ARE MANY REUSE
REUSABLE AND RECHARGEABLE
OPTIONS READILY AVAILABLE. WE
ARE DELIGHTED THAT THE INDUSTRY
HAS PARTNERED WITH US ON THIS
BILL TO PROPERLY INFORMED
CONSUMERS OF CORRECT DISPOSAL.
WELL WE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
THAT CANNABIS EIGHT THE REQUIRED
TO BEAR MANY LABELS SO DO OTHER
PRODUCTS WHICH ARE ALSO REQUIRED
TO LABEL WITH IMPORTANT DISPOSAL
INSTRUCTIONS. I WILL WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US FOR HER LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE I PER SPONSORING
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR- ARE CO
AUTHORS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAD
FOR PRESENTING THE BILL TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY- RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR EYES OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN I
BELIEVE I HAVE THE PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESS. RAN MARTIN-
RAN. HE'S IN THE ROOM. COME ON
UP YOU GOT TWO MINUTES.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE PARENT
COMPANY WHICH I IDENTIFIED
EARLIER AS ONE OF THE LARGEST
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED CANNABIS
COMPANIES IN THE STATE- I WANT
TO SAY TWO THINGS TO BEGIN WITH
NUMBER ONE WE APPRECIATE WHAT
THE AUTHOR DID RELATIVE TO HER
BILL AB SIXTEEN NINETY WHICH LED
TO. ON THIS BILL- BEING
NECESSARY- WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT I'M NUMBER TWO WE ALSO
AGREED THAT THE MESSAGE THAT
THEY AND SHE WANTS TO DELIVER IS
THE RIGHT MESSAGE. WE JUST NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DELIVERING IT IN A WAY THAT IT
ACTUALLY GETS THE ATTENTION OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PURCHASING
CANNABIS PRODUCTS WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THAT AS ADDITIONAL
PROPOSALS ARE OUT THERE RELATIVE
TO ADDING MORE AND MORE. I TO
THE EXISTING CANNABIS PRODUCTS
THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
CREATING VIRTUAL WHITE NOISE THE
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT THESE
PRODUCTS AND DECIDING- ARE NOT
DECIDING NOT MAKING DECISIONS
BASED ON WHAT THEY SAY THEY'RE
JUST IGNORING WHAT THEY SEE-
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE DO- I USE
AS AN EXAMPLE AND I THINK ALL OF
US WILL ADMIT AT LEAST
PRIVATELY. ON THAT WE DON'T PAY
ATTENTION TO PROP SIXTY FIVE
WARNING SIGNS BECAUSE THEY ARE
EVERYWHERE AND THEY DON'T TELL
US ANYTHING THAT WE NEED TO KNOW
WE DON'T WANT THE SAME THING TO
HAPPEN TO CANNABIS PRODUCTS
BECAUSE THOSE PRODUCTS ARE
DELIVERING VERY IMPORTANT
MESSAGES. LIKE PREGNANT WOMEN
SHOULDN'T- USING WITHOUT
CONSULTING A DOCTOR I'M
SHOULDN'T BE AND GIVEN TO THE
CHILDREN AND MESSAGES LIKE THAT-
BUT WE HAVE TALKED WITH THE
SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR- WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN FIND SOME.
YOUR AGREEABLE WAY OF DELIVERING
THE MESSAGE SO THAT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY DO GET THE MESSAGE- AND
OBVIOUSLY I THINK THE BILL WILL
PROBABLY MOVE FORWARD TODAY BUT
WE HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US. AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE INDUSTRY
WHO ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT-
CROWDING OUT IMPORTANT MESSAGES
IN OUR- IN OUR- I CANNABIS
MESSAGE. MESSAGING WARNING
LABELS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING TODAY JUST WANNA ADD ON.
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION OF ANY
IMPOSITION ON THE BILL. MISTER
CHAIR MARKER PRAYER ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. R. DEAL
DURING HER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BELT PLACE OUR- CAMERA LOPEZ
BEHALF OF TRYING GROUP IN
SUPPORT. OF THIS. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
SING NINE OPERATOR LET'S OPEN
THE PHONE LINES- FOR A BI
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR. IF ANYONE
WANTS TO ADD THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND POSITION
SUPPORT OR OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
OKAY AS A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO. OUR
FIRST WILL COME FROM THE LINE OF
TWO FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FROM THE COLD WAR OVER ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
. THANK YOU. NEXO BOTTOM LINE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FORTY ONE POSSIBLE YOUR MUTE
BUTTONS ON. ALEXA CHUNG IS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
ONE OF MINE THIRTY FOUR. WELL
YOU CAN YOU HEAR US. NOW WE
CAN'T. OKAY SORRY NO ONE TOLD ME
MY NUMBER THIS TIME MITCHELL
COMPARE ST WILL BE ADVOCATE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANKS SO
MUCH. THAT'S ABOUT ALL I GOT.
APOLOGIZE WORKERS TO FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING RICH
MILLER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
AMERICAN ALLIANCE FOR MEDICAL
CANNABIS IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
IT THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME GREAT THANKS SO MUCH BRING
IT BACK TO KILEY FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND YET WE'VE GOT A MOTION IN
THE SECOND. YES NUMBER ONE S.
THANK YOU MISTER LEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS-
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS- I THINK
IT IS IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THE MESSAGING IS THERE THAT
THERE IS PROPER DISPOSAL OF
THESE. SINGLE USE BATTERIES
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF REASONS FOR
THAT THERE IS A AN EXPANDED
NUMBER OF PRODUCTS THAT USE
THESE BATTERIES AND- I THINK THE
NEXT STEP IN THIS IS MAKING SURE
THAT WE EXPAND- PROPER DISPOSAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND- I HAVE A BILL
THAT'S GOING TO COMPLEMENT THIS
BILL- VERY NICELY AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY. AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT SO THAT WE
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN A
MULTITUDE OF WAYS AND THIS BILL
IS ONE IMPORTANT PART THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AS A MEMBER IRWIN
GREAT. OPPORTUNITY TO PLUG YOUR
BILL AS WELL ABSOLUTELY. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES- SEEING DOWN
ISN'T REALLY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
PROUD CO AUTHORS BILL AND FIRST
WITH THE ANSWER I GOT A BEHALF
OF SOMEWHERE RIVAS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR STELLAR JOB PINCH HITTING
FOR SOMETHING MEMBER RIVAS AND
FOR- PRESENTING THIS BILL MATTER
TO SUPPORT THE BILL WITH SOME
MOMENTS THAT- I BELIEVE YOU'VE
ACCEPTED ON HER BEHALF- EXCEPT
ON HER BEHALF YOUR THE BEST
PROCEDURE- MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI
BERMAN I FLOOR. LOOM M. I. BONTA
. CHAN CHAN I. CUNNINGHAM DALY.
FONG GIPSON. GRAYSON WHEN I WHEN
I LEE I MAY I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN SALAS TANG.
WEBER. WE WE'VE LOST ALL OUR
COLLEAGUES SO THAT BILL SIX
VOTES AND ONLY THE ROLE ABSENT
FOR A RULES WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS I SEE
MISTER COURT HEARS NOTHING I'M
GONNA BRING MISTER CORK UP TO
PRESENT THE GENOCIDE NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO TEN AND THEN
WILL BRING BACK TO YOU SOME
RELIEF FOR. THE SUMMER BARKING
IN THE BILL. DR CORK READY
WHENEVER YOU ARE.
IT IS STILL MORNING GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
OF I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IN PARTICULAR- IT
WOULD REQUIRE THAT CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO RETURN TO THE
ORIGINAL OF RETAIL PREMISES BE
KEPT IN THEIR ORIGINAL PACKAGING
THAT MAKES TOTAL JUST LOADS OF
SENSE IT'S CERTAINLY WHAT WE
INTENDED AND THEN THERE'S SOME
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING CHANGES
WHICH WERE ALSO HAPPY TO ACCEPT
. THEY WERE ACCEPTING ALL THE
AMENDMENT- AB TWENTY TWENTY
CHAPTERS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ALLOWED GOVERNMENTS TO GRANT
TEMPORARY LICENSES. FOR THE SALE
OF CANNABIS IS EXPRESSLY
PERMITTED VENUES. HOWEVER SOME
VENUES HAVE BEEN DENIED CANNABIS
TEMPORARY EVENT LICENSES ON THE
BASIS OF THE VENUE HOLDINGA
CURRENT ALCOHOL BEVERAGE LICENSE
. OUR AB. TWENTY TWO TEN
GLORIFIES THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SPECIAL CANNABIS EVENT LICENSES
ESPECIALLY FOR VENUES WITH
CONCURRENT CONCURRENT ALCOHOL
LICENSES BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS JUST A SPENDING-
ALLOWING THE ALCOHOL LICENSE TO
BE SUSPENDED FOR THAT TIME WHEN
THIS IS HAPPENING UP UNTIL FIVE
AM THE NEXT MORNING SO THAT
THERE'S NO WAY THAT YOU CAN HAVE
ALCOHOL AND CANNABIS THE SAME
ADVANTAGE. OF ONE OTHER
OBJECTION PEOPLE HAVE HAD IS
THAT THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
MINERS YOU'RE NOT AT THESE
CANNABIS EVENTS WHICH SHALL WE
AGREE WITH ICE IN THE
PROPOSITION THAT CETERA SO WE'RE
WE'RE FINE WITH THAT AS WELL-
WITH ME TODAY IS- AMY JENKINS-
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AMY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY. CCA WAS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION AB TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH PERMITTED THE ISSUANCE OF
TEMPORARY EVENT LICENSES FOR THE
SALE AND CONSUMPTION OF CANNABIS
EVENTS EXPRESSLY PERMITTED BY A
LOCAL JURISDICTION. THIS HARD
FOUGHT LEGISLATION WAS CAREFULLY
WHEN NEGOTIATED WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS TO THAT
END WE INCORPORATED A NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS TO SAFEGUARD AGAINST
THE CONSUMPTION OF CANNABIS
ALCOHOL AND TOBACCO ON THE SAME
PREMISES. THE OTHER IMPORTANT
PUBLIC SAFETY PROTOCOLS AIMED AT
DETERRING YOUTH ACCESS AND
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY WHAT WE DIDN'T
CONTEMPLATE WAS ABC GUIDANCE
WHICH WOULD INTERPRET- THESE
CANNABIS TEMPORARY EVENTS TO BE
IN CONFLICT WITH THEIR EXISTING
LICENSING. AND SO WHAT IS THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES BAND
THAT EVENTS TEMPORARY EVENTS
HAVE BEEN SEVERELY CONSTRAINED
BECAUSE MOST LOCATIONS POSSESS
AN ABC ALCOHOL LICENSE SO WE
APPRECIATE THE SPELL. ON THE
WORK OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL OPTIONS
PROVIDED THAT THERE LOCALLY
APPROVED AND MEETS ALL THE
SPECIFICATIONS ALREADY CAREFULLY
CRAFTED IN STATUTES SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND ARGYRIA VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
DON'T SEE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SO. I WANT TO OPEN
IT UP TO ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
TODAY YOU WANT TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THE BILL.
GOT A MOTION ON A SECOND. THIS
IS YOUR MEMBERS REMARKED ON
BEHALF OF THE PARENT COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HELLO DURING A FOR
CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DON'T SEE ANYMORE THIS IS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM LET'S OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES- THIS IS OPPORTUNITY
FOR FOLKS TO PROVIDE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION THERE WITH IF ANY
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY OPPOSE
OR SUPPORT THE BILL. OKAY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN PRESS
ONE THENZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE COMMENT. ONE ONCE AGAIN
PRESS ONE ZERO. OUR FIRST COMES
FROM NINE TO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO JONATHAN
CRACKLED REPRESENTING THE UNITED
CANNABIS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
THE LONG BEACH COLLECTIVE
ASSOCIATION THE CALLEBAUT LIKE
CANADA ALONE WE ARE ALL IN FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TO SIXTY FIVE
YOU'RE OPEN. RICH MILLER ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN ALLIANCE
MEDICAL CANNABIS. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME BREAK BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS COMMENTS
GOT THE MOTION GOT THE SECOND
LOOK ON MY LEFT LEG AND ON MY
RIGHT DON'T SEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS DR COURT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES OUT SO FAR AS I
KNOW THERE IS NO OPPOSITION NOW
BECAUSE WE'VE AGREED ARE WITH
THE- PEOPLE WERE OPPOSED- WITH
THE CONDITIONS THAT THEY HAD SO
I KNOW OF NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ARRIVE- AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING WITH
THE FOLKS WHO WERE OPPOSED THANK
YOU- DR QUIRK I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE. AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
WITH THE AGREED TO AMENDMENTS MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN ALL RIGHT. BERMAN I
FLORA. BLOOM WHEN I BONTA. GEN
AND I CUNNINGHAM DALY. FONG
GIPSON. THAT'S RIGHT. I GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE IRWIN. WE MAY I
MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
SALAS IN IN AYE WEBER. THE BILL
HAS SEVEN VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU DR
WORK SO I BELIEVE WE'RE BACK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVY I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER. BILL AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR A GENERAL NUMBER NINETEEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR STRAINS
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR FOUR SOMEWHERE
BAR QUE HAN I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
ON HER BEHALF THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH ADDED URGENCY
KLAUSING CLARIFIED DEFINITION OF
SUPERVISION. WELL WITH THAT
TODAY A PRESENT THIS BILL WHICH
WOULD ENSURE THAT TRAINEES IN
THE FIELD OF PSYCHOLOGY RECEIVE
NECESSARY TRAINING IN A SAFE AND
TIMELY MANNER EXTENDING
SUPERVISION TRAINS AUDIO AND
HIPPA COMPLIANT VIDEO
CONFERENCING. CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCING A DIRE SHORTAGE OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
GRAPPLING WITH MEETING THIS NEED
ACCORDING TO THE HEALTH FOR
CENTER CALIFORNIA IS ON TRACK TO
LOSE 41% OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
11% OF ITS CYCLE IS THE NEXT
DECADE. THIS ON TOP OF EXISTING
SCARCITY UNDER CURRENT LAW
PSYCHOLOGY TRAINEES IN
CALIFORNIA COURT TO RECEIVE
THREE THOUSAND HOURS REVISED
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE AS A
CONDITION TO RECEIVE THEIR
LICENSE TO PRACTICE AS PART AS
OUR TRAINEES REQUIRED BE
SUPERVISED 410% OF THE TOTAL
TIME WORKED EACH. WEEK AND HAVE
AT LEAST ONE HOUR PER WEEK OF
FACE TO FACE DIRECT INDIVIDUAL
SUPERVISION WITH A PRIMARY
SUPERVISOR. THIS MEANS THAT AT
LEAST ONCE EVERY WEEK DURING A
TWO YEAR PERIOD A TRAINEE HAS NO
CHOICE. BUT TO BE IN CLOSE
QUARTERS ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL IN
THE MIDST OF A GLOBAL HEALTH
PANDEMICS. RESPONSE-GOVERNORS M.
TEMPORARILY WHAT TEMPORARILY
WEIGHED FACE TO FACE A PROVISION
AND PROVIDE SUPERVISION TO BE
DONE. REMOTELY VIA HIPPA
COMPLIANT VIDEO DESPITE THE
CONTINUED SPREAD OF COVER
NINETEEN THE RISKS ASSOCIATED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONS
BILLS WORKING CLOSE QUARTERS THE
EMERGENCY WAIVER WAS ONLY
EXTENDED UNTIL MARCH THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHICH
HAS NOW OF COURSE EXPIRED. THIS
BILL SEEKS THE REMEDY IS I
IMMEDIATELY CODIFYING THE FACE
TO FACE A PROVISION WAIVER. THIS
WILL PRESERVE ACCESSING CONTINUE
CONTINUE WITTY TO PSYCHOLOGICAL
CARE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE CALL
AND SERIOUS. SERVICE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS ARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION AND ABA RASHID.
LEGISLATIVE ADVENT ADVOCATE FOR
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS RIGHT. GOT A MOTION.
GOT A SECOND TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE. READY WHEN YOU ARE. A
GOOD MORNING AFTERNOON HERE IN
MEMBERS YEAH MY NAME IS- COLLINS
WERE AS DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS OF THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
US ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAF
PRESENTING. THE SENATE WOMAN
TARA CAN COULD NOT BE HERE FOR-
AUTHORING THE BILL. SO YOU HEARD
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAINEES MUST
RECEIVE THREE THOUSAND HOURS OF
SUPERVISED PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH AT LEAST ONE
HOUR EACH WEEK BEING FACE TO
FACE INDIVIDUAL SUPERVISION.
THAT MAN'S THAT OUR TRAINEES
HAVE TO SCHEDULE THEIR ENTIRE
WEEK TRAVELING ATTENDING. COSTS
AROUND A SINGLE HOUR. THANKFULLY
AN EXACT ORDER DURING THE
PANDEMIC ALLOWED TO THE FACE TO
FACE REQUIREMENT TO BE WAIVED
OUR TRAINEES NEEDING TO RECEIVE
THE SUPERVISED HOURS ARE ABLE TO
USE WIDELY AVAILABLE VIDEO
CONFERENCING TECHNOLOGY. AND
CONTINUE THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT A SAFE RELIABLE
MANNER. HOWEVER AT THE MOMENT
THE GOVERNOR LIVES THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY THAT WOULD ALSO
IMMEDIATELY AND THE WAIVER IF
THEY'RE REGULATORY SOLUTION
IT'LL ITS ARRIVAL WOULD NOT BE
FORTHCOMING FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
BOTH PSYCHOLOGY TRAINEES INTO
PROVIDERS HAVE REPORTED VIRTUAL
SUPERVISION TO BE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT AT A
DEGREE EQUIVALENT. TO IN PERSON
SUPERVISION WE ALSO SAW NUMEROUS
BENEFITS TO THOSE BEYOND THOSE
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH.
TRAINEES ARE ABLE TO INTERACT
WITH A LARGER POOL SUPERVISOR
SINCE THEY WERE NO LONGER
RESTRICTED BY ACCESS TO A
VEHICLE OR TRANSIT. TRAINEES
MOST OF THEM FACING SIGNIFICANT
EDUCATIONAL LOANS AND DEBTS WERE
ABLE TO SAVE MONEY AND TIME WILL
STILL RECEIVING DIRECT
SUPERVISION. SEVERAL INSTANCES
WE HEARD STORIES OF TRAINEES
HAVING TO TRAVEL SEVERAL HOURS
EACH WEEK AT THEIR OWN COST IN
HEAVY TRAFFIC. SUPERVISORS COULD
MORE READILY SCHEDULE TRAINEES
OR SUPERVISION SESSIONS AND
STREAMLINE THEIR OWN SCHEDULING.
AND BOTH TRAINEES AND
SUPERVISORS HAVE REPORTED AN
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PATIENTS
THEY WERE ABLE TO SERVE DUE TO
EFFICIENCY SINCE TRAINEES ALSO
SERVE PATIENTS DURING THE
CLINICAL TRAINING. LIKEWISE
ABOARD PSYCHOLOGY'S CONTINUE
EXTENSION OF THE WAIVER IT
HIGHLIGHTED ITS EFFICACY AND
USEFULNESS. NEITHER THE BOARD
pCOMPLAINTS ABOUT YOUR VIRTUAL
SUPERVISION IN FACT WE'VE
RECEIVED OVERWHELMING SUPPORT
FROM OUR MEMBERS. FURTHER OUR
BILL WOULD NOT OBLIGATE
SUPERVISORS AND TRAINEES TO
COMPLETELY ELIMINATE FACE TO
FACE SUPERVISION IN THE FUTURE.
IF TH TRAINING SUPERVISOR SEE
VALUE THEY WOULD STILL BE ABLE
TO DO SO. GPA BELIEVES THAT THIS
BILL IS BOTH TIMELY AND
NECESSARY TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
IMPROVE DELIVERY OF TRAINING FOR
FUTURE LICENSE PSYCHOLOGIST.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE YOUR MUCH. THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
AMBER SHE'D. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WHICH REPRESENTS THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM WITH ORTIZ AND
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
ABC TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
ENSURE THAT TRAINEES IN THE
FIELD OF PSYCHOLOGY ARE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THEIR NECESSARY
SUPERVISION IN A SAFE AND TIMELY
MATTER. A CODIFYING ONE OF THE
FLEXIBILITIES CREATED BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND THIRTY NINE
TWENTY. THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER
WAVED FACE TO FACE REVISION
REQUIREMENTS AND SAID A LOT FOR
SUPERVISION TO OCCUR- VIA AUDIO
HIPPA COMPLIANT VIDEO
CONFERENCING AS YOU'VE HEARD.
THIS FACE TO FACE REVISION
WAIVER DAY PRACTITIONERS THE
ABILITY TO EXPAND CAPACITY AND
PROTECT THEIR HEALTH WITHOUT ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON PATIENTS
SUPERVISORS OR TRAINEES.
ALTHOUGH INITIALLY MEANT TO BE
TEMPORARY NUMEROUS BENEFITS OF
THIS LABOR HAVE EMERGED OVER THE
PAST YEAR AND THE FLEXIBILITY
PROVIDED IMPROVE SAFETY EXPANDED
PRACTITIONERS AVAILABILITY.
ADDITIONALLY THE FACE TO FACE
WAIVER ALLEVIATE A PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSTRAINTS- AND REDUCE COSTS TO
TRAINEES AND SUPERVISORS. THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
RESTAURANT BOTH INCREASED DEMAND
ON THE PART OF PRACTITIONERS.
WHERE THE FLEXIBLE AND SAFE MODE
OF SUPERVISION AS WELL AS
ADVANCES IN HIPPA COMPLIANT
VIDEO CONFERENCING- AND FOR
TRAINING SUPERVISORS LOSING THE
ABILITY O PARTICIPATE IN
SUPERVISION REMOTELY PUTS AN
UNDUE BURDEN ON THEIR SAFETY AS
WELL AS THE TIME. ADDRESSING ALL
OF THE CURRENT BEHAVIOR
WORKFORCE CRISIS. REQUIRES
MAINTAINING EXPANDING TRAINING
FLEXIBILITIES WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL AIMS TO DO AND
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS EASIEST
YOU A SUPPORT AB TWENTY. SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR IN RESPECTFULLY URGES
AND I VOTE THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
ON MY SHEET SO ONE OPEN IT UP
FOR ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY. NO RUSSIAN
OF THE FRONT GONNA OPEN IT UP TO
THE- PHONE LINES OPERATOR CAN
YOU IDENTIFY IF THERE'S ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR AGAIN THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS TO PROVIDE
THEIR NAME. ORGANIZATION THERE
WITH IF ANY. IMPOSITION ON THE
BILL SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. OKAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS A NEED BLOMBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. BRING BACK
THE COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
COMMENTS I THINK WE'VE GOT THE
MOTION IN THE SECOND- ANY
QUESTIONS THEN I'M ALL RIGHT.
LOOK IN MY LEFT. NOT SEEN ANY-
SOME REALLY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
CHÁVEZ DRIVE A- PHONE NUMBER
MCCARTY BROUGHT LUNCH FOR US
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED- BEAR WITH
ME WHILE I FIND MY PLACE. A
DISTRACTED BY LUNCH THANK YOU
WITH SOMEONE EARLY FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER CAN. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AND
APPRECIATE THE MEASURE IS
INTENDED TO ENSURE TRAINEES IN
THE FIELD OF PSYCHOLOGY. RECEIVE
NECESSARY TRAINING IN A SAFE AND
TIMELY MANNER THROUGH AUDIO AND
VIDEO SUPERVISION. WHEN GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TEMPORARILY WAIVED FACE
TO FACE A PROVISION AND ALLOW
FOR REMOTE SUPERVISION IN MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY PRACTITIONERS WERE
ABLE TO EXPAND THEIR CAPACITY
AND PROTECT THEIR HEALTH WITHOUT
ANY NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
PATIENTS. IT IS CLEAR THE FACE
TO FACE WAIVER HAS INCREASED
FLEXIBILITY ALLEVIATED PUBLIC
HEALTH CONSTRAINTS REDUCE COSTS
FOR PRACTITIONERS TRAINEES AND
SUPERVISORS. WE'VE ALSO
RECOGNIZED AN INCREASE IN
PRACTITIONERS AVAILABILITY AND
ACCESS AND FOR ALL THESE MANY
VERY GOOD REASONS I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE AND APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN HI BERMAN I FLOOR FLOOR I
BLOOM. BLOOM I BONTA GEN AND I
CUNNINGHAM DALLI. DALLI AYE
FONG. GIPSON MASON MASON IRELAND. WE AYE MI AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
SALAS. THANK IN AYE WEBER. IT'S. NINE THAT BILLS OUT TO ALL THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AS
LONG MCCARTY. AS DO IT AGENDA
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR.
READY WHEN YOU ARE SICK THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN CHAIR
BERMAN AND MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS BILL
FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS-
NARROWING IN FOCUSING ON
DEFINITIONS. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
REAL ESTATE IN CALIFORNIA AND
USUALLY WHEN SOMEBODY SELLS OR
PURCHASES A PROPERTY THEY WORK
WITH A LOCAL REAL ESTATE BROKER
TO HELP THEM COMPLETE THAT
TRANSACTION HOWEVER IN RECENT
YEARS WITH TECHNOLOGY AND THE
ADVENT OF INTERNET OPTIONS
INTERNET BUYERS HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY ACTIVE IN THE REAL
ESTATE MARKET. AYE BUYERS ARE
ESSENTIALLY ONLINE COMPANIES
THAT USE AUGER THAN TO BUY AND
SELL PROPERTY EXISTING DATA
INDICATES THAT THESE COMPANIES
ARE PURCHASING MOREPROPERTIES
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO SELL MANY
TIMES THESE HOUSES THE ON THE
MARKET THIS INDICATES- A NUMBER
OF PROPERTIES AT SIT IDLE AND
SOMETIMES REMAIN VACANT FOR
MONTHS I USUALLY IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM PROPERTY IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND THERE'S A REAL
ESTATE SITE ON THERE BUT IF
PEOPLE DO THEY CALL THE NAME OF
THE AGENT AGENT KNOWS THEIR
COMMUNITIES LIKE OUR REAL ESTATE
AGENT HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY THAT
DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN WITH THESE
AYE BUYERS AYE WE'RE THERE'S
BEEN SEVERAL HIGH PROFILED LOCAL
NEWS REPORTS IN MY DISTRICT
SPECIFICALLY. ABOUT VACANT
PROPERTIES AND HAVE PROBLEMS AND
NOT HAVING AN ADEQUATE
INDIVIDUAL TO GO AND WORK WITH
TO RECTIFY THE SITUATION SO THIS
BILL WOULD BE SIMPLY REQUIRE
THAT THE I. BUYER WORK WITH A
LOCAL REAL ESTATE BROKER WHEN
SELLING THE PROPERTY. AGAIN
LOCAL REAL ESTATE AGENTS OR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY ALLEN
SURE THERE IS OVERSIGHT OF THESE
PROPERTIES WHEN THEY ARE PUT AT
PURCELL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTES AND I HAVE A LISA
LOPEZ LOZANO A LOCAL REAL ESTATE
AGENT HERE TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH READY WHEN YOU
ARE. MAYBE JUST THE BUTTON THAT
SAYS MY RIGHT IN FRONT. NOT NOT
NOT RUN MIGHT RUN MIKE. HI THERE
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND BRENT
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO TWENTY FOUR I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY FOR
INTRODUCING A SPELL ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO TWENTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE AN I. BUYER TO WORK WITH
LOCAL REAL ESTATE PROFESSIONALS
WHEN SELLING PROPERTY IN
CALIFORNIA. IN RECENT YEARS I
BUYERS HAVE BECOME MORE ACTIVE
IN THE REAL ESTATE MARKET
DIRECTLY PURCHASING AN INCREASED
AMOUNT OF HOUSING STOCK IN MANY
INSTANCES THESE PROPERTIES WILL
REMAIN VACANT. AND MAINTAINED
AND ATTRACT ILLICIT ACTIVITIES
WHEN THE HOMES ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING SOLD. BUT AT BY
REQUIRING AN I. BUYER TO WORK
WITH LOCAL REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS IT WOULD ENSURE
PROPER OVERSIGHT AND MAINTENANCE
OF THE PROPERTIES. OUR LOCAL
REAL ESTATE PROFESSIONALS ARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY WHO ARE
AT WHO ALSO KNOW THE MARKET BAST
AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE BEST YOU WORSHIP FOR
THESE PROPERTIES AND AT ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT IT YOU KNOW WHILE
IT'S BEING **** AT IT IS THE
REASON. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO.
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND I DON'T. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION ANY ADDITIONAL EN
PRIMER WHEN THIS ISN'T SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY WHO WANT TO
ADD ON. SEEING NONE IT GOT ONE
OF THE PHONE LINES FOR ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL TODAY
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE YOUR NAME. ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH IF ANY AND I AM
POSITION ON THE BILL. OKAY MAYBE
THAN GERMAN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO GOT A MOTION. ONCE
AGAIN ONE NINE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES WE'VE GOT A MOTION-
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A SECOND.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA I WAS GONNA
SEE IF MR MCCARTY WON THE SECOND
HIS BILL BUT- YOU BEAT HIM TO IT
. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COLLEAGUES STAR NAMA LEFT. GOING
TO MY RIGHT NOT SEEING ANY. AS A
MEMBER MCCARTY WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT. THE
RECOMMENDED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WHICH PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLARITY
SURROUNDING THE BILL'S
DEFINITION OF AN I. BUYER AND
ESTABLISHING THE REQUIREMENT AND
I BARS WORKS. THAT AND I. BUYER
WORKS WITH A REAL ESTATE BROKER
ONE THING MY STAFF- FOR WORKING
ON THIS TO. HELP CLARIFY AND ADD
SOME SOME DEFINITIONS I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. MET
WITH THAT MR SECRETARY PLEASE
ALL THE VOTE. MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BERMAN HI BERMAN AYE
FLORA. BONAFIDE AND BLOOM. WELL
MY BONTA GEN. THE VOTING
CUNNINGHAM DALY AN OPENING FONG
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON IRELAND IRWIN KILEY.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN SALAS THANK IN
AYE WEBER HOWEVER I. THAT BILLS
NINE VOTES WILL BE THE ROLL OUT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH BRIDGETTE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR- AUTHORS THE
SUMMER OF SUMMER JONES SAWYER.
SOME MEMBER CARILLO OR ELSE I'M
GOING TO HAVE THIS PHONE NUMBER
MCCARTY JUST PRESENT EVERYONE'S
BILLS- BUT WHILE WE RUN THROUGH
THE ISSUE. WITH THAT YEAH WILL
RUN THROUGH- LET'S RUN THROUGH.
THE THOSE THAT ARE THE FOCUS OF
ATTENTION TO VOTE ON BUT WE
LET'S ALSO CONSENT BEFORE YOU
BEFORE DO THAT. GOT A MOTION GOT
A SECOND FOR CONSENT. ON THE
CONSENT COUNTER BERMAN AYE
BERMAN AYE FLORA BLOOM. MY BONTA. TEN TEN I'D CUNNINGHAM DALY L.
A. I. FONG. FONG I GIPSON
THERE'S AN AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON
IRELAND. IRWIN EILEEN MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN. FOLLOW
US US I TEAM IN AYE WEBER IRAQ
CONSENT IS ALEX WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. SO WHAT
WE HAD A COUPLE OF PRESENTATIONS
BEFORE WE HAD A QUORUM THAT WE
NEED MOTIONS AND SECONDS FOR THE
FIRST IS SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO WHICH
AGENDA ITEM. WE GOT A MOTION GOT
SECOND THAT'S I'M NUMBER ONE
MISTER GIBSON BILL. IS IT IS IT
IS A LITTLE BIT SELFISH BUT- SIR
KIND OF MOTION AND A SECOND ON
IT AB SIXTY SIXTY TWO MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE. A.
B. SIXTEEN FIFTY TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
COMMAND APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI
BERMAN I FLOOR. BLOOM M. I.
BONTA GEN AND I'D CUNNINGHAM
DALY DOMINO FONG. FONG I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON RACE IN
IRELAND. LEE IRWIN AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY TWO GIPSON. IRWIN KILEY
MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
. SALAS FASCINATING IN AYE WEBER
HOWEVER I. THE BILL LEVELS OUT
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. AB EIGHTEEN ANYONE
SANTIAGO. BONTA DELI. GEN ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY ONE SANTIAGO. FONG. A ON
MCCARTY SALAS SALAS I ATTAIN. IN
AYE WEBER ALL RIGHT. THAT BILLS
OUT TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR RIVAS. LARA
BONTA VALLEY. IT IS AGENDA ITEMS
OVER THE ENGINE. OF THE AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY FOUR THREE OF US. THANK
YOU DOLLARS I FONG. MONNING
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE MCCARTY. MULLIN
SALAS SALAS I TEAM IN AYE WEBER
ALL RIGHT. THE BILLS I WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SEVEN RICHARD. I DON'T ADAM
SEVEN AB TWENTY TEN BY A QUIRK
LARA. BONTA DALY. I KNOW FONG.
ON NOW GIPSON GIPSON AYE IRWIN.
BERMAN NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MULLIN SALAS SALAS NO WEBER
HOWEVER I. THAT WILL BE THE BILL
OPEN- THAT THE BILL'S. THE LONG
GONE THOSE GO STILL ON CALL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR HOUSE MEMBERS. I JENNA NAINA I NUMBER EIGHT
AB TWO TOO FAR MCCARTY. BONTA
FONG. FONG NOW LEE. MULLIN SALAS
. OSSAI. THAT BILLS OUT WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
. GEN ITEM NINE AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWO WOULD. BONTA DALLY
DALY AYE GIPSON. NINE GIPSON I
MULLIN SALAS- CITING AN AYE
WEBER HOWEVER I. THE BILLS OUT.
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR US MEMBERS.
FOR A CHEN I'M NUMBER EIGHTEEN
YEAH I KNOW WHICH ONE TWENTY SIX
TWO. SEVEN SEVENTY ONE THE
GENERAL NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE I NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND GOT A
MOTION. GOT A SECOND THANK YOU.
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
BERMAN HI BERMAN I FLOOR. WHEN
M. I. BONTA IN. CAN I.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALLI AYE FONG
FINE I GIPSON GIPSON AE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE IRWIN. IT'S THE IS
THE AGENDA ITEM THIRTEEN THAT
ONE OF THE SUNSET BILLS. THANK
YOU- WHEN I LEAN MCCARTY. MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. FOLLOW US US
I TANK THING I WEBER AWRY. THAT
BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OF
AN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AGENDA
ITEM FOURTEEN CALAMOS AND GOT A
SECOND FOR AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR- THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSES. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
COMEDIAN OF PREPARATIONS BERMAN
HI BERMAN I FLOOR. LAMP WHY AM I
BONTA CAN. THE GENOM FOR
FOURTEEN WHAT ANOTHER SENSE OF
BILL. NO WORRIES THANK YOU SIR
CAN I CUNNINGHAM VALLEY VALLEY
AYE FONG ON AYE GIPSON GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE IRWIN
IRWIN KILEY MCCARTY. MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. SALAS
THOUGHTS I TANK IN AYE WEBER
HOWEVER I. THAT BILLOWS OUT WELL
THE ROLE OF AN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. OKAY THIS WAS MEDINA
FRAZIER THE UNITED. AB. TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE. I GOT A MOTION
- DO DO WE ALREADY WE ALREADY
GOT A MOTION AND SECOND TURNS
OUT WE'RE GOING TO RUN THROUGH
BLOOM. WHY AM I BONTA. DALY
SALLY I AM MCCARTY. MULLIN SALAS
SALAS I TAKE AND I. THE BILL WAS
ALREADY OUT IT STILL ISN'T STILL
OPEN FOR US MEMBERS- IT IS A
NIGHT OUT GOT IT. BLOOM WHEN I
BONTA. SALLY I MCCARTY MULLIN
SALAS BECAUSE I TEND ENACT. THAT
BILL IS NOW OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE WOULD.
BONTA DELI. UNINVITING FONG.
UNAVAILING. ONE MCCARTY MULLIN
SALAS. AT TEN. AND I THE BILL
STILL ON CALL WITH THE ROLE OF
AN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR PARA CAN WHICH
IS ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN. BONTA
FONG FONG I IRWIN- WHEN I MULLIN
SALAS. JENNA. NINETEEN SALAS I
WEBER A BRIGHT. THE BILL HAS
ALREADY OUT STILL IS STILL OPEN
FOR HOUSE MEMBERS ARE CALLING
THE AUTHORS AUTHORS HAVE FIVE
MINUTES THE KIND OF THE HEARING
ROOM OR WE WILL ADJOURN THE
HEARING- WE ARE LOOKING FOR THE
AUTHORS IT JONES SAWYER AND
CORREO FOR AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO
AND AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX ONCE
AGAIN YOU'VE GOT FIVE MINUTES
THE COME OF THE HEARING ROOM
YOU'VE GOTTEN DAHLE TWELVE
THIRTY ALSO A SIX MINUTE. TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE'RE AT IN THE MINUTE
TWENTY EIGHT MINUTES. WILL BE
GENEROUS. EXACTLY.
JUST A TIME CHECK CHECK FOLKS OF
FOUR MINUTES FOUR MINUTES UNTIL
WE GAVEL DOWN. I AM HAPPY TO
PRESENT ONE OF THE TWO BILLS. I
DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR OF ONE OF
THE BILLS I THINK THEY WANT
PRESENTED THEMSELVES AS MY GUESS.
HEY CONTACT TIME CHECK THREE.
BEING REMINDED BY MY COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE EAGER TO GET ON WITH
THEIR DAYS THAT- IT IS A TIME
CHECK PROBABLY TWO AND A HALF
MINUTES BY THIS POINT. NOW I GOT
TO THIRTY FOUR. WELL THE. A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE SECONDS AGO. BUT
WHO'S COUNTING. EVERYONE UP HERE
. EVERYONE APPEARS COUNTY.
THIS IS NOT THAT BIG OF A
BUILDING IT CANNOT TAKE THIS
LONG TO GET FROM YOUR OFFICE
DOWN TO THE FIRST FLOOR. WE ARE. LOOKING FOR AUTHORS Y'ALL
COSTIGAN.
SIXTY SECONDS BOTH OF SIXTY
SECONDS TO GET HERE TO PRESENT
THEIR BILLS.
THIRTY SECONDS.
I HOPE THE ELEVATOR MOVES VERY
QUICKLY. WE HAVE AN AUTHOR ON
THEIR WAY WE HAVE A LOT OF
COLLEAGUES WAITING. THE
IMPATIENCE IS PALPABLE. YEAH.
WE HAVE A BILL- FOLDER READY TO
BE PRESENTED WHAT I'M GONNA DO
IT LET'S DO IT LET'S GET IT ON.
YOU HAVE AN AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO. THE PRESENT
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY SIX OH SIX READY WHEN YOU
ARE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX OH SIX A BILL THAT
WOULD PROHIBIT THE DECLINE
PROCEDURE OR- AT. AND THE
KNOCKED ME ON ANY CAT EXCEPT
WHEN THERE IS THE THERAPEUTIC
PURPOSE STILL MOTION. THANK YOU
I WILL KEEP MY REMARKS SHORT
UNLIKEHUMAN NAILS WHICH GROW
FROM SKIN CAT CLAWS GROW FROM
THE BONE MEANING AMPUTATION OF
THE LAST BONE IN EACH TOE IS
NECESSARY. TO REMOVE THE CLAUSE
THIS IS AN INHUMANE PRACTICE ON
ANIMALS THAT CONTINUES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DECLINE CAN
LEAD TO UNWANTED BEHAVIORS LIKE
LITTER BOX AVOIDANCE AND BITING
BECAUSE THE CAT HAS NO OTHER WAY
TO DEFEND ITSELF. I HERE TO
TESTIFY- WE HAVE A INDIVIDUAL
IN- OVER THE PHONE I BELIEVE
HOPEFULLY WERE ABLE TO GET THE
MONEY THAT'S LOS ANGELES CITY
COUNCILMEMBER AND FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PAUL CORRECT AND
HERE IN THE ROOM WITH THIS IS DR
JENNIFER CONRAD WHO IS THE
FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF THE POP
PROJECT. AND THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL GREAT WHEN WE START. WHEN
WE START IN THE ROOM WITH THE
DOCTOR CONRAD AND THEN WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
COUNCILMEMBER KRETZ. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR JENNIFER
CONRAD I'M A LICENSED
VETERINARIAN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE POP PROJECT A CALIFORNIA
BASED NONPROFIT. DECLINING IS
THE EQUIVALENT OF TAKING A CIGAR
CUTTER TO EVERYONE OF A CAT'S
TOES. AB TWO SIX OH SIX WOULD
ONLY PROHIBIT. THE AMPUTATION OF
CAT TOBAN TWENTY IT'S NOT
MEDICALLY INDICATED. THE BILL
ALLOWS US TO PRACTICE MEDICINE
IN THE EVENT OF PATH OLOGY THE
WE VETERINARIANS COULD
ABSOLUTELY STILL AMPUTATE THE
TOES YOU MAY HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT DECLAWING IS
RARE BUT IN THE JOURNALS AND IN
THE SCIENTIFIC JOURNALS IT'S
ACTUALLY PERFORMED ON 2224% OF
AMERICAN CATS. THE CDC THE NIH
AND U. S. PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES
ALL SAY A DECLAWING IS NOT
ADVISED FOR IMMUNO COMPROMISED
PEOPLE IN FACT SUGGESTING THAT
IMMUNO COMPROMISED PEOPLE
DECLARE CATS BY DOING THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS ACTUALLY PUTTING
THESE PEOPLE IN JEOPARDY BECAUSE
DECLAWED CATS BITE MORE IT'S IN
THE SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE AND
BITES ARE WORST AND SCRATCHES.
FINALLY DATA FROM CALIFORNIA
SHELTERS WHERE DECLINE HAS BEEN
BANNED SHOWS THAT THAT
RELINQUISHMENT RATES WENT DOWN
AFTER THE BAND'S WENT INTO
EFFECT DECLAWING IS ILLEGAL IN
MUCH OF THE REST OF WORLD IT
RECENTLY BECAME ILLEGAL IN
MARYLAND AND IT HAS BEEN ILLEGAL
IN NEW YORK STATE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND I HOPE
THAT CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE NEXT
STATE TO BAN IT WITHOUT A
REQUEST YOUR I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THE
ACCOUNT NUMBER CORRECTIVE WE
HAVE YOU ON THE LINE. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN THANKS. GREAT
WELL THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM
CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF THE LA
CITY COUNCIL AND I AUTHORED THE
SUCCESSFUL ANTI D. CALL ON THE
CITY OF LA MORE THAN A DECADE
AGO. THAT ORDINANCE IS GOING TO
BENEFIT BOTH OUR CITY'S CAT
POPULATION AND OUR LARGE ANIMAL
SHELTER SYSTEM. IMPOUNDING OF
CATS IS THE FONG SOME 43% SINCE
WAS ADOPTION. HELPING US ACHIEVE
NEAR NO KILL STATUS THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. AB TWENTY SIX OH
SIX COULD BRING THAT KIND OF
PROGRESS STATEWIDE. AS A MEMBER
OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY I AUTHORED
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ENACTED
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR WHICH
PROHIBITED THE DECLINE OF WILD
OR EXOTIC CATS. EXCEPT FOR
THERAPEUTIC PURPOSES. THE
LANGUAGE CONTAINED IN AB TWENTY
SIX OH SIX IS MODELED ON THAT
BILL. THE PRACTICE OF DECRYING
IS VIEWED BY MANY VETERINARIANS
AND ANIMAL ANIMAL EXPERTS AS AN
ACT OF CRUELTY. THAT WAS
DESCRIBED IT LITERALLY INVOLVES
AMPUTATING PART OF THE CAT'S
PAWS AND CAN CAUSE EXTREME PAIN
AND DISCOMFORT. AND AFTER THE
PROCEDURE CARE HAS TROUBLE
JUMPING A LANDING AND IN SEVERE
CASES BOTH DOMESTIC AND WILD
CATS OF BECOME LEHMAN EVEN
PARALYZED. THE CAPS FOR DEFENSE
MECHANISMS OTHER CLAUSE WHEN
THESE ARE GONE WHAT'S LEFT WITH
THEIR ABILITY TO FIGHT. THE CARD
CAPS REBEL BY BITING AND BY NOT
USING THEIR LITTER BOXES AND
OFTEN WIND UP IN ANIMAL SHELTERS
. I'M LIKE WITH IT AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
OPPOSES THIS BILL. THEY DON'T
OPPOSE MY BILL BECAUSE FEW OF
THEM DECLAWED BIG CAT SO IT
DIDN'T AFFECT THEIR BOTTOM LINE.
ON THE OTHER HAND CAPTAIN LA
WERE DECLINED MOSTLY BECAUSE OF
VETERINARY MARKETING. CAT OWNERS
AN ALLY AREN'T CLAMORING TO
DECLAWED THEIR CAT. AND WE DON'T
RECEIVE COMPLAINTS IN OUR OFFICE
BECAUSE CAN'T CAN'T BE DECLAWED
IN OUR CITY THIS IS A CRUEL AND
UNNECESSARY PRACTICE THE
BENEFITS NO ONE BUT THE VETS
DOING THE SURGERY. WHICH NO
LONGER INCLUDES THE HUGE
VETERINARY CHAIN VCA. IF CAN.
THEIR PROFITS THE WHOLE CRUELTY
OTHER VETS COULD AN SHOULD DO
THE SAME. AND SOME NUMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWENTY SIX CENTS A-
THANK YOU COUNSEL REGRETS- AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO WIN THIS
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
ONE IS DR KEITH ROAD- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN PERSON HERE
TODAY. AND THEN JESSICA C. FOR
MEN WITH THE VET NICK VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD VIA PHONE WHEN WE
START IN THE ROOM- WITH DOCTOR
WROTE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR KEITH
ROADIE I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION'S BOARD OF GOVERNORS
AND ITS PRESIDENT ELECT. I'M A
TWO THOUSAND SIX GRADUATE OF THE
UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE NAY I'M A CO OWNER OF
WOODLAND VETERINARY HOSPITAL
RIGHT BEEN. PRACTICING FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX OH
SIX BASED ON MY LONG STANDING
INVOLVEMENT IN CVM A LEADERSHIP
I CAN ATTEST THAT THE ISSUE OF
KHAKI CLAD HAS INDEED BEEN FRONT
AND CENTER IN OUR ASSOCIATION
FOR MANY YEARS. IN FACT THE CDMA
NOW HAS ONE OF THE STRONGEST YOU
CLASS STATEMENTS OF ANY
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN THE COUNTRY. PURSUANT TO THAT
POLICY THE CDMA STRONGLY
DISCOURAGES OWNERS FROM DECLINE
THEIR CATS AND THE CV MAY
RECENTLY HOSTED TWO WELL
ATTENDED SEMINARS ON
ALTERNATIVES TO DECLAWING CATS.
BUT OUR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
IS NOT ABOUT DECLINE
SPECIFICALLY. I'M NOT PRO
DECLINE I HAVE TWO INDOOR CATS
WERE NOT DECLAWED. AND IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE DOCTORS IN MY
HOSPITAL UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO
STOP IN THE PROCEDURE AT OUR
HOSPITAL. THAT BEING SAID OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THIS BILL IF
SIGNED WOULD CREATE A PRECEDENT
STATUE THAT DIRECTLY IMPACTS OUR
LAWFUL SCOPE PRACTICES
VETERINARY PROFESSIONALS. AND
WOULD DO SO IN A SITUATION WHERE
THE PROFESSIONALS ALREADY SELF
REGULATED MUCH OF THAT DECLINE.
AS TO WHERE IT'S NOW RARELY.
RARELY PERFORMED. IT IS
CONCERNING TO THINK THAT AT ANY
TIME AN OUTSIDE GROUP MAY HAVE
AN AVERSION TO A SIGNIFICANT
SURGICAL PROCEDURE TREATMENT.
THAT GROUP WOULD BE ABLE TO
MEMORIALIZE A BAN. OF THAT
MEDICAL PROCEDURE INTO LAW AND
TRULY THAT GOES FOR ANY HEALTH
PROFESSION NOT JUST VETERINARY
MEDICINE. YOU MAY ASK IF A GOOD
MAJORITY OF AT THE VETERINARY
PROFESSION IS TRENDING AWAY FROM
THE SURGERY THEN WHY NOT JUST
BAN IT. THEN WHAT WE DO AND THE
VERY RARE INSTANCES WHERE WE
HAVE A CLIENT WITH AN AUTISTIC
CHILD IN THE HOUSE AND THE CAT
IS SCRATCHING THAT CHILD. OR
SENIOR CITIZEN WHO LIVES ALONE
AND HAS A CAP TO PROVIDE SOME
WITH COMPANIONSHIP BUT THEY'RE
TAKING COUMADIN OR CHEMOTHERAPY
AND CAN'T RISK BEING SCRATCHED.
SHOULD THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO
RELINQUISH THEIR CATS THE CVM IS
SHORT AND SIMPLE ANSWER IS NO.
AND BOTH OF THE EXAMPLES I JUST
GAVE THE CAT OWNERS WOULD SHOULD
BE COUNSELED ABOUT THE SURGERY
THE WHOLE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
ISSUE SHOULD BE CLOSELY
CONSIDERED AND THE SURGERY
SHOULD BE PERFORMED AS A LAST
RESORT BASED ON THE PROFESSIONAL
JUDGMENT AT THE VETERINARIAN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT AUTHORITY.
NEXT UP- IF WE'VE JUST CÁC FOR
MEN. VIA THE PHONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON ABOUT TRUMP ADMITTED
MEMBERS MY NAME IS UP AT THE
FRONT AND- BACK TO THE DOCTOR
THE BATTERY MEDICAL BOARD. THE
BOARD REGULATE A LARGE
POPULATION VETERINARIANS AND
REGISTERED VETERINARY
TECHNICIANS IN THE NATION. A
PROTECTING AN ANIMAL FIVE.
LICENSEES PROMOTED STANDARDS AND
DILIGENTLY ENFORCING A LETTER
THREATENING MEDICINE THAT.
PUBLIC PROTECTIONISM HIGH. IN
COULD HAVE BEEN QUITE THE RIGHT
THE- FONG. AFTER CUTTING TWENTY
SIX SIX THIRTY ABLE TO TWENTY
TWO. WHERE DOCTORS POSITION AND
GENERAL BOARD MEMBERS AGREED
DECLINE IS NOW LONGER. HE
PERFORM BETTER PROFESSION IS NOT
BE PERFORMED WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION OF THE FACT THAT
THE ANIMAL PATIENTS. ABOUT THE
VISION IS BEST LEFT THE
VETERINARIAN AND ANIMAL OWNERS.
EDITION APPROX ACTIVE NOT. HAVE
A ANY MEDICAL BECAUSE SOMETHING
. BY THEIR WHITE VETERINARIANS
ARE A TO PRACTICE ALL AFTER IN
THE NAME. WITH MISTER. HELLO IN
THE BILL OF RIGHTS. RIDING AND
COMPETENT YOU MADE ME AMERICAN
WITH VETERINARY MEDICINE MEDICAL
PRACTICE AND. REQUIRED HE'S A
PRO HUMANE CARE TOO MANY. THE
STRESS BEFORE DURING AND AFTER
PERFORMED ANYTHING. I MIGHT BE
INDIVIDUAL ARE NOT. HAVING
LICENSE. AND ONE IN THE- MEDIC
PROCEDURE WILL RESULT ECONOMIC
HARM TO. PATIENTS AS- OWNER WILL
FIND OTHER MEANS HAVE THAT.
CLASS BUDGET UNDER WILL HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE PERFORMED BY WANTED TO
THE MIDDLE ARE NOT. TO PERFORM
THE FIRST OR TREATMENT OF PROPER
OPINION. THIRTY THREE THE
AFFORDABLE EIGHTY TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
FOR TO OPEN IT UP TO ANY IN THE
ROOM TODAY. I TO SPEAKING
SUPPORT ON. JUST THIS AN
OPPORTUNE TO PROVIDE YOU NAME.
ANY YOU'RE WITH IF ANY. WHETHER
OR NOT HE'S A OR OPPOSE THE
BILL. IS GOING TO- MAN SANTOS
AGAIN SUPPORT. AB TWO SIX OH SIX
THANK YOU. NICHOLAS SACKETT
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAD MEMBERS JENNY BURKEON
BEHALF OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. JIM CHEN TOLD
PRESIDENT OF- THE DEMOCRATS FOR
THE PROTECTION OF ANIMALS WERE
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. STEPHANIE
MEDRANO WOULD STRAY CAT ALLIANCE
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NOT SEEING ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING TODAY GONNA OPEN IT UP
FOR THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN OF THE
PHONE LINES FOR AB TWENTY SIX OH
SIX. REMINDER THIS IS FOR FOLKS
OF RATHER NAME ORGANIZATION
THERE WITH IF ANY IMPOSITION ON
THE BILL SUPPORTER OPPOSED. ARE
YOU READY FOR THE PHONE MISTER
CHAIR YEAH YES WE'RE READY FOR
THE PHONE JUST FOR ADD ONS LIKE
YOLKS THE BROTHER NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER ANOTHER
SUPPORTER POSTS THANKS.
OUTSTANDING THANK YOU FOR THE
REMINDER OUT LADY JOHN ON THE
PHONE LINES TO SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH THE OUTLINE
FORTY SIX. HELLO CAN YOU GIVE ME
WE CAN- MY NAME IS ALEX BACK AT
THEM SACRAMENTO I THE COURT
EIGHTY EIGHT SIX SIX- AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT AND
I THINK YOU I APPRECIATED OR
JUST TAKE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL RIGHT
NOW THANKS SO MUCH. AND IT IS NO
IT IS LIKE SEVENTY NINE ALL
RIGHT. YES WE GOT A NUMBER OF
THEM MISTER CHAIR THANK YOUNG
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TURN ON YOUR OPEN. ONE MORE SHOT
FOR ONE SEVENTY NINE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY PLEASE THE
MUTE YES- MY NAME IS YOUR NOSE
SO AND THEY SUPPORT THE BILL
THANKS. EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE CALL
AT. BRITISH BOMBER PRESIDENT OF
THE GROUP COMPASSIONATE DAY
CITIZENS OF A GROUP SUPPORTING
ANIMALS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE UNMUTE. ONE MORE SHOT ONE
ONE SIXTY FIVE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
ON YOU. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
YES WE CAN. YEAH HI I AM AGAINST
THE DECLINE MY NAME IS DAN
ABRAMS I AM FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA- I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU YOU KNOW I
DIDN'T ANY EGGS AGENCY CALLING
OKAY THAT'S FOR SURE THANK YOU.
NO PROB THANK SO MUCH THANK YOU
HAVE A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
A PRETTY THEIR. ONE THREE OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DIANE ENABLE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE THREE CAN YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS AND MAKE A CALL ON THE
PORT AB TWO SIX ZERO SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE PROCEDURE
THANK YOU. THREE ELEVEN YOU ARE
UP. HELLO MY NAME IS ROCKY SHALL
FROM RICHMOND CALIFORNIA
FOSTERED DOG AND CAT- AND A
MEMBER OF JELLY FLEET- NO KILL
ANIMAL SHELTER AND- I- STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION STILL
LOOKING FOR A SECOND JUST FOR
COLLEAGUES THERE IT IS. SO I
COME A MILE AWAY. AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE THREE OH SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SHANNON
OTHER FAMILIES NALA CAT AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. PINETREE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALVIN BERNARD I LIVE IN
BURLINGAME CALIFORNIA I'M A
MEMBER OF COMPASSIONATE BAY AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THREE FOURTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS A LONG TERM INVESTOR
CALIFORNIA SOCIAL WORKER AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
EIGHTY FOUR ARE YOU MARRIED
HELLO. HI HI MY NAME IS PAULA
MARTINEZ AND I LIVE IN SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SIX OH SIX. THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO NINETY NINE.
MY NAME IS BRANDY FERTIG FROM
BEAUMONT CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORTIVE FANS. THANK YOU. ONE
THREE FIFTEEN YOU ARE UP. I AM
ALSO FROM SACRAMENTO I'M A BOARD
MEMBER FOR ONLY SUNSHINE ANIMAL
SANCTUARY ANYWHERE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS BELINDA DION FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. PLEASE
GO AHEAD THREE TWENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DR BARBER HAD USED
REPRESENTING THE HUMANE SOCIETY
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND ARE MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. YOU ARE OPEN THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN. HI MY NAME IS
INCLUDING YOUR MORE ON FROM SAN
MATTEO CALIFORNIA AND A STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX OR SIX
THANK YOU. THREE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE CALL AT. HI MY NAME IS
OMAIR KANTOR FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THAT.
THANK YOU. THREE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN I'M
CONSIGNMENT AND EDUCATOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT TWENTY SIX OH SIX THANK
YOU. THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS JENNIFER HAGUE
WITH THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THREE TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU WE WILL PERFORM THE
CREEK THIRTY YEAR GUARDIANS OF
THE HOT CAT. IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO THREE
TWENTY SEVEN. HI JOSE SANDOVAL
WITH THE LATINO ALLIANCE FOR
ANIMAL CARE FOUNDATION BASED IN
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
SIX OH SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOU ARE OPEN THREE TWENTY EIGHT. THREE TWENTY EIGHT. YEAH GO
AHEAD. WOULD YOU LIKE TO TEST
FIVE THREE TWENTY EIGHT. MOVING
ALONG WITH OUR LINE THREE TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU. MY NAME IS BACK
I THINK WE'LL BE DIMAS SHELTER
VETERINARIAN FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND THE FOUNDER OF
NONPROFIT OUR HONOR INVESTMENT
PRACTICE HARMONY AND I SUPPORT
THAT THE- THANK YOU. THREE
THIRTY YOU ARE UP. HI THIS IS DR
SIR STAN ROSENBERG I'M A
VETERINARIAN AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HAPPY HEN ANIMAL
SANCTUARY AND I SUPPORT MYSELF.
THANK YOU. ONE THREE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALICE AND I'M FROM FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THREE THIRTY THREE YOUR OPEN.
HELLO MICHELLE LANG FROM SAN
LEANDRO CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE GIVER AND FOSTER PARENT AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARIANO ARE
YOU BORN IN PIERATA MONTH OR
SEEN SOME COUNTRIES CURRENTLY
STRONGER SUPPORT ISRAEL BUT-
THANK YOU. THREE THIRTY FIVE
HERE OPEN. GARY COOPER CAT
OWNERS STRONG SUPPORTER OF BOB
PROJECT VERY MUCH SUPPORTING AB
TWENTY SIX OH SIX THANK YOU.
THREE THIRTY SIX YOUR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
RAY THOUGHT THAT THE HIGH STREET
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT BILL THANK
YOU. MOVING ON WE WILL GO TO
LINE THREE THIRTY SEVEN YOU'RE
OPEN. HELLO CHRISTINE SO I G.
LONGTIME FOSTER CARE GIVER AND
THE LOS ANGELES RESCUE COMMITTEE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THREE THIRTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. THREE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME CARILLO SAYS
THE STRAY CAT ALLIANCE IN LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU PAUL. THREE
FORTY TWO PLEASE CALL AT. THIS
IS SOMETHING IS A STATE THAT
ALLIANCE TRANSPORT THIS BILL.
THANKS. THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DOCTORS THERE WEST
VETERINARY RADIOLOGISTS IN
TWENTY EIGHT YEAR MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THREE FORTY FOUR. HELLO
JERRY HAIRSTON BRENDA
CENTENARIAN SPECIALIZING IN
ANIMAL CRUELTY WORKING WITH THE
SACRAMENTO ANIMAL CRUELTY TASK
FORCE AND I IN SUPPORT OF THE
SELF. THANK YOU. THREE FORTY
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. HI I'M JOHN
FROHNMAYER A NUMBER OF
COMPASSIONATE DAY IN MENLO PARK
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. A QUICK FINAL REMINDER TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR THIS BILL AB TWENTY SIX OH
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO THREE
FORTY SEVEN. MICHAEL PUTTING
AWAY FROM MY LOS ANGELES. I
STRONG SUPPORT AB TWO SIX OH SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I AM THREE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR UP. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. MY NAME IS
MAKAYLA FROM SAN RAMON. AND I
WAS THE GUARDIAN OF A CAT WE
FOUND DECLINE IN ABANDONED AND I
AM VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU MAKAYLA. THREE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DAVE ANGLE I LIVE IN SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THREE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SALLY
VETO MEMBER OF TI C. IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND NEURO DIVERGENT
WHO GREW UP WITH CATS I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
SIXTY ONE YOU ARE UP. HI MY NAMEIS MELANIE SADEK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SOUTH. THREE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHELLE NEED IN A LONG TIME AND
ALL RIGHT SUPPORTER AND PROMOTE
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MR SHERIFF ARE OUT THERE'S
NO OTHER PARTISAN QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME WONDERFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR OPERATOR BRING IT
BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. STARTING ON THE LEFT
SOME MEMBER LEE. I WANT TO THANK
HIS OTHER CAREER FOR BRING THE
BILL FOR IT I'M PROUD TO BE A
JOINT AUTHORS TO BAN THE
PRACTICE DECLINE. RESPECTFULLY
IF THIS PRACTICE IS ON ITS WAY
OUT I THINK WE SHOULD CLARIFY
THAT AS MORE- COOK CATALONIA
SAID HOMEOWNERS FOR CAT OWNERS
ARE AWARE OF THIS PRACTICE AND
CRUEL INHUMANE IT IS. WE CAN
JOIN CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES
DENVER AND EVEN JOIN STATES LIKE
NEW YORK AND MARYLAND WHICH THIS
WEEK BANDY CALLING SO THERE'S A
CATCH UP TO OTHER STATES AND CAL
FOR ONCE A LEAD ON. ISSUES LIKE
THIS WE HAVE TO PASS THIS BILL
SO HAPPY TO BE A OFFICE MAKE THE
MOTION AND- BUT FOR TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS I THANK
YOU SOMETIME EARLY. AND WEBER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- JUST A QUESTION. TWO
YEARS TO YOUR- SUPPORT WITNESS.
SO IF YOU HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO- HAD A CAT AND TO MEMBER OF
THEIR FAMILY AND THEY END UP.
WITH THE STROKE OR DVT AND
THEY'RE NOW ON BLOOD THINNERS.
HOW DO YOU COUNSEL THEM WHAT DO
YOU OFFER THEM OUTSIDE OF
DECLINING. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND UP DR I'M WHAT WE
WOULD SAY IT WAS YOU CAN KEEP
THE NAILS TRIMMED YOU CAN PUT.
US WHAT'S CALLED SOFT PAWS WHICH
ARE VINYL SHE'S ON THE NAILS
AND- THERE ARE OTHER WAYS THE
REST OF THE WORLD WHO- WHERE.
CAT DECLAWING IS ILLEGAL ARE
CONSIDERED UNETHICAL PEOPLE ARE
LIVING WITH STROKES WERE OR ARE
NEURO DIVERGENT AND THEY ARE
ABLE TO LIVE WITH CATS WITH
CALLS SO JUST BY THE CDC
RECOMMENDS CUTTING THE NAILS.
AND I'M NOT PLAYING WITH THE CAT
WITH THEIR HANDS AND- AT BUT
LEAVING THE CLAWS ON BECAUSE
DECLAWED CATS ABSOLUTELY BITE
MORE. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT. I'M DECLINE
SOUNDS LIKE A VERY YOU KNOW AND
HUMANE OUR PROCEDURE I. IT WAS
HONESTLY VERY MOVED BY YOUR
TESTIMONY- AS ANOTHER SURGEON IT
IS REALLY CHALLENGING TO HAVE
PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF YOUR FIELD. I
DETERMINE WHAT KIND OF SURGERIES
YOU CAN AND CANNOT DO AND- YOU
KNOW AS AN OBGYN WE HAVE HAD
THAT DONE AS WELL- BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT- I THINK HAS
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IS NOT
NECESSARILY- BANNING A PROCEDURE
LIKE STERILIZATION OF YOU KNOW
MINORITY WOMEN BUT ACTUALLY
PUTTING MORE SAFEGUARDS AROUND
IT. SO THAT- PEOPLE ARE VERY
WELL INFORMED OF WHAT THEY'RE
DOING GIVING TIME AND OPTIONS.
AND SO- AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY
BUT I REALLY STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO WORK. WITH OPPOSITION TO
FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S A WAY THAT
YOU CAN STILL ALLOW FOR-
MEDICAL. AND VETERINARIAN-
JUDGMENT TO COME INTO PLAY TO
ALLOW FOR- THEIR OPINION AND
THEM TO BE THE FINAL DECISION
MAKERS IN SOME CASES THAT MAY
BE. YOU KNOW. VERY RARE BUT
STILL ALLOWING THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY- BEFORE COMES TO THE
FLOOR BECAUSE IT IS. THE CALL AS
FROM ONE SURGEON TO ANOTHER. I
FEEL EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR WEBER
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE AS A
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
WAS ACTUALLY HOPING- WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIR THAT OUR
DOCTOR WHO'S ALSO A VETERINARIAN
CAN RESPOND TO THAT. SURE SURE
THAT'S GREAT. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND DR WEBBER- AS A
VETERINARIAN MYSELF. I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT THIS BILL LETS US
CHOOSE WHEN IT IS A THERAPEUTIC.
PURPOSE IT'S A THERAPEUTIC
PURPOSE IF THERE'S A TUMOR IN
THE TOTAL IT'S NOT A THERAPEUTIC
PURPOSE IF THE PEOPLE WANT THE
CAT TO STOP SCRATCHING THE COUCH
. AND I GET THAT BUT I THINK
THERE'S ALSO- LOOKING AT THE
OWNER AND JUST THE ENTIRETY SO
WHEN BRINGING IN SOME OF THESE
VERY RARE KIND OF MEDICAL
CONDITIONS A DISCUSSION BETWEEN
THE- THE VETERINARIAN AND- AND
THE ACTUAL OWNER ITSELF GIVING
THAT. OPTION BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MORE QUESTION FROM
A SUMMER MCCARTY. JUST FOLLOWING
UP I KNOW THIS BILL WAS-
PRESENTED A FEW TIMES BEFORE.
AND ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS WHO
LEADS TO THE FOLLOW UP HERE FROM
DR WEBER'S QUESTION. IT IS IT I
KNOW YOU SAID THE CALLOUS
EXAMPLE AND SOME WOULD SAY THAT
IF YOU DON'T HAVE DECLINE PEOPLE
WOULD ABANDON THEIR PETS MORE
BECAUSE OF THEIR PERSONAL ISSUES
WITH THEIR FURNITURE WHAT HAVE
YOU. BUT WHAT ABOUT THIS EXAMPLE
IF AN INDIVIDUAL FOR THEIR OWN.
YOU KNOW HEALTH REASONS NEEDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE- IN A
SAFE PLACE A PROTECTED ARE WE AT
ALL CONCERNED THAT. THE WE WOULD
LOSE MARC CATS FOR AS FAR AS
ABANDONMENT. YOU DO NOT HAVE
SPECIFIC EXEMPTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER THANK-
SO EVERYWHERE WE BANDY KLEIN
WHICH IS MORE AND MORE PLACES IN
MARYLAND JUST PASSED THE BAN
RECENTLY WE HAVE FOUND. THAT THE
NUMBER OF CAPS RELINQUISH HAS
DECREASED MARKEDLY ANANT AND
COUNCILMEMBER KRETZ EVEN ALLUDED
TO IN LOS ANGELES THE NUMBER
WENT DOWN 43% AND THAT
TRANSLATES TO TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF CATS LIVES SAVED AND IT THE
CONCERNED ABOUT HUMAN HEALTH
REMEMBER THAT. HUMAN HEALTH
AUTHORITIES LIKE THE CDC AND I
H. U. S. PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES
INFECTIOUS DISEASES SOCIETY OF
AMERICA ALL AGREE THAT DECLAWING
IS NOT ADVISED TO PROTECT HUMAN
HEALTH THEY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THAT DECLAWING IS AN ANSWER THEY
BELIEVE COMMONSENSE PRACTICES
ARE AN ANSWER AND PLEASE
REMEMBER THAT IT'S IN THE
LITERATURE THAT DECLAWED CATS.
FIGHT MORE AND A BITE WOUND IS A
FAR MORE SERIOUS INJURY THAT A
SCRATCH. BATCHES THANK YOU. AND
WITH THAT AS A MEMBER CARILLO
YARD CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU- TO THE
MEMBERS FOR THE CONVERSATION- I
WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW IT'S ONE
IT'S INHUMANE IT'S CRUEL BUT YOU
HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER DECLINE
IT'S BEST FOR THE INDIVIDUAL ARE
BEST FOR THE ANIMAL AND WHAT I
HEARD TODAY WAS CONTRADICTING
TESTIMONY FROM THE OPPOSITION
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD HAS ACTUALLY NOT
SUBMITTED AN OFFICIAL LETTER OF.
OPPOSITION AND SO WE HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO ACTUALLY WORK WITH
THEM TO ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT THIS
CONVERSATION IS ARISING AND SO I
DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION AND WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT WE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT. BUT YOU
CAN'T COME TO COMMITTEE AND
OPPOSE SOMETHING WITHOUT HAVING
INFORMED US OF WHAT YOUR
OPPOSITION TO YOUR CONCERNS ARE
AND NOT ACTUALLY SUBMITTING A
LETTER OF OPPOSITION TO ACTUALLY
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST. DECLINE A CAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT THE CAT'S NOT GOING TO
BITE AND SO IF THE CONCERN IS
FOR AN AUTISTIC CHILD OR FOR A
SENIOR CITIZEN THE REALITY MAY
BE THAT HAVING A CAT MAY NOT BE
THE ANSWER WHAT THAT INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS AND THERE ARE OTHER
SOLUTIONS TO THAT AS OUR OWN
VETERINARIAN INTO AND WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. HAS STATED
THERE ARE OTHER ALTERNATIVES TO
NOT HAVING TO DECLAWED CAT
THAT'S NOT SPECIFIC TO THE
HEALTH OF THE CAT OR THE ANIMAL
ITSELF AND SO WHILE THIS BILL
PROHIBITS AN INDIVIDUAL FROM
DECLINE A CAT IT DOES ALLOW FOR
THE NECESSARY SURGICAL
PROCEDURES TO BE PERFORMED ON A
CAT'S PAW FOR DEFINED
THERAPEUTIC PURPOSE AND WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH US LIMBER CREO AND THANK
YOU FOR CHAMPIONING THIS ISSUE
WHICH WHICH I DO UNDERSTAND HAS
A LONG HISTORY. WHILE I
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
TODAY AND WITH THAT MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO THE COMMAND OF PREPARATIONS
BERMAN HI. BERMAN I FLOOR. LOOM
BONTA. AND I'M BLOWN AM I CAN
CUNNINGHAM DALY ANOTHER THING
FONG. IN THE FUNDING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. IRWIN WHEN I
LEE. MAY I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA. MULLIN SALAS- CITING AN
AYE WEBER. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL-
IS OUT WALKING THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WANT TO MAKE A- IT KIND OF-
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT TO
ALL STAFF WATCHING US STAFF OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PLEASE GET
YOUR BOSSES DOWN OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
ONE MORE BILL BY MR JONES SAWYER
I EXPECTED TO BE PRETTY QUICK.
MOVE THE BILL GOT A MOST. GOT A
SECOND. SO WE WERE ADDED AFTER
MR JONES SAWYER PRESENTS IS
BUILT PEOPLE HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
TO ADD ON THE BILL'S BIGGEST
HEALTH COMMITTEE WAS SUPPOSED TO
START SIX MINUTES AGO. MISTER
JONES SAWYER PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO- WHICH IT
SAYS IS A CIVIL PENALTY OF UP UP
TO THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
DAY FOR PROPERTY OWNERS STATE
KNOWINGLY- RIGHT. TO ILLEGAL
CANNABIS OPERATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR DRIVER
THAT IS A GREAT PRESENTATION-
ANY WITNESSES YEAH I KNOW
PRIORITY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
OUR REGION. THE ONLY ONE THAT
MATTERS WE MIGHT HAVE ADD ON SO
WHEN I OPEN IT UP FOR ANYBODY IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WANTS IT-
ADD ON IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU
RESEARCHER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE AFTER SEEING HOW MUCH
TIME. AROUND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE PARENT COMPANY VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MS MARTIN ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ADDING ON TO THIS
BILL SAYING NAH I'M GONNA OPEN
UP FOR THE PHONE LINES. OPERATOR
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE OH TWO- IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN THIS. AB
TWENTY ONE OH TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FIVE
EIGHT ZERO IF THIS TIME. AMATEUR
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP. THANK YOU
MR OPERATOR I THINK THIS MIGHT
BE OUR LAST TIME WITH YOU TODAY
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR A GREAT JOB
DURING A LONG COMMITTEE HEARING-
OPEN UP THE CALL IS QUESTIONS.
MISTER GIBSON MR SORRY PLEASE
ADD ME AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE. YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR. SIGNING
ON GOT A CO AUTHOR REQUEST GOT
EMOTION GOT A SECOND I THINK
RIGHT. YUP ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THING NINE.
MISTER JONES OR WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
HELPING ME DECLAWED. THE ILLEGAL
CANNABIS BUSINESS. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER-
I'VE GOT SOME THINGS I'M
SUPPOSED TO SAY THAT I'M GONNA
FINISH IT WOULD HAVE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. AND MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TOOK ME OPERATIONS
BERMAN HI BERMAN I FLOOR- BLOOM
. M. I. BONTA HI BONTA ACTION.
DALLI DALLI AYE FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON IRWIN
IRWIN KILEY. A. I. MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA. MULLIN
FOLLOW US SALAS I TEN WEBER. IN
TEN AYE WEBER AYE. THE BILLS OUT
IT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU WITH
SOME OVER JONES SAWYER MIDI. SO
WITH THAT FOLKS HAVE FIVE
MINUTES LITERALLY FIVE MINUTES
Y'ALL WE'RE STARTING THE CLOCK.
THEY COME DOWN AT ON THE BILL'S
- BUT WE WILL START THE PROCESS
BECAUSE I KNOW SOME FOLKS ARE
HERE ALREADY NEED TO ADD ON THE
SOME BILLS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SECRETARY WERE READY WHENEVER
YOU ARE. TO RUN THROUGH THE
BILL'S. PERCENT YEAH PLEASE. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. LARA BONTA
AYE BONTA AYE LEE MAY I MCCARTY. MCCATY I AIN'T MULLIN. AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO GIPSON FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE LARA BONTA HI
BONTA I LEE. MAY I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB EIGHTEEN ANYONE
SANTIAGO BONTA I BONTA I.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. FIND A NUMBER
FOR AB EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR
RIVAS LARA BONTA I BONTA I.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE IT MULLIN.
PHONE NUMBER. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWO TWO ONE ZERO CORK
FLORA. WE'RE BILL GEN I'M SEVEN. ARE NOT VOTING BONTA HI BONTA
I. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWO
TWO TWO FOUR MCCARTY BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE LEE. I MULLIN. FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWO THREE
TWO TWO WOULD BONTA. I BONTA I
MULLIN. WELL I DON'T NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWO SIX OH SIX CARILLO
FLORA. LARA NOW CHEN. GRAYSON
MEDINA MULLIN. TWENTY SIX A SIX
IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
US MEMBERS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
ONE BNP COMMITTEE A FLOOR. FLOOR
AYE BONTA. AYE BONTA AYE LEE MAY
I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR BNP
FLORA. OUR I. BONTA HI BONTA I
LI LI I MCCARTY. SORRY I MULLIN. AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
BEING P. BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I AM ALL IN. AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN BNP
BONTA. I WANT TO I MCCARTY
FRIDAY I MULLIN. MAN FILE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
ONE WOOD BONTA HI BONTA I.
MCCARTY. AN OPENING MULLIN. OKAY
MULLIN I.
AB TWENTY SIX ANYONE SALAS NOT
VOTING THÀNH. FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
BAR CAN BONTA. I BONTA I MULLIN. MONNING.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA RUN THROUGH ONE MORE TIME-
BECAUSE WE STILL GOT A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE IN THE THAT ON- AND THIS
WILL BE THE LAST ROUNDS OR
ANYBODY ELSE IS NOT HERE. SO
SORRY. YEAH ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FLORA FLOOR AYE MULLIN
ON- AB SIXTEEN SIXTY FIFTH
GIPSON LARA NOBODY. MULLIN.
ONE
A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR RIVAS
MULLIN. ON. AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO
JONES SAWYER FLORA. RIGHT OUR.
FLOOR I. TEN GRAYSON MEDINA
MULLIN. AB. TWENTY SIX NINETY
ONE. I WOULD GIPSON. I WILL GIVE
THE AUTHOR OF THAT BILL OCCURS
THE VOTE AND- LOOK FOR HIM TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD. THAT
BILLS OUT. BACK TO AB TWENTY ONE
ONTO JONES SAWYER GRAYSON MEDINA
MULLIN MONNING. AB TWENTY TWO
TEN QUIRK. MULLIN. ONE AB TWO
TWO TWO FOUR MCCARTY. ONE ONE
NINE- UNABLE TO. AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWO. WOOD MULLIN. ONE A.
B. TWENTY SIX OH SIX CARILLO
CHEN GRAYSON MEDINA MULLIN. ON.
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE B. IN
PIEDMONT. BERMAN. AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY FOUR BNP MONTH. AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE THE IN PIEDMONT
. ONE I WE TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN BNP MULLIN. ON I. AB
TWENTY SEVEN. THEY WERE. AND
WITH THAT THERE IS A TURN.